Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Hallo?
Test, Test.
Kunst.
Ich dachte mir, ich könnte mal wieder streamen so am Sonntagmorgen.
Habe ich ja jetzt bestimmt schon
drei Monate oder so nicht gemacht.
Oh ich bin noch müde.
Und Twitch zeigt mal wieder nicht die Viewer an.
Hyper Gachi, jawoll.
Gachi Roll.
Oh ich muss erstmal aufwachen.
Aber es ist ja Aufwachen-Stream.
Und Leute,
los geht's.
Ich frage jetzt nicht,
was habe ich verpasst.
Weil die letzten Monate
schon einiges,
war ja einiges.
Ich war...
Ich hab ja einmal gestreamt vor...
vor knapp einer Woche oder so.
Zum ersten Mal seit ein paar Monaten wieder.
Ich will jetzt Tee trinken, ja.
War gestern im Museum.
Eigentlich übelst langweilig.
Aber...
war dann doch ganz nice.
Im Senckenberg Museum in Frankfurt.
Falls auch schon mal wer gewesen ist.
Da gibt es Dinosaurier-Skelette.
Oder wahrscheinlich
3D-gedruckte
Dinosaurier-Skelette.
Ja, war eigentlich ganz nice.
Müsste ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
jedes Wochenende hin.
aber kann man sich mal angucken
ich hab pennt bis 8 uhr 30 ich bin jetzt eigentlich schon fast eine stunde auf
aber ich habe den fehler gemacht ich bin liegen geblieben und habe youtube zeug
geguckt und da wirst du nicht richtig wach bei ich bin dann erst aufgestanden ich hatte
einfach video video angemacht irgendwie war das so ein mach nicht wirklich ein let's play
und multiplayer let's play keine ahnung und auf einmal normalerweise gucke ich so was nicht weil
das viel zu viel zu weiß ich kann mir die meisten let's player nicht angucken ja aber irgendwie habe
ich gedacht mach einfach mal zum wach werden und auf einmal schreien da irgendwie die let's
player rum ich verstehe das nicht es ist also ich kann mir nicht weiß ich wie es euch geht
aber ich kann mir die meisten let's plays nicht angucken ich weiß nicht warum wieder einfach
random rumschreien müssen irgendwie let's plays wenn überhaupt nichts passiert
aber ich irgendwie habe ich ein eindruck so dieser ultra hype um let's plays wie
es damals bei sich 2012 oder so gewesen ist wo sehr gefühlt auf einen schlag drei
spieljahren let's play kanal gibt ist vorbei heute ist es so standard so die
leute gucken halt ab und zu mal let's play und also alles nicht so dass
irgendjemand jetzt sagt ich gucke jetzt jedes let's play jedes video von diesem
channel leute gucken sich halt wenn er mal irgendwie ab und zu verfolgen dann
muss ich auch sagen ist ja zum größten teil auch echt langweilig gibt ein paar
let's player die kann ich mir angucken aber großartig dass ich gucke eigentlich
so selten let's plays
guck lieber auf twitch
ich mache jetzt mal kurz package updates was ist mit sport noch fleißig
letzten monat bisschen weniger letzten monate nicht so viel ich habe richtig
viel gemacht hat wieder quasi laut meiner garmin app hatte ich wieder neue
bestzeit in mir wobei ich immer so glaube die garmin app übertreibt ein
bisschen so zur motivation aber jetzt habe ich schon ein paar monate kaum noch
was gemacht so zwei monate wieder groß
jürgen kurs joggen noch fahrradfahrt dabei war jetzt eigentlich richtig gute
zeit dafür so im sommer ja ich habe das letzten stream erzählt dass ich gerade
ein bisschen Motivationsprobleme habe.
Habt ihr auch einen Hiring Freeze oder wie sieht es bei euch aus? Ne, haben wir nicht. Bei uns gibt
es Stellen und letztens habe ich gehört, es wird demnächst sogar noch deutlich mehr Stellen wieder
geben.
Das liegt aber, also das ist jetzt nix,
wo man sich irgendwas für ganz Deutschland oder so
draus ableiten kann, nur weil das bei uns so ist.
Bei uns ist halt einfach
gerade so im
Versicherungs
das
Gewerbe, keine Ahnung.
Das sind halt viele Leute bei uns,
die sind schon irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
100, 150 Jahre dabei und gehen
jetzt demnächst mal in Rente und deswegen werden viele Stellen frei.
Machen wir mal Update hier. Deswegen werden viele Stellen frei und da gibt es dann neue.
Also sprich, bei uns gibt es weder einen Hiring Freeze noch irgendwie was
anderes, was in die Richtung aussieht. Es wird demnächst eher mehr. Das heißt aber
natürlich nichts für alle anderen ja ich war vor einer woche schon mal da
aber nicht sonntag sondern random unter der woche irgendwann
nur von am gehen es könnte aber auch an den pillen liegen
da steht eine nebenwirkung drin die verursachen gehen
aber ich glaube eher das liegt daran weil ich es aufgestanden bin so jetzt machen wir hier
erst mal updates update ist post weiter ist running weiter ist recht weiter ist
ist running ist korrekt jetzt ist aber jetzt ist aber nicht mehr running jetzt macht das okay
dass das chat brad steuers funktioniert in der regel dann geht es wieder youtube videos
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht ich habe ja ehrlich gesagt bisschen drauf spekuliert
dass mir Battlefield 6 gefällt
und ich kann nicht sagen
ob es mir gefällt oder nicht gefällt
weil ich hab's nicht gespielt
die Beta
ich wollte die Beta spielen
ich hab's sogar schon runtergeladen
nee installiert hab ich's nicht mehr
nee
ah Battlefield 3 hab ich nur installiert
also
ich hab's sogar installiert
und dann
dachte ich mir so, ah ja, startest du es mal und da kam ein Popup, dass es nicht geht,
weil ich Secure Boot nicht aktiviert habe.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, warum, was ist das, was wollen die von mir?
Bis ich da mal nachgeguckt habe, die haben hier Battlefield 6 Secure Boot.
ich brauche kein guide um secure zu aktivieren zumindest sind sie der meinung das geht nur noch
mit secure boot weil anti cheat nein nein
Okay.
Diese Checks sind so dumm, Alter.
So, weil die haben jetzt den
krassen Javelin-Anti-Cheat
anscheinend. Also ist nicht mehr...
Wie hieß das? Wie hieß das letzte?
Easy-Anti-Cheat hieß das davor,
was sie davor hatten, gell?
als Teil unserer Bemühungen für positives Spiel.
Moment, was zum...
Okay, Moment.
Das ist bestimmt einfach nur schlecht übersetzt.
Positives Spielen.
Positives Spielen für EA ist, wenn man möglichst viel Kempel kauft.
Ultra Mega Hyper Deluxe Edition.
Und dann noch 20 Season Passes und alles mögliche an Skins.
Und die sagen zumindest, dass man Secure Boot braucht.
damit ihr Anti-Cheat ordentlich funktioniert.
Und ich kann keinen Secure Boot aktivieren,
auf meiner Kiste, zumindest aktuell nicht,
weil ich mein ganzes System,
und das habe ich schon Jahre,
habe ich verschlüsselt mit VeraCrypt,
einfach, dass man Festplatten wegschmeißen kann,
hauptsächlich die Gründe, dass man Festplatten wegschmeißen kann,
selbst wenn sie kaputt sind,
und dann ist es halt unrecoverable.
Das heißt, ich hätte jetzt erstmal mein System decrypten müssen und sonst was.
Da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Deswegen bin ich mir noch gar nicht so sicher, was ich mache.
Ich habe mal geguckt, ob man Veracrypt mit Secure Boot verwenden kann.
Das geht nicht. Die haben keinen gesigneten Bootloader.
Dann habe ich mir überlegt, ich könnte mir...
Vielleicht hat hier irgendjemand Ahnung von euch davon.
Kann ja sein. Wir haben ja hier jede Menge...
high iq leute dann habe ich mir überlegt man könnte ja einen usb stick machen zum
booten mit keine ahnung eventuell irgend etwas drauf oder momentan ist
irgendwas drauf mit einem gesagten bootloader falls man so was auf die reihe
kriegt kann man vom usb stick booten und von dort dann quasi rüber hoppen in den
vera club bootloader da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher ob das funktioniert in
wie weit diese secure boot sache das von windows ob checkt ob das wieder gut vorgang ich habe keine
ahnung ob das funktioniert die einfachste variante dürfte wahrscheinlich sein ich die crypto mein
volume mit vera crypt und benutzt locker wobei bit locker bei mir unten durch ist ich kann es
wahrscheinlich stichhaltig begründen der grund warum bit locker bei mir unten durch ist weil
weil ganz am Anfang, als BitLocker neu war,
also BitLocker ist diese Festplattenverschlüsselung von Microsoft,
seit glaube ich Windows 8 oder Windows 10,
gibt 10 Gramm, ja,
und eine der ersten Meldungen, die ich gelesen habe,
über BitLocker war,
wenn man sein Passwort vergessen hat,
kann man das irgendwie restoren oder recoveren
mit irgendeinem Passwort-Recover-Verfahren,
frag ich.
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht kennt ihr,
Ist das noch so? Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal von aus.
Und da muss ich halt sagen, eine Festplattenvollverschlüsselung mit Passwort-Recovery-Funktion ist irgendwie bedenklich.
Weil das heißt ja, der Zugang ist irgendwo anders, ist quasi der Key zum Entschlüsseln gespeichert.
Das sehe ich nicht ein. Warum?
Ich meine, wenn ich meine Festplatte voll verschlüssele, dann soll die halt gefälligst auch voll verschlüsselt sein.
und ich habe mein Passwort im Kopf und nicht Microsoft bei sich irgendwie rumliegen oder sowas.
Das ist das erste, eines der ersten Sachen, die ich über BitLocker gelesen habe
und seitdem war BitLocker bei mir unten durch.
Weil das, finde ich, komplett dem Prinzip von Festplatten oder generell Vollverschlüsselung widerspricht,
wenn es eine Möglichkeit des Restores gibt.
Ich verstehe, dass das für irgendwelche Business-Enterprise-Sachen gewollt ist,
Ja, wenn dann irgendwie irgendeine HR-Mitarbeiterin ihr Notebook dreimal falsches Passwort eingibt, dass es gesperrt ist und was recovert, keine Ahnung, aber ich will das nicht.
Weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht.
Wollt ihr eine Festplattenvollverschlüsselung, wo man ein Passwort recoveren kann?
Was ja im Endeffekt heißt, dass irgendjemand anderes da Zugriff drauf hätte.
weil euer Passwort, oder sagen wir mal
wahrscheinlich die eigentlichen
Keys, das ist ja bei Festplatten
Vollverschlüsselung so
dass nicht das Passwort wirklich zum Verschlüsseln
verwendet wird, sondern
es werden Keys
zum Verschlüsseln verwendet, die wiederum
mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt sind
das wollt ihr auch nicht
so und das ist das erste, also vielleicht ist es
übelst Fake News, die ich verbreite, das ist
gar nicht mehr so bei BitLocker
aber
Am Anfang war das bei BitLocker so.
Wir können ja mal googeln danach.
BitLocker.
Passwort restore.
Ja, ja.
Restore, you must first unlock the drive using your recovery key, which can be found in your Microsoft...
Hey, hey, hey.
Alles klar.
Na gut, na gut.
Come on.
Okay.
Vielleicht, also, erst einmal keine Ahnung, ob diese KI-Antwort überhaupt stimmt.
Aber wenn diese Antwort stimmt, vielleicht gibt es ja auch die Möglichkeit, das nicht im Microsoft-Account zu speichern.
Sondern nur auf dem USB-Drive, Textfile oder halt auch Zweifelsfall gar nicht.
Das Ding ist nur
Warum ich BitLocker immer noch nicht traue
BitLocker ist halt Closed Source
Du weißt nicht wirklich was es macht
Manch einer würde sagen
Das driftet jetzt vielleicht schon Richtung Verschwörungstheorie ab
So nach dem Motto
Ah ob Microsoft da nicht doch irgendwas speichert
Aber mal ganz im Ernst
Könnt ihr euch dran erinnern?
Oder erinnert ihr euch dran
Was du bei einer Windows Installation alles an
Matrix und sonst was
Abwählen musst bei der Installation
und was Microsoft da mit ihrem komischen, wie ist das, Recall oder sowas,
mit was automatisch Screenshots macht von einem Desktop und unverschlüsselt speichert und sowas.
Also ganz ehrlich, traue ich Microsoft wirklich, dass sie das ordentlich machen bei einer Software,
wo keiner überprüfen kann, außer Microsoft selbst, was er macht? Also ich nicht.
Deswegen bin ich eigentlich ein großer Fan von TrueCrypt, beziehungsweise jetzt VeraCrypt gewesen.
Das habe ich seit, keine Ahnung, über 10 Jahren habe ich das schon.
Also ganz lange benutze ich das, wie gesagt, hauptsächlich, da ich Festplatten wegschmeißen kann.
Und ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock BitLocker zu verwenden, auch nicht für Battlefield 6.
Die sind lokal und nicht bei Microsoft.
Kann man sich denn wirklich sicher sein, dass die nur lokal sind und nicht bei Microsoft?
Antwort kommt von der KI.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Aber ich finde die Google-Antworts-KI ist meistens gar nicht so übel.
Die AI sagt das.
Na gut.
Bei Nutzung eines Microsoft-Kontos wird ein separater 48-Stelle-Automanager-Cloud gespeichert.
Ja.
Ist aber nur für den Kontoinhaber zugänglich.
ja gut das sagen die ob das wirklich so ist keine ahnung also ob die das
wirklich so verschlüsseln dass sie kein kinder also dass sie das selbst was da
drin kein schimmer das ist halt das ding bei so fertigen
close source produkten das ist genauso wie bei allen möglichen vpn anbietern
und sowas die sagen immer alle viel wenn der tag
lang ist vertraut man den wirklich komplett dass es so ist also ich nicht
ja genau
das kann ich auch bei jedem update ändern die sagen ist ja also ganz ehrlich
Ich traue MS da nicht wirklich.
Was? Keg? Keg?
Wie? Das Emote gibt es nicht mehr?
Warum gibt es das nicht mehr?
Was ist da los?
Warum gibt es kein Keg Browse mehr?
Hier waren die Modes gelöscht.
Was ist die Alternative?
Werra Crypt ist der Nachfolger von True Crypt.
Das Problem ist, weshalb wir da überhaupt drauf gekommen sind, dass immer mehr Anti-Cheat-Software Secure Boot will.
Und Secure Boot funzt mit Veracrypt nicht.
Das ist halt ziemlicher Sack.
Also.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade noch nichts gescheites ein.
Ja.
den unterschied wie sieht's aus synchrone verschlüsselung als im grunde verschlüsselung
was was da der unterschied ist vielleicht auch mal wie so ein asynchroner ki austausch funktioniert
und so was das da aber da ist wikipedia nicht schlecht gibt sicherlich auch jede
Menge gute YouTube Videos dazu.
Riot funzt schon fast alles auf
Linux ohne Secure Boot.
Ist das so? Kann man mittlerweile Valorant auf Linux
spielen? Ne, oder?
Die haben doch auch irgendwelches Kernel-Anti-Cheat-
Gedöns, was nicht unter Linux funktioniert.
oder nicht mehr das arch wiki ist wenn man wissen will wie man es dann macht
unter unter anstellung ist natürlich auch gut ja
ach so da ist so quasi einen koma es soll heißen außer ei und freie ich habe
ich habe gelesen außer ei und bei so nach dem und bei ryan funs schon alles
Was schon mitbekommen war bei Call of Duty mit Voraussetzungen für Anti-Cheat.
Viele können einfach gar nicht mehr spielen, weil so eine bescheuerte Art von TPM benutzt wird.
Ne, habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Wieso? Was machen die?
Die machen sicherlich auch mal mindestens Secure Boot mittlerweile.
Ja, Algorithmen verstehen.
Obwohl, der heißt ja gar nicht mehr so.
Der Florian, der hat auch gute Videos zu dem Thema.
Ist ein...
Fake!
Alles fake!
Wenn ein TPM-Chip auftritt,
ist kannst nicht spielen weil die tpm plus moment die benutzen so modernes
art ist aber modern ist jetzt ja irgendwie so das positiv an oder so so
modernes anti cheat dass man den bios update machen muss zum spielen
alle so langsam irgendwie ich weiß mir geht es ja seit jahren schon ein
bisschen auf den sack aber das ist jetzt schon übertrieben dass der erste mal
vor dem spiel spielen was ein bios update machen muss also komm jetzt
theoretisch geht das ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch keine anleitung gefunden die
vertrauenswürdig aussieht so als wird es danach auch noch alles funktioniert
also das will ich nicht was ich mir überlegt habe ist ich habe ja noch
einige m2 slots wartet mal ich muss diesen läuft schon die nase hat hier
ganz seinem aufstehen
was wollte ich jetzt sagen ja also da weiß ich nicht keine ahnung
dass also dass keine anleitung wo ich denke dass es danach noch funktionieren
würde was ich mir überlegt habe ich habe noch zwei freie m2 slots bei mir auf
mainboard ich habe überlegt ob ich mir nicht einfach nur eine zweite ssd rein
mache und dann in gaming auch die windows drauf installiere wo ich mich
weder irgendwelche passwörter credentials passwLAN irgendwas einfach
einfach nur zu spielen ja das habe ich mir überlegt das könnte man machen
ich glaube sogar ich habe irgendwo noch eine 1 oder hier ist doch hier liegt
doch was hier liegt doch was hier liegt doch eine ssd keck wait die habe ich warum hab leute
ich habe hier übelst random einfach ne 1 terabyte 990 pro m2 ssd liegen hier auf meinem bastel
basteltisch was macht die da warum habe ich die was wollte ich denn da machen mit dieser
original verpackt dieser original verpackt gibt man da irgendwie war man
die gekauft hat vielleicht modellversion modell sieht man nicht
keine ahnung hatte denn hatte denn die war das nicht so leute dass die 990 pro
ssd hatte die nicht irgendein firmware back wo man aktualisieren musste war da
nicht was
du wolltest sie im stream verlaufen ja ganz bestimmt oder wo man nicht
aktualisieren ja doch hier guckt da aber ich hab die ich habe die bestimmt nach
2023 gekauft samsung behebt rapiden verschleiß paar firma update die für
die sache soll ich schnell sinken ins smart wert wie man schnelles update wird
empfohlen ja ich habe meine meine system erst das die habe ich geupdatet aber ob
ich die hier noch update muss kommen also ich denke mal die ist zu neu die
ssd die ich hier habe die wird das nicht haben aber ich kann natürlich einfach
abdecken das ist richtig da muss ich secure boot an und ausschalten
naja gut ist dann halt so
oder ich benutze doch bitlocker oder ich krieg doch irgendwie hin vera crypt
secure zu booten mit irgendeinem bootloader mit sitem bootloader auf usb
stick oder so keine ahnung das ist alles irgendwie kacke
also secure boot pro platte einstellen ich glaube das kann man nur allgemein
eine ausschalten im bios oder gibt es so was gibt es eine option kennt jemand
option pro platte nicht ob das gibt es nicht glaubt kannst du einen ausschalten
Hast du auch das Problem mit Secure Boot?
Bäm.
Oder Bäm.
Oder weshalb hast du nicht gespielt?
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde drauf tippen, dass sie das auch machen.
Oder es ist ihnen zu teuer.
Secure Boot ist doch im Mainboard
Ja, aber trotzdem könnte es ja vielleicht eine Logik geben
Es wird
Enforced auf dieser Disk und auf dieser nicht
Läuft Linux auch nur ohne
Secure Boot? Also Linux ist tatsächlich auch
Außer Ubuntu, die haben gesagt, ein Bootloader
Ist gar nicht so einfach
Linux zum Laufen zu bekommen
Gibt es einen riesig langen
ArchWiki
Secure Boot
also gehen tut das ist aber in der tat nicht ganz so easy ja das ist der artikel
zur secure boot by the way arch by the way
cash ios wenn das easy ist heißt es die verwenden wahrscheinlich den ubuntu
bootloader der ist ja gesign
also wie gesagt ich habe noch keine einladung gefunden dafür die der ich traue was das problem
mit secure boot da hatten wir es gerade von das problem mit secure boot ist dass mittlerweile
es anti cheat gibt das nur funktioniert noch mit secure boot und ich secure boot aktuell
nicht aktivieren kann, weil ich meine
Festplatten voll verschlüsselt habe mit
VeraCrypt.
Und ich irgendwie umsteigen müsste. Also entweder
komplett entschlüsseln
oder halt
BitLocker oder irgendwie sowas verwenden.
BitLocker habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock.
Ja.
Ich habe letztens ein Video erst gesehen, wo sie
wieder eine manipulierte Maus hatten mit
Arduino Controller dran und sowas.
Ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Ja, das Eventoy hat das auch.
Dieses Einmalklicken.
Für Veracrypt gibt es das leider nicht.
Das ist doch die Geschichte mit einer PCI-Express-Karte,
die RAM ausliest für Cheats, gell?
Das habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt.
Da baust du eine PCI-Express-Karte.
Also da gibt es...
ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher wie das war die die leute haben ein netzwerk gerät eingebaut
was ich glaube ich als netzwerkkarte oder so und windows angemeldet hat und da konnte dann
quasi ram auslesen unter anderem halt auch ram von einem game und dann brauchst du einen posten
einen zweiten PC oder halt
irgendeinen Microcontroller,
der diese Informationen dann verwendet,
der dann beispielsweise
erkennt,
du bist jetzt mit deinem Cursor
über dem Kopf vom Gegner in CS
und der klickt dann für dich die Maus
und sowas. Da ist ja quasi, du verbindest dann auch
einen Controller mit deiner Maus oder du hast dann
einen, nicht mit der Maus,
du hast dann einen Controller,
also einen Microcontroller, der sich als Maus
anmeldet und sowas. Ganz abgedrehte
Sachen mit Hardware-Sheets.
normaler pc wie gesagt der hauptsächliche grund warum ich meine festplatten verschlüssel ist dass
ich wegschmeißen kann willst du wirklich eine festplatte wegschmeißen in müll die
deine passwörter credentials wlan wlan zugänge und alles mögliche enthält also ich nicht
Und ich weiß, jetzt sagt irgendjemand, dann löscht sie doch vorher
Aber es gibt ja auch
Die Situation, dass du die Festplatte nicht mehr richtig löschen kannst
Vielleicht weil sie kaputt ist
Ja, also
Das habe ich mir auch
Tatsächlich, das habe ich mir auch
Das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt
Ja
Das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, aber ich verwende ja kaum noch
magnet festplatten sondern ssds und da bin ich mir nicht sicher wie man ssds
richtig zerstört da bräuchte ich irgendwie so ein häcksler oder sowas
genau irgendwie sowas bräuchte ich dann
zur text
Ich habe schon ewig, wie gesagt, ich hatte auch schon True Crypt im Einsatz, als es das noch gab.
Ich glaube, ich habe meine Festplatten schon voll verschlüsselt, seit ich damals, glaube ich, in der CT damals.
Also, ihr könnt euch überlegen, wie lange das her ist, als ich noch auf dem Klo CT gelesen habe.
Ich hatte im Prinzip das CT-Abo nur, da ich auf dem Klo damals was zu lesen hatte.
da habe ich damals einen artikel darüber gelesen über truecrypt und da habe ich mir gedacht boah das ist ja nice
und seitdem habe ich meinen pc voll verschlüsselt das ist schon das ist schon ewig her ich glaube das ist sogar noch länger her als ich youtube angefangen habe
gucken wir mal wann truecrypt rausgekommen ist
Ja, 2004.
Ja gut, 2004 werde ich es nicht gleich verwendet haben, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie 2007 oder sowas oder 2008.
Weil ich habe mir schon immer Gedanken gemacht, was ist, wenn du Hardware wegschmeißt?
Das ist ja auch der Grund, das ist auch, wo die Leute immer sagen, hier Max, wozu braucht man sowas?
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich für mein WLAN DPSK verwende.
Da kannst du für jedes WLAN-Gerät ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort vergeben.
Und jetzt nicht etwa wie bei WPA Enterprise, wo das Gerät das unterstützen muss.
Ne, ne, für das Gerät sieht das aus wie ganz normales WLAN.
SSID eingeben,
beziehungsweise auswählen und ein Passwort eingeben,
nur, dass das Passwort
im Access Point gemappt
ist zu dem Device. Also jedes
WLAN-Device kann ein
eigenes WLAN-Passwort bekommen, für das
gleiche WLAN wohlgemerkt.
Und das ist halt mega nice. Ich habe so viele
kleine
China-Chinesen-IoT-Geräte,
die auch Microcontroller und sonst was,
die öfters mal kaputt
gehen.
und da habe ich mir auch am anfang überlegt was ist denn wenn du mal irgendwie so eine
typische oder zwischenstecker oder so wenn du den in den müll schmeißt dann ist ja streng
genommen dein wlan passwort da noch drauf kriegst das ja auch nicht gescheit gelöscht
das da bräuchte ich auch wieder einen shredder ja es ist höchst unwahrscheinlich dass das jemals
probleme macht also selbst wenn ich ich meine und muss das ja auch mal
realistisch sehen wenn ich die klüger in den müll schmeißen wird jetzt nicht mal
nachbar hingehen die klüger rausholen da irgendwie mit riesen auswand das
wlan-passwort auslesen um sich dann in mein wlan einzuloggen das ist ja bescheuert ja
das wird ja nicht passieren aber allein schon die möglichkeit dass
mein wlan-passwort quasi unverschlüsselt im müll liegt gefällt
mir nicht deswegen habe ich auch mittlerweile so was hier am start und
jedes neue WLAN-Gerät kriegt
ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort.
Das ist halt, das ist mega nice.
Also, du kannst
vor allem,
kannst du damit dann auch
richtig gut Gästezugang und sowas machen.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwie Gäste bei mir hätte
oder so.
Andere Menschen kommen ja nicht ins Haus hier.
Ist Mikrowelle safe?
Kein Schimmer.
SSD in den Ofen?
Ja, danach stinkt mein Ofen und ich kann den nicht mehr für was anderes benutzen.
Das ist doch auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache, oder?
Kann man die GitHub-Links teilen zu Veracrypt?
Äh, Veracrypt, gibt's das auf GitHub?
Kannst du aber machen, ruhig.
Ja.
Musst du dann immer ein Passwort extra eingeben?
Wenn ich meinen Rechner boote, muss ich einmal ein Passwort eingeben.
Aber das Passwort tippe ich ja quasi schon seit 15 Jahren oder so.
Das ist auch relativ lang.
Also jetzt nicht, dass ich 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 hätte.
Relativ lang und kompliziert das Passwort, aber das kann ich mittlerweile im Schlaf tippen.
und
das tippe ich einmal ein beim Booten
und dann ist das entsperrt und
Pfunz.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ich sage halt
immer Disk. Ich sage zu allem Disk.
Egal ob es eine SSD ist oder eine Festplatte.
Eine klassische.
Ja.
Ja, das muss...
Kannst du...
Wie gesagt, brauchst du irgendwie...
Irgendwie...
Lager musst du irgendwie im Garten Feuer machen oder so.
Und dann einmal im Monat verbrennst du dann alle alte Hardware oder wie.
Das darfst du wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Moment, das ist nicht VeraCrypt, sondern das ist irgendein extra VeraCrypt Bootloader, was
du da gepostet hast.
Das ist...
Weiß ich nicht.
Irgendwas, was ich nicht ausprobieren will.
Sieht nicht so aus als funst das zuverlässig.
Ist das Passwort dann zur MAC-Adresse gemappt? Ja.
Aber, also das funktioniert so.
Diese Sache mit WLAN-Passwort pro Gerät.
Du gehst in einen Access-Point rein.
Ich kann es euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen, weil ich ja auch mal einen Test-Access-Point nicht da habe.
Also, du gehst in den Access-Point rein.
Sagst, wobei ich kann ja aber ein Screenshot von zeigen.
Wir haben noch hier ganz gute Docs.
Alter, das ist Werbung.
Keck, wait.
Hey, guck mal, da gibt es sogar ein Video.
Da gibt es sogar ein Video zu, wie du das findest.
Also, du gehst in der nächsten...
Alter.
Nee, das ist das Falsche.
Naja, wurscht.
naja gibt es wieder keine
hier
da sieht man es
da trägst du
drückst du auf hinzufügen
trägst
ein erstmal einfach nur ein Passwort
und sobald
ein Gerät sich zum ersten Mal
verbindet in das
WLAN
Äh.
Das bleibt schmelzen.
Heck, wait. Ja, ist klar.
Sobald sich ein Gerät zum ersten Mal verbindet mit diesem neuen Passwort,
dann merkt er sich die MAC Adresse von dem Gerät
also du musst nicht etwa die MAC Adresse vorher abtippen
und dann ist das auch gelockt auf dieses Gerät
das Gerät kann sich dann nur noch mit diesem Passwort einloggen
so und wenn du das Gerät dann irgendwann mal wegschmeißt
der Gerät, wenn der Gerät im Müll landet
dann gehst du einfach in deine Access Point Oberfläche
und löscht dieses Passwort und das war's
also selbst wenn irgendeiner da die MAC Adresse spooft oder so
bringt ihm das nix
weil das passwort ist ja weg
scowal danke für den sub exzellente subscription hier easy clap
die festplatten erst dann verschlüsseln bevor man sie wegwirft dann könnte man
sie auch einfach mit nullen überschreiben
man muss ja davon ausgehen dass eine festplatte kaputt ist und man sie
deswegen wegschmeißt. Aber ist immer noch
restorebar. Und du hast alle deine Passwörter
noch unverschlüsselt drauf.
Braucht man da nur einen Access Point, der das
unterstützt? Ja, du brauchst einen Access Point, der das
unterstützt. Und mittlerweile ist es so,
dass die
meisten Hersteller der etwas
besseren Access Points das können.
Es kann sogar
Ubiquiti kann das mittlerweile sogar.
habe ich gelesen ich habe kein ich habe kein univer mehr im einsatz also ruckus
war da so ziemlich mit als erstes heißt nicht unbedingt dps k es gibt auch noch
gibt noch andere namen dafür er open vrt und so kann das auch
ja manche manche dennoch auf pps k genau mps k ja guck hier private pre-shared keys kann
unifile mittlerweile auch ich weiß nicht wie gut das funst wie keine ahnung wie gut das bei
bei Unify-Fonds. Aber
man kann es, gerade für
IoT-Sachen, steht ja auch hier irgendwie,
kann man das
nur empfehlen. Also wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt,
kann ich euch das wirklich nur ans Herz legen.
Gerade für IoT-Geräte ist das
eines der besten Erfindungen ever.
Weil die unterstützen kein WPA Enterprise oder
sowas.
Die können nur stinknormales,
was ist das wahrscheinlich noch,
was können die?
Wifi 5 oder so.
Und WPA
oder WPA 2.
Da könnt ihr quasi für jedes Gerät ein extra Passwort
vergeben. Übrigens auch super
für, falls ihr denn wirklich mal, also wenn
ihr nicht so seid wie ich, falls ihr ab und zu mal
Besuch habt oder so, da könnt ihr auch
ein WLAN Passwort rausgeben
und das danach
wieder löschen. Es gibt sogar
zumindest bei den
Ruckus Access Points
gibt es sogar ein Gäste-Portal.
Die können sich da einloggen und sich so ein Ding selbst generieren.
Ist also eigentlich ganz cool gemacht.
Ja.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Reboot.
Dann müssen wir mal gucken, was auf GitHub
heute so trendet.
Hast du noch Pläne für YouTube? Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe keine fehlende Zeit.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Ich habe ja im letzten Stream erzählt, was sage ich, muss ich auch nicht wieder.
Kein Bock heute nochmal zu erzählen.
Nicht, weil ich nicht will, dass keiner weiß, aber es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein beliebtes Thema für mich,
dass ich das immer jedes Mal im Stream eine Stunde breitreden will.
Ne, am Fehlerzeit liegt es nicht.
Und es liegt auch nicht daran, dass ich keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube habe oder so.
sondern eher
so ein bisschen gesundheitlich
und fehlender Antrieb aktuell irgendwie
großartig was zu machen
ja du kannst
du kannst das Wort
theoretisch weiß ich nicht ob das Wort
aber das Wort vielleicht schon hier
wo man es sogar durchsuchen kann
ne
irgendwo relativ am Anfang
erzähl ich das
so nach Viertelstunde oder so
Oder soll ich nochmal erzählen, warum ich so inaktiv bin in letzter Zeit?
In 5 Minuten kann ich ja nochmal, wenn ihr wollt, erzählen, falls ihr es nicht mitgekriegt
habt im letzten Stream.
Okay, dann erzähl ich's gleich nochmal.
So grob.
Wie viele Fehleingaben möglich?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube,
unendlich Fehleingaben
möglich.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht schlimm,
wenn du ein ordentlich sicheres Passwort hast,
kann das nicht
in annehmbarer Zeit
durchprobiert werden.
Ich mache auch nur
Kurzfassung.
Ich glaube,
heute ist im Stream übelst Delay.
Nö.
Ist nicht.
Ich gucke gerade bei mir auf den Vorschau-Bildschirm.
Ich markiere das jetzt.
Und jetzt ist es im Stream von der Stream-Vorschau markiert.
Wie heißen die Tabletten nochmal?
Ja, erzähle ich gleich.
Robert, danke für den Sub.
Habe ich schon gesagt, aber kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Also, nach Reddit soll seit Veracrypt 1.26 der Bootloader von Microsoft...
Wirklich?
Hast du mal einen Link, Henry?
Ich habe letztens erst auf Veracrypt
Subreddit gelesen, dass das mit Secure Boot
nicht zurechtkommt.
Wann gab es denn Veracrypt 126?
Komm mal, such Secure Boot.
Ich finde da nichts.
Ich finde da nichts zu.
Weil was ich gefunden habe ist...
Moment, loge ich mich gerade mal ein.
Was ich gefunden habe dazu war auf dem
Veracrypt
Veracrypt Reddit
Auf
Veracrypt
Reddit
Da habe ich hier gefunden
Letztens erst, da ging es sogar um Battlefield
Hat irgendeiner geschrieben
Dann weiß ich nicht wo ich es gefunden habe
Ja, will enabling secure boot cause problems for vera crypt?
So, hello, I need to enable secure boot, but I'm using full...
Will enabling secure boot cause any problems? Yes.
Yes, vera crypt bootloader doesn't work with secure boot.
so und jetzt zeigt erst mal den threat angucken von dir wie aktiviert man sich
ob es das auf deutsch man das irgendwie
ausländische für fully encrypted system drive ist der any safe to do in one other
risk and counter man for me it was easy as just enabling secure boot for microsoft in bios
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das ist Bullshit, was der da schreibt.
Ich glaube, das ist Mist.
I have to disable CSM, was ist denn CSM?
Aber das ist auch nur ein Monat her.
Hier ist How-To-Guide, but I used only part of it.
Ich mein, Chat.
Wenn ich Secure Boot im BIOS einschalte
Also ich update Veracrypt
So
Und ich schalte Secure Boot im BIOS ein
Und es bootet dann nicht
Dann kann ich doch Secure Boot einfach wieder ausschalten
Und es bootet wieder, oder?
Ich speichere mir das mal
Hockers Link
Ich gucke mir das mal an nachher
Dann probier ich das einfach mal aus
Make sure you have GPT partition table
und MBR
Ja, ich glaube ich hab GPT
Glaub ich, bin mir sicher
Kann ja auch sein, dass das nicht ging damals
Vielleicht muss ich Windows auch neu installieren
Hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, ey
Alles nur für Battlefield 6
Der echte Max, wer sagt denn sowas?
Fake News
Ich bin Wummblos
Bios Update für neue Signaturen
Ey man, was ein Act, nur für ein Game
Alter
Wo kommen wir da hin, wenn man ein Game
einfach auf Steam kauft und starten kann
Erstmal BIOS Update machen
Secure Boot Keys einspielen
Secure Boot, also what the fuck, Alter
Meine Güte
Jetzt könnte man sagen
Spiel's doch einfach auf der Konsole, Mann
Da hast du das Problem nicht
Das Ding ist aber
Ich hab keinen Bock auf Controller Battlefield
Und das viel größere Problem ist
Ich hab gar keine aktuelle Konsole mehr
Die letzten Konsolen, die ich mir gekauft habe, waren eine Xbox One und eine PS4 zu Release
Und die habe ich so gut wie nie benutzt
Und seitdem habe ich mir keinen neuen Konsolen mehr gekauft
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie krass sich das geändert hat
Ich war der übelste Xbox 360 Fanboy
Ich habe da hunderte, tausende Stunden, keine Ahnung wie viel drauf
Aber kaum kam die Xbox One raus, habe ich instant aufgehört Xbox zu spielen.
Und PS4 habe ich auch nicht benutzt.
Die PS4 steht bei mir aktuell aber im Wohnzimmer.
Als Blu-Ray-DVD-Player.
Brauche ich nicht oft, aber wenn, dann ist sie dafür da.
Kaufe einen zweiten PC nur für Battlefield.
Ich habe hier doch schon eine SSD liegen, habe ich gerade gesehen.
Im Zweifelsfall baue ich mir die ein, die SSD, und installiere dann Windows nur für Games drauf.
Also die Xbox One Präsentation war absolut fail.
Könnt ihr euch noch an die Xbox One Präsentation erinnern, wo die irgendwelche Football-Spiele gezeigt haben?
Also nicht, sorry, ich meine damit keine Football Games, sondern halt echte Football-Geschichten, so richtig Helly-Eck-Kona.
Irgendwelche Football-Geschichten mit Overlays und sowas, wo man sich gedacht hat, was wollt ihr denn?
Es geht mir sowas voll am Arsch vorbei.
Was ist Trustfall?
Was hast du für einen Netzwerk-Setup? Was hältst du von Unify?
Ich hatte Unify.
Ich hatte ein paar Jahre lang
Unify sogar, ich hatte hier insgesamt
glaube ich, lass mal überlegen
wie viele Access Points hatte ich denn
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr
Ich glaube 3
Unify Access Points hatte ich
im Einsatz
und ich war damit nicht zufrieden
Aus mehreren Gründen war ich mit
Unify nicht zufrieden
Erstens hat das WLAN
für das wie gut eigentlich
hier die Abdeckung sein müsste mit drei Access Points,
irgendwie sehr hakelig
nur funktioniert und ich habe nie
wirklich verstanden, warum.
Weil
ich hatte davor
einen ganz billigen, einen,
einen ganz billigen
Linksys Access Point
und da hat ein Access Point
am Arsch der Welt für das gesamte Haus
inklusive Terrasse ausgereicht.
So.
Und, ich meine, das war nicht der schnellste und
langsames WLAN,
in der Regel besserer Empfang, ja.
Aber,
ich habe da drei Access Points
gehabt von Unify, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher,
wo ich die stehen, ich glaube, einen hatte ich im Keller stehen,
einen hatte ich im Erdgeschoss stehen und ich glaube,
einen hatte ich im ersten Stock stehen, irgendwie so, ich weiß gar nicht
mal genau, ist jetzt schon zu lange her, wo die
standen. Und,
damit war die Abdeckung schlechter,
gefühlt, wenn du raus bist auf die Terrasse.
als mit dem mit dem billing links access point ich schiebe das ein bisschen darauf dass das gar nicht so sehr an der wlan abdeckung selbst liegt sondern
dass die access points irgendwie probleme hatten wenn du von einem access points zum anderen gewechselt bist
wobei eigentlich gerade das bei unify ganz gut funktionieren sollte weil die access points sich untereinander austauschen können und das
wie nennt man das
es ist auch roaming wie heißt das bei wlan wo man dann oder eine access point zum anderen
sagt hier, da kommt jetzt ein Gerät
und so, ohne dass die Session ab...
Irgendwas im Hintergrund,
was sie da treiben.
Das war echt...
Das ging teilweise so,
ich bin vom ersten
Stock hier aus meinem Arbeitszimmer
runtergelaufen in die Küche
und hatte ich erstmal 30 Sekunden kein WLAN,
bis das Ding sich ausgehandelt hat.
Ah, ich muss jetzt zum neuen Access Point.
Was auch dämlich ist, weil der Empfang
in der Küche unten sollte auch noch
zu dem Access Point oben
im ersten Stock ohne Probleme ausgereicht
haben. Also das hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und da kannst du ja auch
nichts großartig einstellen bei Unify in der Richtung.
Das geht oder das geht nicht. Bei mir hat es nicht richtig
funktioniert. Ich habe keine Ahnung warum. Ich weiß, dass
ganz viele Leute halten da große
Stücke auf Unify und es gibt auch ganz viele
Influencers, die auf YouTube
da voll abgehen auf Unify und sonst was.
Also für mich,
vielleicht war ich auch einfach nur zu doof,
kann ja auch sein,
Aber für mich hat es nicht gut funktioniert.
Und das nächste war, dass Unify manche Features nicht hatte, die ich wollte.
Zum Beispiel WLAN-Passwörter pro Gerät.
Der Gerät, also das, was ich euch gerade gezeigt habe, konnte Unify da nicht.
Die haben ewig gebraucht. Die können das ja erst seit einem Jahr oder so oder zwei Jahren.
Ja, und was mir auch nicht gefallen hat, dass ich...
Ich musste ja damals Raspberry Pi laufen lassen, nur für die Unify-Oberfläche.
Das war auch nicht so meins.
ich weiß, es gibt einen fertigen Controller von Unify,
aber du brauchst ein extra Gerät für diese Oberfläche,
das macht nicht der Access Point selbst.
Und das letzte war dann, dass mir auch die Settings
und das Handling von Unify persönlich nicht so gut gefallen hat.
Das war nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Das war...
Advanceter als Einsteiger-Kram,
aber die hatten gerne für alle Sachen irgendwie eigene Namen
und dann wiederum nicht Advanced genug.
Und das war irgendwie nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
das ist das ist jetzt so mein persönliches ding zu unify das kann für
euch ganz anders aussehen prinzipiell ist das schon ganz okay
wenn es den funst sonst würden das nicht so viele leute verwenden hat das junior
fast roaming aktiviert ich kann dir meine settings von unify nicht mal sagen
aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass auch noch das alte unify muss man sagen also
noch dieses mit dem dunklen team nicht dieses blaue team weiß gar nicht ob sie
diese option überhaupt schon gab naja was ich jetzt habe ist ganz einfach
jetzt habe ich euch auf ebay zeigen
jetzt habe ich solche ist schon seit ein paar jahren wir sind überhaupt ist sie
wirklich outdated mittlerweile aber jetzt habe ich die hier
Ja, so sieht das Teil aus.
Die habe ich mir auf Ebay...
Die habe ich mir auf Ebay gekauft.
Einer im Keller.
Im Keller ist glaube ich nur ein R510.
Oder ein R610.
Und einen hier oben im ersten Stock.
Und da kann ich mich echt nicht beschweren.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Ich kann auch auf die Terrasse rausgehen
Und es funzt noch
Also da hab ich
Da bin ich zu
Ich sag mal 95% zufrieden
100% ist immer schwierig zu kriegen
Aber da bin ich zu 95% zufrieden
Würde ich mir wiederholen
Das Problem bei diesen Dingern ist
Ich kann es euch mal zeigen
Weiß nicht was der Neueste ist
Das Problem an den Dingern ist,
dass sie ein bisschen teuer sind.
Das ist halt ein Wechselpoint.
1.130 Euro kostet.
Oder 8.
Moment.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Hallo?
Google, ich würde das gerne öffnen.
Darf ich nicht. Ich darf das nicht anklicken.
Tesla Landing.
Warum 18 Cent?
Alter, AliExpress
jebaitet wieder.
Ach, das hat sechs Kabel.
Die China-Kinesen wieder,
Alter.
Findet ihr nicht auch,
ich hab da ja schon öfters bestellt,
aber findet ihr nicht auch,
dass AliExpress,
wenn man das noch nicht kennt, ja,
Dass es einfach nach der übelsten Scam-Seite aussieht.
Auch gerade die Startseite und sowas.
Ich finde diese Seite sieht so krass nach Scam aus.
Ah, okay.
Das wollte ich schon immer.
Die sieht so nach Scam aus.
Und solche Dinger machen es nicht besser.
Aber ich habe das schon öfters bestellt.
Das AliExpress.
Stell mir das mal nicht.
Nicht auf eine Stufe mit Temu, Alter.
TEMO ist quasi
AliExpress auf Wish bestellt.
Also,
AliExpress
Funst, ja.
Ja, vom Vibe der Webseite, okay.
Es gibt ja noch mehr. Es gibt noch Banggood.
Banggood hat übrigens nichts,
also nicht, dass ihr irgendwie denkt, wir suchen
jetzt nach irgendwelchen, also, das ist
eine Shoppingseite.
Wahrscheinlich, weil du viel
Bang für dein Geld kriegst oder so.
Sieht aber genauso aus.
Die ganzen China-Seiten,
die sehen alle, guckt euch das mal an,
die sehen alle ähnlich aus.
Guckt euch mal AliExpress an, guckt euch Banggood an,
sieht alles ähnlich aus.
Ich finde, das sieht so ein bisschen aus,
als hat das chinesische Ministerium für Webdesign
das alles gemacht.
Die haben alle die gleiche Webseite genommen,
ein bisschen modifiziert.
Amazon, das ist China Amazon.
Amazon.
Wie das die coolen Leute aussprechen.
Ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir da drauf gekommen sind.
Achso, ja. Ja, genau.
Das eigentliche Problem ist, wie gesagt, dass die
Access Points ein bisschen teurer sind.
Deswegen habe ich meinen Access Point
auf Ebay gekauft.
Wenn man da sucht,
dann findet man manchmal welche
zu besseren Preisen.
Also ich habe glaube ich nur 100 Euro
oder 120 oder so
dafür bezahlt.
Ich würde jetzt auch gar nicht mehr den R710 kaufen,
weil der ist schon ziemlich outdated.
Doch ich habe sowohl bei Banggood
als auch bei AliExpress schon bestellt.
Kam immer alles an.
Ich glaube ich habe nur einmal Probleme bei AliExpress
und da hat AliExpress sogar instantes Geld zurück überwiesen.
Ja, guck hier, sowas
Ganz ehrlich, kann man empfehlen
Ihr müsst aber ein bisschen drauf achten
Achtung
Kokona Style
Es ist ja so
Dass es in den USA
Irgendeine Regelung gibt
Für Export von
Produkten, die
Kryptografische Funktionen und sowas enthalten
Deswegen gibt es
dieses gerät mit unterschiedlichen firmas es gibt es gibt mit kona usa
firmware und eine internationale firmware das gerät mit der us-firmware
ist theoretisch nicht legal bei uns zu benutzen weil die frequenzen nicht mit
dem übereinstimmen was bei uns erlaubt ist es gibt die möglichkeit bzw es gab
die möglichkeit ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das noch geht das um zu flaschen
also ich konnte meinen ich hatte auch einer der access points der hatte us
firmware die habe ich umgeflasht auf die eu-firmware das ging weil es damals noch
einen root exploit gab für den access point weiß gar nicht ob er den dafür
gebraucht hat aber es gab damals sind ein exploit wo man eine rutsche auf dem
access point bekommen konnte und da konnte man firma down krähen und
firma umflaschen und sowas das ging ich kann weiß ich kann jetzt auch quasi als
land kann ich deutschland auswählen und dann ist das auch entsprechend der
ja vorgaben von hier was frequenzen und sendeleistung und sowas angeht ob das bei
den neueren access point geht weiß ich nicht deswegen würde ich davon absehen mir access
points mit us firma zu bestellen ja hier großbritannien und so das ist okay aber
nicht unbedingt wenn man sich neueren kauft die sind teuer deswegen kann ich
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde, das geht sogar klar für einen R750.
Muss man halt mal gescheit Geld ein bisschen ausgeben, dann hat man auch wirklich gute WLAN-Hardware.
Hast du eigentlich irgendwie einen besonderen Bürostuhl?
Ja.
Ich habe einen Sedus Mr. 24 Bürostuhl.
Nicht Mr. 26, Mr. 24.
26 Stunden am Tag.
So ein Ding habe ich.
Ja, so sieht er aus.
Ja.
So hier, so sieht meiner aus. Genauso.
Schwarz mit dieser Kopfstütze.
Kein Hermann Miller.
Nein, das hier ist der beste Stuhl, den es gibt.
Ich schwöre voll auf den Stuhl.
Wallah.
Wie man heute so sagt.
Ohne Mist.
Bester Stuhl.
Das ist echt
an
Bequemlichkeit allein ist es nicht.
An Komfort und Bequemlichkeit
bis jetzt hat das noch keinen Stuhl
überboten.
Und eins muss man
dazu sagen, das Ding ist stabil
as fuck.
Ich hatte davor
Preis, willst du nicht wissen.
Viel zu teuer.
Aber ganz ehrlich, so oft wie ich hier
vorm Rechner sitze und wie viele Jahre der schon hält,
ist das gut investiertes Geld gewesen.
Ich meine, ich verdiene tatsächlich mein Geld auch mit
hier auf dem Arsch vorm Computer sitzen. Also
ist das schon ordentlich investiertes Geld, ja.
So, ich hatte da vorher
so einen komischen Gaming-Chair.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Wie heißen diese Dinger? DX Racer, gell?
DX Racer, gibt's die noch?
DX Racer?
Chair, diese Dinger noch, ja.
Ja, so ein ähnliches Ding hier hatte ich mal.
Und
das war Schrott.
Da ist mir, das sah sehr ähnlich aus zu dem hier.
Da ist mir wirklich, als ich mal aufgestanden bin zu schnell, nach ein paar Jahren.
Ich habe den hier mitgenommen vom Umzug.
Ich würde gerne den Stuhl im Ganzen sehen, wenn das möglich ist, DXRacer.
Wobei, das hier reicht auch.
Ne, das nicht.
Was da?
Ich habe den, als wir umgezogen sind, bzw. als wir hier eingezogen sind,
habe ich den mitgenommen, den Stuhl.
Das heißt, den hatte ich davor schon ein bisschen.
und nicht lange nach dem Umzug bin ich mal aufgestanden, hat das Telefon geklingelt oder so,
ich wollte aufstehen und man steht ja aus dem Stuhl jetzt vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen zackiger auf,
also sprich, ich mache hier zack, Hände auf die Armlehne und drücke mich dann hoch so mit Beinen und Ärm.
So, und da ist mir dieses Ding hier komplett aus dem Rahmen rausgerissen, unten, vom Stuhl, die Armlehne.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, also das spricht nicht gerade für die Qualität von diesem Stuhl, wenn die Armlehne da quasi komplett abreißt.
Vielleicht haben sie schlecht, schlecht gelötet, geschweißt oder so, aber das war nix.
Das war nix.
und daraufhin habe ich mir den stuhl gekauft und den habe ich seit bock keine ahnung 2013 oder
irgendwie sowas aber richtig lang ja die x-rays habe schon von einigen gehört dass das qualitativ
nicht sonderlich lange das ist wohl nicht so gut ist und das nicht so lange hält sondern sei der
habe ich den Stuhl und der ist super. Den würde ich
mir, sollte der mal wirklich kaputt sein,
den würde ich mir wieder kaufen. Das Gute ist,
das Ding ist wirklich saumäßig stabil.
Also ich kann hier, Leute, ich kann
mich, ich hänge jetzt gerade,
das seht ihr jetzt nicht, ich habe keine Webcam oder so,
ich hänge gerade im Stuhl
nur auf meinen Händen. Ja?
Ich habe die Füße, ich habe die Füße nicht
auf dem Boden und die Beine auch nicht.
Ich hänge quasi nur auf den,
auf den Ärm, auf den, ähm,
auf den Arm lehnen und da tut sich
gar nichts. Jetzt nicht mehr.
Also ich bin jetzt nicht so krass Gymnastik Mensch, dass ich das drei Minuten durchhalten würde oder so
Aber ich kann mich hier in Stuhl hängen und nur auf die Hände stützen
Und dann hänge ich quasi mein Poppes hängt in der Luft
Poppes hängt in der Luft und ich bin nur hier
hier drauf
gestützt ja und das Ding bewegt sich null
Das Ding bewegt sich nur, das hält einfach
Bombenfest, ey
Dazu kannst du die Armlehnen
Nach vorne verstellen, nach links verstellen
Nach oben und unten verstellen, so 3D mäßig
Auch sehr nice, weil
Ich hab das gerne
Dass ich die Armlehne
Rechts ein Ticken
Höher und weiter vorne hab, als die
Links und sowas
Und auch ein bisschen weiter nach innen, weil rechts ist halt
die Maus, Mausarm.
Und da habe ich die Armlehne gerne minimal
höher, ein bisschen schräg
näher an mir dran und ein bisschen nach vorne.
Das passt für mich einfach am besten
hier für Maus.
Ja, gut, aber lang genug hier über den Stuhl
gelabert. Die Frage, was der kostet,
kann ich euch beantworten. Der ist
saumäßig teuer, aber für mich hat es sich gelohnt.
Der Kram kostet
so viel wie den Access Point.
Der Krieger hat, das weiß ich,
der hat den auch, ja.
Aber, ich sag mal,
Ich hatte den vorher.
Nicht vorm Krieger.
Daheim hatte er den vorher.
Aber ich hatte den vorher schon, weil ich kenne den von meiner alten Arbeit.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Stuhlschwanzvergleich.
Wer hatte den Stuhl früher?
Ich kenne den von meiner alten Arbeit.
Deswegen habe ich mir den geholt.
Da hatten wir den auch.
Also wir hatten den nicht.
Unser 24-7-Support auf der alten Arbeit hatte den.
Wir hatten ja da so ein...
so ein... Das ist nicht wirklich
First Level, aber so was, was
ein Team, was den ganzen Tag einen da
hatte, zwei Leute da hatte und
auf Monitoring und Ausfälle geguckt
hat. Und die hatten den. Und daher kannte
ich den und hab ich mir gedacht, der ist so gut,
der Stuhl, den kauf ich mir auch.
Und seitdem hab ich den.
So. So sieht's aus.
Bin ich
bisschen hinten dran mit...
Eigentlich wollte ich ja noch erzählen was.
Okay, also.
Weil jetzt so viele Leute gefragt haben.
Ich habe das im letzten Stream schon erzählt.
Warum ich gerade keinen Bock auf YouTube habe.
Oder was bei mir los ist.
Ganz kurz Zusammenfassung.
Tix, danke schön für die krassen 5 Subscriptions hier.
Pog.
Danke.
Huge Subscriptions
Nice
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll
Danke
Ja, also
Was ich sagen wollte
Wie fange ich denn da jetzt am besten an?
Wahrscheinlich fange ich so an
Zur Entspannung, okay
Wie laut die Musik
Ne, passt eigentlich
Also, ihr habt ja gesehen
dass ich jetzt schon eine Weile nichts mehr auf YouTube gemacht habe oder auch eine Weile hier bestimmt ein paar Monate schon nicht mehr gestreamt habe und sowas in der Richtung.
Und ich habe im letzten Schriebe ja schon erzählt, was los ist. Ich habe gerade ein bisschen wenig Antrieb und das liegt daran, ich muss da anders anfangen.
Ich erzähle euch jetzt einfach mal, wie das Ganze angefangen hat, weil es hat sich jetzt ja fast ein Jahr hingezogen, bis sich das jetzt wieder gebessert hat.
beziehungsweise bis
bis man jetzt so richtig
dann auch mit Tabletten und so
also, das hat bei mir angefangen
letztes Jahr
im Oktober, November
hat das angefangen
dass ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ich konnte mir das nicht so richtig erklären
habe ich sehr schlecht geschlafen
so
da denkt man sich ja erstmal noch gar nichts großartig dabei
Woke, genau
da denkt man sich ja noch gar nichts erstmal großartig dabei
denkt man sich
komisch und so, aber es war
so. Und
das hat dann angefangen,
irgendwann, so
nach ein paar Tagen, habe ich mir dann angefangen,
übelst Gedanken zu machen, was ist denn
los, ja. So.
Und ich habe mich dann irgendwann da so reingesteigert,
dass ich dann
gar nicht mehr nicht geschlafen habe, weil ich nicht schla...
dass dann irgendwann, dass ich das quasi
geändert habe von,
ähm, ich mache mir Gedanken,
warum ich nicht schlafen kann, zu, ich kann nicht schlafen,
weil ich mir Gedanken mache, was los ist.
Obwohl das eigentliche Problem,
die eigentliche Sache, die hätte sich wahrscheinlich von alleine
wiedergelegt, keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich mir übelst Gedanken gemacht.
Also so ging das Ganze los.
Da habe ich mir übelst Gedanken gemacht und konnte
deswegen nicht schlafen.
So, und dann,
so ging das Ganze los.
Die übelsten Schlafprobleme.
Also teilweise richtig, also ich kann euch
sagen, Schlafprobleme sind wirklich scheiße.
Schlafstörung ist wirklich übelster Kack.
Und das ging dann mal so ab und down, so über die nächsten Monate.
Und ich habe dann auch angefangen, mir immer mehr Gedanken zu machen, was denn jetzt ist.
Und ich kann euch nur als Tipp geben, Leute.
Wenn ihr irgendwie Bedenken habt, dass ihr irgendwie irgendeine Krankheit habt oder sowas,
googelt nicht.
Google nicht, Leute
Google nicht
Ich hab, ich hab
Du hast mindestens mal ein Gehirntumor
Wenn, wenn Google, wenn du Google fragst
Googelt nicht
So, ich hab halt gegoogelt
Und Leute
Ich hab übelste Panik gekriegt danach
Weil sonst was
Was, was ich alles hätte haben können
und natürlich habe ich dann mega Panik
gekriegt
so nach dem Motto, ich habe bestimmt
irgendwas Schlimmes, dass ich mich
da voll reingesteigert habe
und
das hat dann auch voll
durchgeschlagen, ich habe dann gemerkt
ich bin übelst angespannt den ganzen Tag
und mache mir übelst viel Gedanken und denke, dass ich
irgendwas Schlimmes habe, kann nicht richtig pennen
es war mega belastend
und das hat sich dann
das hat sich dann immer mal wieder
auf und ab geschaukelt
bis ich dann irgendwann gesagt hab
im Februar
war das dieses Jahr
bis ich dann irgendwann im Februar mal gesagt hab
das kann's alles nicht mehr sein
du gehst jetzt mal zu nem ordentlichen Arzt
hab ich mir einen neuen Hausarzt gesucht
im alten war ich ja überhaupt nicht so zufrieden mehr
hab ich mir nur einen Hausarzt gesucht
und der hat dann zum ersten Mal
gesagt, so nach dem Motto, na wobei
nicht zum ersten Mal, ja das stimmt nicht
aber hat gemeint, das
könnte doch auch durchaus was
psychisches sein
so wirklich gedacht, also gedacht
hab ich mir das im Vorfeld auch schon
aber ich wollte es nicht so
richtig wahrhaben, ja
und
ich hab auch
schon im Vorfeld mal irgendwann dann
angefangen im November oder so,
habe ich mir online mal mit einem Therapeut gesprochen
und so und der meinte auch, ja,
das kann schon in diese Richtung
gehen.
Naja, zumindest lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Das
ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Und
das war dann so schlimm,
da bin ich,
das ist noch Anfang
August
Ende Juli bin ich dann nochmal zum Hausarzt gegangen, nachdem das alles nicht besser geworden ist.
Und die hat dann was gesagt, was wirklich auch was gebracht hat.
Die hat gesagt, also wie gesagt, sie glaubt, das ist ein psychisches Problem.
Und ich soll mal nach Frankfurt in die Ambulanz fahren von der Psychiatrie.
Ja, offiziell in die Klapse
Da hab ich mir gedacht, Alter, okay, weißt du was, scheiß drauf, du kriegst das alleine nicht mehr auf die Reihe
Ich wollte ja nicht, ich wollte ja nicht
Ich hab gesagt, ich geh doch nicht in die Psychiatrie, Alter
So, und
Aber dann, an einem Freitag war das, das weiß ich noch, da hab ich wieder so überhaupt nicht gepennt die Nacht davor
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, Max, weißt du was, das klappt so nicht mehr, du fährst da jetzt hin
Und da bin ich wirklich, ich hatte übelst Schiss davor, Leute.
Aber wahrscheinlich, weil man das ja so aus Film und Fernsehen kennt, dass das so ganz, ganz schrecklich ist, ja.
Und dann bin ich da hingefahren nach Frankfurt.
Und hab mich da angemeldet.
Und ich hab da im Wartezimmer gesessen, hab mir halb in die Hose gemacht.
Also, sinnbildlich, ne, nicht wirklich.
Weil ich gedacht hab, das ist ganz schlimm und die behalten mich da und ich komm hier nie wieder raus und whatever, ja.
total bescheuert
im Nachhinein, jetzt kann ich drüber lachen
an dem Tag war es mir nicht zum Lachen zumute
da hab ich echt Schiss davor gehabt
so und
bin ich da hingefahren
mich angemeldet
und da muss ich ein bisschen warten
und da bin ich dann zu einer Ärztin
da reingekommen
und das war echt gut
muss ich sagen
das war nicht so nach dem Motto
hier schnell wieder raus schmeißt und ich war bestimmt 35 40 minuten hat die
hat hier mit mir geredet und alles und die hat mir dann
also die hat auch gesagt ja das ist auch alles was ich jeder erzähler bis ganz
typisch und so dafür und auch dass ich mich so angespannt fühle und da ich
manchmal herzklopfen habe und sowas wegen der aufregung und alles das ist
ganz typisch das ist ganz ganz typisch dafür und sie gibt mir jetzt nicht sie
gibt mir jetzt ein paar pillen und sie würde würde auch empfehlen dass ich
vielleicht wiederkommen und so und zumindest hat die mir hat die mir dann
pillen aufgeschrieben und also aktuelle vermutung ist also so richtig so ein
richtig super erklärung wo das herkommt
weiß ich nicht zumindest ist die der meinung ich habe eine angststörung und
das würde auch alles gut passen dazu ich weiß nicht so hundertprozentig genau
warum sich das da im november oktober entwickelt hat keine ahnung vielleicht
weil ich ein bisschen schlecht geschlafen haben wir dann angefangen
habe gedanken darum zu machen und mich da voll reingestellt habe keine ahnung
und jetzt pillen dagegen aufgeschrieben plus plus ich soll ich soll regelmäßig
damit im therapeut reden hast du die symptome auch damals zur schulzeit gab
nicht hatte so was noch nie noch nie
war mir vollkommen vollkommen neu zumindest kriege ich jetzt kriege ich
jetzt tabletten gegen angststörungen und das hilft auch ganz gut muss ich sagen
das ist dann wirklich unüblich naja die hat gesagt 20 prozent der leute haben so was einmal im leben
also dass das ja auch gesagt das haben total viele und wichtig ist erstmal auch dass man
erkennt dass es das ist und nicht denkt es liegt dann irgendwas anderem macht
ja macht ja irgendwie auch sinn
haben die schlafstörung vor dem fitness klein angefangen
das hat einer mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun
wie gesagt seit letztes hat letztes jahr also oktober november angefangen zwar
ein bisschen stressig davor, aber
also
so hundertprozentig erklären,
oder kann ich mir schon, also
ich will jetzt nicht alles so sehr im Detail erzählen,
aber so eine hundertprozentig richtig gute
Erklärung dafür habe ich auch noch nicht.
Also ist das
etwas Vergängliches, wenn man dies behandelt, ja.
Man muss halt selbst erstmal drauf klarkommen.
Dadurch,
dass das so lang ging, hat es halt auch
gesagt, dadurch, dass das so lang
ging, man schießt sich da im Kopf
so ein bisschen drauf ein.
Ja, und ist dann halt auch so total angespannt
und macht sich wegen jedem Scheiß Gedanken
und sowas. Habe ich auch schon bei mir ein bisschen
gemerkt, dass ich mir
wegen total sinnlosen Sachen übelst
Gedanken mache. So als wäre das jetzt was ganz
Schlimmes. Dabei ist es halt die meisten Sachen so
nix wildes, ja.
Zumindest, was ich jetzt kriege,
ich kriege jetzt, ähm,
warum hängt das Aquarium? Was ist da los?
Was hier?
Ich kriege jetzt Seatralin.
Das ist...
Irgendein Medikament, was im Hirn...
Frag mich nicht.
Irgendwelche chemischen Dinger verändert.
Man hat dann irgendwie mehr Serotonin im Hirn.
Und deswegen geht es einem besser.
Bist du schon in Therapie?
Oder warst du noch?
Bin ich schon.
Auch schon länger.
Ja, also ich, äh, also auch schon seit, seit, ähm, zum ersten Mal mit einem Therapeut geredet, hab ich irgendwann im November.
Und regelmäßig mach ich das, mach ich das...
Ach, ich seh, gibt noch mehr Leute, die den Kram...
Gibt noch mehr Leute, die das, die den Kram nehmen, okay.
Die Nebenwirkungsliste ist auch sehr kurz, jaja.
Da hab ich auch schon den Fehler gemacht, überhaupt was Nebenwirkungen zu lesen, aber ich hab keine.
Ich hab, ich hab so gut wie keine Nebenwirkungen.
Nimmst du die Tabletten täglich? Ja.
Machst du mal in einem Schlaflabor?
Ne. Ey, Leute, wir müssen jetzt gar nicht so sehr...
Ihr müsst nichts analysieren.
Und ich hab auch keinen Bock, mich mit irgendwelchen
Medizinsachen großartig jetzt zu beschäftigen.
Ich hab's euch nur erzählt,
dass ihr Bescheid wisst.
Ja, aber ich nehm das
täglich.
Ja.
Und...
Ich würd sagen,
Das verläuft manchmal so ein bisschen in Wellen, ja manchmal ist es ein bisschen schlimmer, aber ich würde sagen, seit ich das nehme, ist es schon eindeutig besser geworden.
Also mir geht es eigentlich den überwiegenden Teil mittlerweile gut versus davor, wo es mir den überwiegenden Teil schlecht ging.
Und eine Sache habe ich auch gemerkt, wenn es einem gut geht und nur ein bisschen schlecht, hat man vergessen, wie schlecht es einem wirklich mal ging und interpretiert das als viel schlechter, als es eigentlich ist.
Kann man die Tabletten dann auch irgendwann wieder absetzen? Ja, ja, kann man.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass das wieder weggeht.
Ich muss mal kurz den Chat hier auf...
Also ich muss sagen, also heute, bei mir ist ja meistens so, dass es morgens die Anspannung da am größten ist.
Heute geht's eigentlich, heute ist es echt ganz gut.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde, man sieht eindeutig, dass die Tabletten was bringen.
Plus ab und zu mal da Therapeutgespräch und so bringt das schon was, ja.
Also ich bin da...
Ich bin da eigentlich recht zuversichtlich, dass das wieder weggeht.
Das ist so... Manchmal hat man da so zwei Sachen im Kopf, ja.
Wenn ich so meine fünf Minuten habe und mir wieder über alles Gedanken mache, ja,
dann denke ich so, boah, das geht wahrscheinlich nie wieder weg.
Wenn ich aber mal realistisch drüber nachdenke, so wie jetzt,
ist die Chance, dass das wieder weggeht, ziemlich hoch.
Und das hat die Ärztin dort auch gesagt.
hätte auch gesagt, sie hat glaube ich seit
in den, in den, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahren, wo sie
hier ist, hat sie noch nicht eingesehen,
wo das, so was ich ihr da erzähle,
wo das noch nicht wieder weggegangen ist.
Es dauert halt ein bisschen.
Was gibt's heute zu futtern?
Keine Nudel mit Lachs.
Es gibt heute Nudel,
aber wahrscheinlich nur mit ein bisschen
Speck drüber.
Ja, seht ihr, Leute? Wenn's bei euch wieder
alles klappt, dann klappt es bei mir bestimmt auch wieder.
Es ist ja auch schon deutlich besser geworden.
Ich habe auch nicht vor, die Pillen jetzt mein Leben lang zu nehmen.
Aber es hat ja auch gesagt, ich soll das jetzt wirklich
erstmal konsequent ein halbes Jahr lang
nehmen. Einfach um diesen
Effekt, so nach dem Motto, es liegt nur
an den Pillen oder es liegt auf keinen Fall an den Pillen
oder sonst was,
dass das sich alles
wieder normalisieren kann.
Und nachdem ich so gut wie keine Nebenwirkungen habe,
Ist ja okay, ja.
Ihr solltet übrigens nicht den Fehler machen.
Das ist ein Tipp vielleicht noch, ja.
Wenn ihr auch so jemand seid, der sich viel Gedanken macht,
wegen Nebenwirkungen und Gesundheitssachen und so,
wie ich ja irgendwie angefangen habe da im Oktober, November.
Und ihr habt eigentlich ein ganz gutes Gefühl bei einem Arzt,
ihr seid nicht wirklich in der guten Verfassung
um euch die Nebenwirkungsliste durchzulesen
ich sag jetzt nicht, man sollte nie
reingucken in die Nebenwirkungsliste
aber wenn das der Arzt, wenn das euer Arzt
dem ihr da traut, für sinnvoll hält
dann müsst ihr nicht unbedingt die Nebenwirkungsliste
durchlesen
weil da steht alles drin, Leute
bei jedem Medikament steht
irgendwo drin, seltene Nebenwirkungen
plötzlicher Tod und sowas
da drehst du durch, wenn du dir das
alles durchliest und wenn du eh schon
Bedenken hast, wegen irgendwelchen Gesundheitssachen
und dann auch die Nebenwirkungsliste
durchliest von irgendwas, was dir eigentlich helfen soll,
lest es nicht.
Lest es nicht.
Lest es einfach nicht.
Oder zumindest, wenn ihr euch
gar nicht davon abbringen könnt, es zu lesen,
dann lest nur das, was mal sehr häufig
steht, okay?
Weil das ist meistens nicht so schlimm.
sehr häufig heißt bei Medikamenten,
by the way, 1-10%
der Leute, die das nehmen,
bekommen was davon.
Also selbst dann ist es nicht häufig,
also sehr häufig würde man ja
denken, ist so, so irgendwie jeder kriegt's
oder die meisten kriegen's. Nee, nee.
Bei Medikamenten heißt es, sehr häufige Nebenwirkungen
zwischen 1 und 10%
der Leute bekommen es.
So.
So sieht's aus.
Jetzt hab ich das länger erzählt, als ich wollte,
aber jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Letztes Jahr,
im August,
da wo ich auch richtig krassen Sportgrind gemacht hab und sowas, ja,
da hätte ich gesagt, mir geht's besser als jemals zuvor.
Mental und körperlich und so.
Wie schnell der Scheiß gehen kann,
das glaubt man gar nicht, bis man's mal hatte.
innerhalb von ein paar Wochen.
Ja, bis Ende Oktober alles gut
und dann auf einmal richtig kacke.
Durch nix eigentlich, durch nix.
Also wer sowas noch nicht hatte,
kann man sich nicht vorstellen,
aber das kann ganz schnell gehen.
Wenn bei dem Antidepressiven
Nebenwirkungen Depressionen tritt,
ja, es steht ja auch bei Kopfschmerztabletten drin,
dass du davon Kopfschmerzen bekommen kannst.
lest euch das erst gar nicht durch
dankeschön für den sub so habe ich nicht die ganze zeit nicht gesehen
box abscription dankeschön
fritzbox wlan ist auch nicht übel das ding ist fritzbox das fritzbox wlan hat mir schlicht
ergreifen zu wenig features beispielsweise eigene passwörter für
jedes gerät
ich glaube ja ich glaube du kannst die alle also diese die alle die mit er
anfangen diese er 510 er 750 und sie kannst du alle auf anlicht meines wissens
umfläche aber das ist nicht schlimm du kannst bei an die nachgucken was
support devices sind da steht alles drin
mit diet oder mit die dankeschön für den sub messer subscription
dankeschön
dh geht auch sehr die seite die hatte ich nicht mehr im kopf genau die sieht
die sind weil es gerade von hatten hier ali express genau das wollte ich zeigen
ali express banggood und die h gate genau guckt euch die seiten an leute
guckt euch die seiten an das hat doch alles das chinesische webdesign
ministerium erstellt oder das sieht alles gleich aus
Sogar die gleiche Schriftart.
Und wenn wir noch ein paar andere China-Shops finden,
sehen die wahrscheinlich auch so aus.
Die haben alle denselben Frontend-Entwickler.
Ja, den einen Chinese,
den sie im Container eingesperrt haben,
der jetzt Webseiten entwickeln muss wahrscheinlich.
Die kennen da ja nix.
Wisst ihr, manchmal denke ich mir so, wir können uns eine Scheibe davon abschneiden, allerdings wäre es doch schön, das nicht so extrem zu machen.
Wisst ihr, jetzt mal übertrieben gesagt, in China bauen sie in zwei Wochen ein Krankenhaus, das besteht dann vielleicht nur aus Container oder sonst was.
Problem dabei ist, dass wahrscheinlich fünf Arbeiter im Fundament einbetoniert werden, aus Versehen.
Und bei uns brauchen sie 18 Jahre, um einen Fahrradweg zu bauen.
Wäre nicht sowas in der Mitte ganz cool
So, nicht 5 Arbeiter
Im Fundament aus Versehen verschütten
Und auch nicht 18 Jahre für einen Fahrradweg brauchen
So nach dem Motto
1-2 Jahre und dafür ordentlich gebaut
Wäre das nicht nice, hä?
Wäre das, das wäre doch mal was
So ein Zwischending
Nicht ganz so extrem wie die Chinesen
Und nicht ganz so extrem wie wir
So irgendwas dazwischen, guck mal
In Italien haben sie eine Brücke gebaut
Ich hab vergessen wo das war, innerhalb von einem Jahr
und es ist eine riesen Brücke oder eineinhalb Jahre.
Eine riesen Brücke.
Wie hieß denn das Ding nochmal? Ganz bekannt.
Mir fällt es aber gerade nicht ein.
Ihr wisst das bestimmt, Chatge. Ihr seid schlau.
Weiß ich nicht mehr. Brücke.
Ein Jahr Brücke Italien.
Gate Bridge in Italien. Ja genau, Chatge.
Genua.
Genau.
ja und die haben eine neue brücke gebaut innerhalb von ein bisschen über einem jahr
nicht bei einem ist eine brücke entstanden wir
hoffen dass nur dieses ordentlich gebaut und schütze ich auch wieder ein
runter scrollen wenn ich irgendwas übersehen habe leute schreibt sommer in
chat ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen aufholen hier dann noch mal für die
ganzen subs
Ja, come on, come on.
Hast du euch eine neue Katze?
Ne.
Ich hätte aber gerne wieder eine.
Ich gehe manchmal ins Tierheim
Da wo ich auch ab und zu mal
Was spende
Und gehe da zu den Katzen rein und streichle mal
Eine Runde Katzen und dann gehe ich wieder heim
Und ich habe
Eine Runde hier
Bei mir im Ort
Die habe ich extra so gelegt
Also
Eine Jogging-Spaziergehrunde
spaziergehrunde habe ich extra so das ist so eine ganz schräge achterrunde die
die habe ich wirklich nach der eine ziemlich eierische acht ist das die ich
so laufe durchs ort die habe ich extra so gelegt weil auf dem weg ganz viele
katzen wohnen die ich öfters mal sehe unterwegs also auf einer standardrunde
sind bis zu sieben katzen die ich zufällig treffen kann auf dem weg und
Ich laufe immer ab und ich habe bestimmt, also ich habe meistens bestimmt mindestens, also, naja, nicht jedes Mal mindestens eine, aber zum größten Teil mindestens eine, die ich unterwegs sehe.
Und die dann auch meistens schon zu mir kommen.
Die kennen mich schon.
Kann ich eine Runde auf dem Gehweg eine Runde Katze streicheln.
Also ich habe einen, der freut sich immer richtig schon, wenn er mich sieht.
Was vielleicht auch daran liegt, dass ich dem manchmal schon ein bisschen Schlabberstick gegeben habe.
Also nicht so ein Leckerli.
Sieht aus wie eine Mini-Salami für Katzen.
Der ist schon immer ganz happy, wenn er mich sieht.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, er wartet sogar drauf.
Der liegt dann immer im Hof.
Und wenn er mich sieht, springt er schon immer auf.
Mau, mau, mau, mau, mau.
Kommt hin.
schmeißt sich dann erstmal hin, wird eine Runde gestreichert
und dann kriegt er einen kleinen Stick.
Ritzkohl.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
37 Jahre, ja.
Massive Subscription.
Und Faceman auch.
Dankeschön, Leute, für die Subs.
Buffer Plot.
die einfachste sache dürfte sein eine leitung nicht voll zu machen
baffer laufen ja nur voll wenn du mehr schickst oder wenn mehr traffic ist als
bandbreite zur verfügung steht die meisten leute sollten überhaupt kein
problem mit bach verbraucht haben wenn du nicht gerade was spielst und nebenbei
irgendwie steam games installiert oder so oder oder
die torrens laufen hast oder sowas das sollte normalerweise überhaupt kein
problem machen ansonsten kannst du sicherlich auch qs settings machen aber
das ist meistens gar nicht notwendig es sei denn es sei denn der sorry ich sehe
das ja immer so aus meiner sicht ja von jemand der irgendwie keine kinder hat
die streams gucken und so was wenn du natürlich eine familie hast dass du
spielst und was ich gehe davon aus deine eltern sind im haus plus was noch
geschwister oder so und will spielen die kinder gucken youtube die eltern gucken
netflix die arbeit das okay dann sieht das natürlich ein bisschen anders aus
da würde ich als erstes mal überlegen gibt es vielleicht ein anschluss mit
bisschen mehr bandbreite wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt ja wenn ihr da wirklich
anders an das bandbreiten limit öfters stößt stoßt wenn das nicht verkehrt
mittlerweile ist ja in deutschland gar nicht so schlimm mit dem ausbau mehr gibt ja immer mehr
glasfaser ansonsten hast du eigentlich nur die chance dass du in einem router qs settings machst
was es qm ist weil sie nicht wahrscheinlich service qualitätssicher wahrscheinlich auch
sowas in der richtung da kannst du dann beispielsweise sagen ich will alles auf
port xy oder alles von dieser ip muss man gucken was da ein router für settings hat hast
kannst du einstellen kann es beispielsweise einstellen dass alles priorität von einem rechner hat
Dann hast du keine probleme mehr mehr bandbreite wäre auf jeden fall auch nicht verkehrt wenn ihr da regelmäßig ans limit kommt
Es ist also das ist bei mir ja auch so sind jedem es ist bei jedem anschluss so
also ich kann jetzt kein speedtest machen gerade ich will jetzt nicht wieder alles liegen aber wenn
ich speedtest mache dann sieht man auch dass ich normalerweise habe ich ein ping von keine ahnung
89 10 oder so und wenn ich volle pulle download dann habe ich auf einmal eine ping von 180 200
ja klar die leitung ist ja nicht aber das problem hast du wenn du alleine bist
und nicht gerade download vom spiel nicht bei einem verband mit einer
familie sich natürlich anders aus mehr bandbreite ist aber auf jeden fall
sinnig so updates aber alle gemacht passt hier gut hat die fritz box qs
settings ich sag mal ja aber ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert weil ich keine fritzbox benutzt
für internetzugang bzw mein rechner ist da eh nicht ich gehe über den mikrotik router dahinter
der hätte so was aber brauche ich nicht hier macht keiner außer mir die leitung nicht aber
die fritzbox hat so was bin ich mir relativ sicher dass die fritzbox so was hat wie können wir gucken
also ich weiß halt bei der fritzbox nicht wie umfangreich da die einstellungen sind bei fritz
box ist es halt immer so die fritzbox kann saumäßig viel hat halt saumäßig viel man muss halt immer
sehen die fritzbox ist jetzt in den jeweiligen einzelnen kategorien hat nicht unbedingt immer
das beste also die fritzbox ist jetzt nicht den besten router denen wir vorstellen kannst oder
Oder die beste, besser Paketfilter, den du dir vorstellen kannst.
Oder beste Telefonanlage, die du dir vorstellen kannst.
Die Fritzbox ist ein sehr gutes Multifunktionsgerät, was alles relativ gut kann.
Aber wenn du halt Spezialfunktionen brauchst, wie beispielsweise fürs WLAN einzelne Passwörter pro Gerät und sowas.
Das kann die Fritzbox dann nicht.
Und deswegen weiß ich auch nicht, aber guck mal, hier kannst du QoS-Settings machen.
fritz box ist das beste gesamtpaket ja sehe ich auch so dass wir das neue fritz
us 8.2 ich glaube ich habe meine fritz box seit fünf jahren oder so nicht mehr
geupdatet weil die macht nichts außer telefon hier bei mir macht nur web die
fritz box
sonst nichts.
Die steht einfach nur da und macht VoIP
und gammelt vor sich hin.
Richtiges kann die Fritzbox nicht.
Was bedeutet...
Was ist denn der Unterschied bei dir
zwischen richtigem QoS und nicht richtigem QoS?
Also was ist denn richtiger?
Was können denn andere richtiger als die Fritzbox?
Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert.
wir müssen gleich mal videos gucken merkt schon wieder ganz trockenen hals
vom schwätzen
wofür brauchst du eigentlich dann fest ich brauche das nicht meine mutter
braucht das die wohnt ja hier im erdgeschoss
die braucht dass die steht unglaublich auf festnetz telefon und was wo das halt
wirklich ganz wobei das hat mit der fritzbox nichts zu tun vergisst ich
benutze die fritz box noch für stimmlich für zwei sachen für telefon und für fritz
heizungs thermostate dafür
und was auch ganz praktisch ist das liegt aber nicht an der fritz box das
festnetztelefon das läuft über einen web anbieter nicht über den internet
provider habe ich absichtlich gemacht so dass das man unabhängig ist vom internet
provider mit der telefonnummer und dort kann man sich eine app installieren auf
dem handy eine web app und bekommt dann quasi auch die festnetzanrufe aufs
handy wenn man die app von dem von dem volk anbieter hat finde ich ganz nice
da ist man unterwegs da ist man unterwegs und wenn einer festnetz
anruft, sieht man das auf dem Handy.
Finde ich ganz praktisch.
Verwirrt die Leute manchmal,
wenn man dran geht und sagt,
jo, hier, was geht?
Und du sagst, ich kann gar nicht,
weil ich bin nicht daheim. Das verwirrt die Leute
immer noch. Auch im Jahr 2025.
Wenn die Festnetz
anrufen und du gehst nicht Festnetz dran.
Kann man Unify
NVR ohne... Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab kein
Unify mehr und ich hab Unify NVR auch nie
benutzt.
Auch während ich
es hatte.
So.
Jetzt gucken wir mal. Haben wir schon ganz lange
nicht mehr gemacht.
Was trendet denn heute?
auf und diese woche was trennt denn auf
schritt ab windows
windows trendet nach windows inside docker container doch doch uhr windows
mac os aha ok ja warum nicht schnell windows inside docker container
lass mich raten unter der haube ist dann kvm trainer wetten wie soll das sonst
funktionieren das wird einfach ein kvm sein und du
musst wahrscheinlich bei docker auch def kvm oder wie es heißt weiterleiten dass
es funktioniert und guck mal auf kvm lege ich schon mal richtig
Und die weiß, DevKVM musst du weiterleiten.
Chat.
Hab ich nicht gesagt.
High IQ Mode
aktiviert.
Aber es war naheliegend.
War naheliegend.
Und ich bilde mir ein,
ich glaube, ich hab sogar ein bisschen gecheatet.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich hab mir das nämlich für MacOS
schon mal angeguckt da war es das gleiche
okay was trennt sonst noch na klar
was sonst ich skippe einmal wenn ich gucken will gucke ich feier schipp
Kann ich mir drei Stunden lang AI-Content geben.
Bei FireShip, ich gucke mittlerweile eigentlich kaum noch FireShip, weil...
Weiß nicht, wie sieht es bei euch aus? Guckt ihr noch FireShip?
Oder habt ihr mal geguckt und guckt nicht mehr?
Weil es ist zu 80% AI.
Und ich habe fast den Eindruck, die Videos sind mittlerweile auch AI-generated.
Also früher habe ich den sehr gerne geguckt.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Ey, sag mal.
Wisst ihr, was echt gut wäre?
Wenn es den Filter gäbe hier oben.
No AI.
expert official elixir language server
ai ai
wo es in ja das ist so ein ding da kann man informationen über verschiedene domains und
so rausbekommen der harvester so die hälfte davon ungefähr gehen aber nur also von den
methoden die das unterstützt gehen aber nur wenn du api keys und subscriptions
hast aber ein ziemlich neues tool gibt keine demo ausgabe ja aber da fragt
jede menge services ab und hat beispielsweise infos über domains
rauskriegen ohne dass alles selbst abklappern muss oder vielleicht gar
nicht weiß dass das alles gibt
kennst du eigentlich das denn was was was ich habe keine ahnung was du meinst
evolution of spreadsheets also quasi excel ng mit hilfe von wlan signalen
durchwende schon. Da habe ich schon mal was drüber
gelesen.
Es gibt ja auch
so Presence Detection Dinger
für Heimautomatisierung,
die anhand von
Signalstärken von
verschiedenen Geräten ungefähr ableiten kann,
in welchem Raum man ist und sowas.
Vielleicht geht es in ähnliche Richtung.
Was?
FireShip wurde gekauft? Wirklich?
gut der lässt sich das nicht nehmen messer messer songs ok evolution of
spreadsheets also es kostet was okay kann man selbst haus nachdem ich ja auch
schon immer mehr excel oder was in der richtung verwende brauche ich die
evolution of spreadsheets auch nicht
das habe ich schon mal irgendwas drüber gesehen ja dann irgendwie kommt mir das
klingelt ganz leise irgendwo im Kopf, ja.
Da ich da schon mal was drüber gelesen habe.
Yep, Coke.
Official Kotlin Framework for Building and Running Robust Scalable Production Ready.
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt was Gescheites, aber nein.
AI Agents.
Coke.
Yep, Coke.
Wie läuft es mit der Diät?
Noch am Abnehmen?
ja in letzter Zeit ein bisschen weniger
abnehmen, aber ich wiege jetzt um die
80 Kilo, das ist
erstmal okay
ich bin 174
80 Kilo
das ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen zu schwer noch, aber
ich bin weit
entfernt von 108,5 was ich mal hatte
aktuell geht's
schwanz ein bisschen
mal ein bisschen weniger, mal ein bisschen mehr
also mein ziel ist tatsächlich dauerhaft noch unter also aktuell schwankt also um
die 80 rum mein ziel ist jetzt eigentlich das einzige ziel was ich
gewichtmäßig noch habe ist eigentlich dass ich dauerhaft unter 80 bin
das heißt ich muss ein bisschen unter 80 sein dass auch wenn ich mal ordentlich
gefressen habe ich noch unter 80 bin also ich würde gern dauerhaft unter 80
sein so aber ansonsten bin ich da echt ganz happy mit
Ich müsste viel eher mal wieder anfangen, wieder regelmäßig zu joggen.
Ich war in den letzten 14 Tagen einmal joggen.
Und gar nicht Fahrrad fahren.
Krafttraining.
Habe ich jetzt nichts geplant, ey.
So, was gibt es denn sonst noch hier?
AI.
Aha, Rust-Stells.
Placingly fast, written in Rust.
Trivi. Trivi ist tatsächlich ganz nice, das kenne ich von uns auf der Arbeit.
So ein Security-Scanner für...
Kannst du auf dein Git-Repo loslassen.
Ein BRC One Billion Row Challenge.
java mks einer so jetzt guck ich mal was sich in der dort net welt zu tut
wahrscheinlich nichts die sachen sind immer super langweilig für den arsch
von arsch von arsch ist vielleicht bisschen gemein ich wirklich aber weiß
gar nicht was ist das ist nicht für den arsch das kann man sich gut sagen
abgucken microsoft gedöns brauche ich hier jetzt wo ich das gerade lese mit
hardware monitor hat jemand trifft der dankeschön für den sub hat jemand von
euch auch noch die letzten tage eine windows defender virus fehlermeldung
bekommen
angetrifft winring ja habt ihr das auch gekriegt ja leute ich habe gedacht ich
bin wie nennt man das heute wie heißt das es gibt doch so ein tolles
jugendfortführer wieso sagt dem motto ich bin am arsch das hat man sagt heute
nicht mehr ich bin am arsch sondern ich bin sagt man denn auch heute gibt so ein
dummes wort kommen jetzt gerade nicht guckt guckt genau guckt ist man gekocht
man ist guckt guckt habe ich habe gedacht ich bin guckt
als ich das gesehen habe
wenn die fehlermeldung
ja das ding hier wenn du schuf beliebliche tools plötzlich als warnt vorging nulltreiber
Ja, ja.
Na, gucken wir jetzt mal hier.
Suchergebnisse, beliebige Zeit, die letzte Woche.
Hier, Threats detected.
Wie Gorf A, was auch immer.
Was meint Windows denn eigentlich, was es dort gefunden hat?
Das interessiert mich jetzt mal.
Gar nichts.
Wieder eine falsche Positive, ja.
Also, genau, das Ding kriegt man dann.
das ist oftmals bei rgb software ich hatte open rgb installiert mal ganz am anfang hier vom wo
ich den rechner neu hatte und daher kam das bei mir das benutzen viele viele tools um hardware
anzusprechen da gibt es halt ein treiber und in windows und windows ist der meinung das ist kein
wirklicher virus ja also es ist windows ist der meinung das wäre jetzt ein virus also das ist
so ein...
Eigentlich ist das ein False Positive,
aber es ist ein kleiner
False Positive, falls es sowas gibt,
weil das Ding selbst hat wohl
ziemliche Sicherheitslücken, dieser Treiber.
Dass über diesen Treiber
können beispielsweise unprivilegierte
User-Root-Rechte oder Admin-Rechte
unter Windows bekommen. Das heißt,
irgendwo ist es schon ein Threat.
Toyana würde
jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen.
Ja, also
kann man sich jetzt streiten, ob es
es als Trojaner erkennt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
richtig, dass es entfernt wird.
Da habe ich aber ein bisschen
Schiss gekriegt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja.
Also ich sehe aber, es hatten bei euch auch ein paar Leute.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Hä?
Wieso? Ich bin Wubblors.
Wer ist denn das?
Okay, ich gebe zu, mein Avatar ist wahrscheinlich zu auffällig hier auf Twitch.
Aber schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Hast du Glück, weil ich war die letzten Monate kaum da.
Lass uns mal schauen, was können wir uns denn heute mal auf YouTube angucken.
Meine YouTube-Empfehlungen sind komplett kaputt, weil ich so lange nicht eingeloggt war hier.
Was zum...
Jesus. Okay, alles klar.
Gibt's schon weird
Weird champige Shorts, Alter
Was krieg ich denn hier empfohlen, Mann
Wäre das hier vielleicht was?
Zeig mal
Erkenne den Hacker
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Vortrag oder wie?
Oder was?
was ist das ich kann das jetzt recht 42 minuten
pewdiepie arch install das hatte ich tatsächlich sogar schon mal offen
irgendwann das video was sind das für bescheuerte trends ich muss unbedingt
ein paar videos an machen weil es ist ja hier durch so was hat ein fire chip hier
aber es lang hat feier schipp mehr geguckt so 100 seconds of dac db gucken kein feier schipp
aber hier lohnt sich das habe ich sonst auch immer gerne geguckt was verdient ein medienpädagoge
was zum teufel macht ein medienpädagoge karriere als erzieher da ordnet leute das wäre ich glaube
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich glaube, das wäre...
Also das wäre Folter für mich.
Kindergarten und sowas.
Das ist einfach nur...
So viele Kinder ist ja...
Das ist ja...
Sowas...
Von nervig. Also...
Mir reicht's ja schon,
wenn mir irgendwelche Leute mit Kindern auf der Straße
entgegenkommen, dass die mich abfacken.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich würde nochmal Geld damit verdienen, jeden Tag im Kindergarten zu hocken und mir das Geschrei von den Kindern anzuhören. Also ich glaube, sowas hier Erzieher oder Grundschullehrer und sowas ist, glaube ich, echt Folter. Das wäre, glaube ich, das Schlimmste, was ich mir irgendwie als Beruf vorstellen könnte.
Kinder sind Endgegner, was das angeht.
Es gibt eigentlich kaum eine Situation, in der Kinder nicht nervig sind.
Selbst wenn die einfach auf der Straße nur rumrennen und happy sind und lachen und so, ja.
Da denkt man sich manchmal so, ja, okay, sie sind ja nicht immer nervig.
Aber sobald du das denkst, schreien sie rum.
Dann halt nicht, weil sie traurig sind, sondern weil sie sich so freuen schreien.
Sie schreien immer, Kinder schreien den ganzen Tag immer rum.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Also hier Kindergarten, ne, ne, ne.
Kindergarten, vergiss es.
Painstamp, ja.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, nur kleiner Disclaimer,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man eigene Kinder hat,
dann sieht man das anders.
Zumindest was die eigenen betrifft.
Aber ich habe nicht vor, Kinder zu kriegen.
Ich bin zwar nicht der Dünnste, aber so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Ich habe auch, ich müsste eher sagen,
Ich habe auch nicht vor, Kinder zu zeugen.
Politiker in Teilzeit.
Abgeordneter im Landtag.
IT-Berater am Abend.
Projektleiter einer Behörde.
Oh, das ist bestimmt Bürokratie-Overload, oder?
Food-Truck-Besitzer.
Oh, nice.
Der könnte jetzt bei mir kurz mal halten, der Food-Truck-Besitzer.
Metzgerei, Fachverkäufer, Maurer, Richter, Gastronom, Sales Manager, Monker.
Okay, das gucken wir uns an, aber nur aus dem einzigen Grund, dass ich über Management und Vertriebsleute meckern kann.
Hacken bei der größten Industriemesse.
Gehalt eines Cyber Security.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Social Media Managerin.
Ja, das ist auch ein Beruf, auf den ich absolut keinen Bock hätte.
Also, okay.
Der Beruf von dem, was man hier sieht, wo ich am wenigsten Bock drauf hätte,
ist natürlich eindeutig die arbeit im kindergarten das wird mich den ganzen
tag abfangen und die kinder würden mich zu dem ich zum komplett da würde ich
geistig müsste mich gleich wirklich die psychiatrie einliefern
die sind so nervig da würde ich echt
komplett die nerven verlieren also
so und das nächste wäre wahrscheinlich social media manager weil influenza sind
nach kindern die zweitnervigste gruppe an leuten
So, nee, wir gucken uns
den
Cyber Security Experten gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Zoo wäre noch cool.
Ich glaube Zoo ist ziemlich eklig.
Aber ich würde deutlich lieber im Zoo
arbeiten als mit Influencern
oder im Kindergarten.
Oh, Kinder sind so unglaublich nervig,
alter ich habe es jetzt schon 580.000 mal gesagt gesagt aber auch jedes mal wenn ich im supermarkt
bin alle einfach nur nervig gerade wenn an der kasse dann irgendwie wieder ein riesen aufstand
gemacht wird letztens auch wieder ein bisschen auf dem boden rumgerollt hat im edeka und was
mir persönlich am meisten auf den Sack geht,
ist, wenn du Leute
mit Kindern im Zug hast,
die es nicht schaffen, ihre Kinder mal ein bisschen
ruhig zu halten.
Wir reden hier von einer
Fahrt von, keine Ahnung,
25 Minuten oder so.
Die turnen dann da rum und
rennen rum und stolpern über Zeug drüber
oder sitzen neben den Eltern und schreien die ganze
Zeit. Die Eltern ignorieren es
und, boah, Kinder sind so
nervig, Alter.
Okay, egal. Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich schon...
Opa Max kann nix leiden, ich weiß.
Ja.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das hier an.
Also, der Cyber-Sicherheitsexperte.
Das Thema Cybersicherheit ist ein ständig sich wandelndes Fachgebiet.
Fachgebiet. Wir bereiten uns auf die
Hannover Messe vor, die größte Industriemesse.
Ist laut genug, Leute?
Windows
macht ja prinzipiell immer andere
Soundsettings zwischen zwei
Windows Sessions.
Ich glaube, es ist okay.
Mr. Hamek,
danke schön für den Sub.
Ich gucke mal kurz rein, nicht, dass ich wieder irgendwas vergessen habe.
Ich übersehe ja manchmal Sachen.
Was ist das?
Ich bin ausgelockt in Twitch.
Geil.
Ja, gut.
Äh, da muss ich auf mein Handy gucken.
Warum bin ich ausgelockt in Twitch, Alter?
Morgen, Kais.
Handy, Bitch, eingelockt.
Was? Stimmt, warum hab ich Untertitel an?
Ich hab übrigens auch schon bei euch
gesehen, dass YouTube gerade wieder
testweise einen neuen Player
ausgerollt hat.
YouTube neuer Player?
Mit so runden, da sind die Knöpfe alle so rund
und floten so komisch.
Gestern haben wir
mir auf dem anderen Rechner bekommen.
Und ich gesehen.
Gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht können wir es ja reproduzieren,
indem wir das mal hier drinnen aufmachen.
Hier ist auch noch alt.
Anscheinend noch nicht.
Ich mag den auch nicht
Aber es ist immer so
Neue YouTube Änderungen mag ich
Prinzipiell immer erstmal nicht
So, ups, jetzt habe ich meinen Stream selbst aufgebaut
Das wollte ich doch gar nicht
Ich wollte hier in den Stream Manager
Da wollte ich hin
So, und dann wollte ich gucken
Subscriptions
Übrigens auch danke für die ganzen Follows, Leute
Richtig viele Follows.
Gut, dann schauen wir uns mal den Cyber Security Experte an.
Okay, da läuft was rot.
Das Thema Cybersicherheit...
Was? Was? Da läuft was? Was wird da?
Okay, da läuft was rot.
Da läuft was rot?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Das Thema Cybersicherheit ist ein ständig sich wandelndes Fachgebiet.
Wir bereiten uns auf die Hannover Messe vor.
Terminal, Terminal muss ich gucken.
...Sicherheit ist ein...
PIP Install
Aha
Ubuntu stellt's
So so
Ubuntu
... sich wandelndes Fachgebiet. Wir bereiten uns auf die Hannover Messe vor, die größte Industriemesse.
In dem Zuge müssen wir uns auch nochmal einen Demonstrator anschauen. Das ist so ein automatisierter Kicker.
Schauen wir mal, hoffentlich läuft der.
Wenn ich Promovieze habe, werde ich auf jeden Fall in die Wirtschaft.
Chat.
Auf jedem Team-Event oder so
stehen die Leute immer voll auf
Kickerspielen.
Bin ich der Einzige, der Kickerspielen übelst doof findet
und gar keinen Bock drauf hat?
Sobald es irgendwo Tischkicker gibt,
schampen die Leute alle da voll hin und
yeah, Kicker.
Ich denke mir so, pff, Alter.
Wen juckt's?
Ich hasse Kickerspielen. Ja, ich auch.
Also, wenn es irgendein Team-Event gibt und ich die Auswahl habe zwischen Kicker spielen
oder kostenlos Sachen futtern, dann fresse ich lieber das ganze Buffet da leer, bevor
ich Tischkicker spiele.
Letztes Team-Building-Event ist bei uns schon ein bisschen her, paar Monate her.
ich habe glaube ich an diesem einen tag an zwei tagen habe ich glaube ich vier kilo zugenommen
nur durch fressen natürlich habe ich wirklich viel kilo zugenommen die tage später ging es
wieder runter das war halt einfach nur weil einfach ich sage ich war immer das muss ich
euch kurz erzählen was ich da gefordert habe also team event ob ich das überhaupt zusammen
kriegt übelst. Also, ich bin mit dem Fahrrad
hingefahren, das ist nicht so weit weg gewesen.
Von mir war ich eineinhalb Stunden unterwegs.
Also, erster Tag ging
schon los. Direkt morgens
stand da, ist da so eine Mini
Snack-Ecke gewesen.
Hab ich erstmal, weil ich Fahrrad gefahren bin, weil ich mega Hunger
hab, ich bin richtig schnell gefahren,
eineinhalb Stunden, hab ich erstmal drei Stücke
so komischen Zimtkuchen
gefuttert. So.
Und in dieser
Snackecke gab es halt sau viel,
was gefährlich ist. Da gab es
so jede Menge
Süßkram, Kuchenkram und sonst was
erstmal weggefuttert.
So, dann habe ich bestimmt
während dem
ähm, während diesem
Workshop, habe ich bestimmt
noch drei oder vier
kleine, kleine 0,3
Fantas getrunken, also auch
Brutalsucker.
Dann, ähm, gab's
Gab's Mittagessen, das war gar nicht so viel, weil das war nicht Buffet.
Und zwischendurch habe ich auch wieder in der Snackecke den ganzen Tag gefuttert.
Dann habe ich abends, aber abends habe ich richtig, Leute, abends habe ich richtig zugeschlagen.
Also, da gab es eine, also, war auf so einer Terrasse, das Restaurant da und da gab es quasi so eine kleine, kleine Karte mit Auswahl, so, ich habe gegessen, normalerweise hätte mir eine Hauptspeise gereicht und ich habe den ganzen Tag schon, ich war schon, ich hatte schon gar keinen Hunger mehr richtig, abends so viel habe ich den ganzen Tag gefuttert, ja.
also richtig, richtig
PepoFatTime, so
und dann, abends habe ich mir
bestellt
Handkäs mit Musik
kennt ihr das, das ist was
sehr hessisches
das ist Käse
das sind Scheiben Käse mit Kümmel
bisschen Brot und so einer
was ist das, so Creme oder so
ne, keine Creme, irgendwas zum reintunken
ja
Handkäs
mit Musik
Ja, so, so, so in der Richtung, ja, genau
So, da kam, genau, da kam dann auch so
Hab ich, hab ich erstmal
Es war wirklich eine ordentliche, wirklich ordentliche Portion, die es da gegeben hat
So, Vorspeise, Handkäs mit Musik
Danach war ich eigentlich schon, danach war ich eigentlich schon satt
Max, du siehst heute gut aus
Wieso? Weil ich so viel gefuttert hab auf meinem Team-Event?
Oder wie kommst du da drauf?
Du meinst den hier?
So
Danach war ich eigentlich schon satt
Aber
Danach
Moment
Oh, juckt
Was ist das hier?
Danach
habe ich mir noch
Fried Chicken bestellt.
Auch ganz furchtbar kalorienarm.
Kalorienarm. Fried Chicken.
Gab es dann so
zwei große Stücke frittierte Hähnchenbrust
mit Pommes frites.
Und Dip.
Fried Chicken.
So.
Und ich habe das kaum gepackt.
So voll war ich schon.
Ich habe das kaum reingekriegt.
Aber als ich damit fertig
zu essen war,
habe ich mir dann noch Vanilleeis bestellt.
Noch mal oben drauf.
Das musst du halt nicht selbst bezahlen.
Ich weiß nicht, kennt ihr das?
Sobald es kostenlos zu essen gibt,
muss so krass vollgestopft werden,
weil man ja sonst irgendwie was verschenken würde.
Und...
Ja.
Und den nächsten Tag ging es dann weiter.
Und deswegen, ich hatte dann
ungefähr 4 Kilo oder so Essen im Umlauf,
weil ich hab mich dann auf die Waage gestellt
und hatte irgendwie 4 Kilo mehr.
Das ist mittlerweile wieder
alles weg und ging dann auch schnell runter.
Aber das war halt einfach alles, weil das
es war halt alles voll.
Ja, es war voll von oben bis unten.
Nach diesem Team-Event.
So.
Das Torwartspiel.
So schlimm war das gar nicht.
Da war ja nix krass ungesundes, irgendwie super spicy mäßiges dabei.
Das ging eigentlich ganz gut.
So.
Jetzt gucken wir uns aber das Video an.
Ja, Hacken für größte Industriemessen. Gehalt eines Cybersecurity-Experten.
Okay, da läuft mir was rot.
Das Thema Cybersicherheit ist ein ständig sich wandelndes Fachgebiet.
Wir bereiten uns auf die Hannover Messe vor, die größte Industriemesse.
In dem Zuge müssen wir uns auch noch mal einen Demonstrator anschauen.
Das ist ein automatisierter Kicker. Schauen wir mal, hoffentlich läuft der.
Wenn ich promoviert habe, werde ich auf jeden Fall in die Wirtschaft gehen.
Hi, ich bin Max, bin 28 Jahre alt und wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter
Mitarbeiter im Bereich Cybersicherheit am Fraunhofer-Institut.
Alles fit im Schritt. Das ist auch so ein Spruch, das ist schon so Facebook-Boomer, Mann.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht ihn, sondern er hat das ja nur die abgekürzte Variante gesagt.
Aber alles fit im Schritt ist wirklich so ein übelster Boomer-Spruch.
Das ist nicht für Freifäder.
Menschen.
Hexor. Die guten Thinkpads. Habt ihr's gesehen? Der weiß was taugt.
Hier, die guten Thinkpads mit dem Knubbel.
So, was steht heute an? Heute steht viel an. Wir sind quasi die nächsten Wochen auf der Hannover Messe. Genau, müssen da noch mal eine finale Absprache machen.
Ansonsten habe ich heute tatsächlich Studententag mit Terminen, mit unseren Studierenden.
Was ist die Auflösung? Die Auflösung ist irgendwie... Warum ist die Auflösung so 480p?
The fuck?
Wollte gerade sagen, das sieht irgendwie so pixelig aus.
So, Kaffee wird getrunken jetzt. Gehen wir mal runter.
Käffchen.
Boah, ich weiß nicht, wollen wir hier reinfüllen?
Nächster Gannerpunkt.
Das gibt es da nicht kostenlos.
Wir schaun uns an, ob unsere Demos alle laufen.
Ein Demonstrator ist quasi eine Veranschaulichung von den Technologien, die wir entwickeln.
Normalerweise, vor allem jetzt in dem Bereich Cybersicherheit, wenn wir da jetzt was entwickeln, ist es immer schwer greifbar.
Und wir versuchen das, damit auch quasi fachfremde Leute das verstehen, eben so aufzubereiten, dass man sieht, was quasi diese Lösungen bewirken.
Das ist unser Showroom.
Was wir auf die Messe mitnehmen, ist insbesondere hier diesen Demonstrator.
Das ist quasi meiner.
Demonstrator.
wenn auch später mal irgendwas erkennen hier diesen demonstrieren
wenn ich da irgendwas
in den wlan dingen würde ich sagen
router
dann irgendwas mit wie er wäre es dass diese diese hutschiene stelle
hutschienen fassung
Gibt es ja mittlerweile auch Raspberry Pi Mounts für.
Und was das da ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Das hier.
Das ist ein Netzteil, ja.
Ja, ja.
Das sieht man auch hier.
24 Volt, 1,5 Ampere.
Input 100 bis 42 Volt AC.
Ganz normales Netzteil, ja.
Aber was das da ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Das ist ein Mini-PC.
Ja, mit
serieller Schnittstelle noch, so wie das sein muss.
Demonstrator, das ist quasi meiner.
Das ist das Security Gateway.
Da werden wir auch später noch ein bisschen mehr zu sehen.
Aber ich gucke mir das erstmal einfach an, ob alles läuft.
Bist du aufgeregt? Ja, ein bisschen. Es ist jetzt nicht mein erster Messeauftritt, aber quasi der erste, wo ich wirklich dann mit meiner eigenen Demo da bin.
Das heißt auch mehr oder weniger die Verantwortung für Trager, dass alles funktioniert.
So ganz habe ich jetzt den Zusammenhang zu Cybersecurity noch nicht verstanden.
Zumindest von meiner Seite. So, dann haben wir die Demo jetzt auch zum Laufen gebracht. War doch gut, dass wir nochmal gecheckt haben, ob alles funktioniert.
Moin. Was geht ab? Was geht ab?
das ist quasi unser automatisierter kicker das hat mit cybersicherheit nichts zu tun jetzt nicht dass
es keinen bock macht dann sowas zu basteln das ist genau quasi ein demonstrator und da oben eine
kamera verbaut die detektiert quasi ein ball der sich hier bewegt kann darüber die position dann
bestimmen und genau quasi diese beiden achsen hier steuern einmal die abwehrspiele bin ich nicht ich
Ich bin der Wubblors, wie man hier sieht.
Eindeutig.
Hatten wir uns schon ein paar.
Ich weiß nicht mehr. Wer ist denn der Max eigentlich?
Ja, erstaunlich, ne?
Dass viele Leute am Start sind.
So.
Wahrscheinlich doch zu auffällig
mit meinem Keks-Avatar.
Warum bist du nicht mehr auf YouTube?
Letztes Jahr kein... Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich habe ja vorhin im stream schon erzählen noch mal erzähle ich jetzt nicht um ich gerade bisschen wenig antrieb habe irgendwas zu machen
Und den torwart also das ziel mehr oder weniger von dem kicker ist es jetzt
quasi bälle zu halten und das ziel von uns von den menschen ist es quasi ein tor zu schießen das thema cyber sicherheit ist aktuell noch
Nicht mit inbegriffen ist aber für die nächsten jahre geplant
Genau die idee ist es auch die kicker zeigen ich habe ein bisschen angst und ganz ehrlich zu sein
Niklas, Herr Kollege, die Kamera funktioniert nicht.
Direkt Abmahnung.
Sieht man ein Bild?
Ja.
Echt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ah ja.
Schön, ey.
Mach ihn!
Mach ihn, er macht ihn!
Mario Götze!
Ich bin gerade über das Profilbild auf dich gestoßen.
Ja, ist doch zu auffällig, ne?
Das macht für uns aber auch keinen Sinn.
Das System ist doch zu kalibrieren,
weil wir eben diesen Kicker bekleben müssen.
Und um den Kicker bekleben zu können,
müssen wir den Kicker erstmal auseinanderschrauben.
Er hat jetzt auch ne...
Ah!
Die gute Vera-Zyklop-Ratsche.
Mit dem Vera Rapi... Rapi...
Rapi... Dingsbums?
Wie heißt dieses Teil vorne der Bit-Halter?
Vera Rapi... Rapigator?
Oder irgendwie so?
Rapidaptor. Rapidaptor heißt er, glaube ich.
Das Ding ist wirklich gut.
Das kann ich empfehlen. Das habe ich auch.
Die Vera-Zyklop-Ratsche.
So.
Jetzt sind wir fertig.
Jetzt kann der Kicker quasi beklebt werden.
So, bis später, ne?
Moin.
Dapidapdo hört sich wie ein Dinosaurier an.
Stimmt.
Ey, zum Thema Dinosaurier, ne?
Ah.
Okay, ich bin nicht mal eingeloggt.
Gestern ein Bild gepostet,
wo ich unter einem T-Rex
ähm
T-Rex Skelett stehe.
Ja, man findet halt hier auf X nichts mehr, ne?
Warum ist X eigentlich so unglaublich beschissen geworden?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären mal?
Du findest hier nichts mehr.
Vibe-Coding. Ohne Scheiß, das wirkt wie Vibe-Coding.
Es wirkt wie Vibe-Coding.
Guck mal, da war ich noch 10 Kilo dicker.
Oder 15 Kilo.
Tico Tico
Tja, dann zeige ich euch, was die linke Post, Moment, Nitta gibt's wieder
Oder ist es deine eigene?
Was ist denn post.org?
Oder ist das deine Domain?
Ist das ein selbst gehostetes Nitta von dir?
Ja, guckt.
Ja.
Gestern drunter gestanden.
Sieht schon echt groß aus, das Ding.
Senckenberg-Museum-Stelz.
Ganz schön zähne.
Ja, keine Ahnung, wie ich jetzt da drauf gekommen bin.
Wir gucken uns den Cyber-Security-Experten jetzt weiter an.
Ich habe jetzt quasi noch ein paar Meetings mit Studenten, also Mittwoch ist quasi mein
Studitag auch.
Genau, schauen wir uns mal an, was so in den letzten Wochen passiert ist und was als nächstes
dann folgt.
Moin, alles fit?
Jo.
Schauen wir mal, so wie sieht es aus.
Wir wollen erstmal das System zum Laufen bringen.
Der soll über die Kamera den Ball quasi detektieren, quasi unabhängig auch von der Position, wo
Ball ist, den dann aufheben und zu einer
bestimmten Endposition dann auch führen.
Das hat aber immer noch nichts mit
Cybersecurity irgendwie zu tun.
Diese Logik, die
den Roboter das sagt, was er tun
soll, das werden wir dann auslagern, eben
auf dem IT-System. Im ersten Schritt auf
einen PC, im zweiten Schritt auf eine Cloud.
Heute ohne Facecam, ja ausnahmsweise keine Facecam.
...anbindung über 5G herstellen, dann fangen wir an eben zu schauen, wo die
Sicherheitsschwachstellen sind. Sind wir hoffentlich so...
Was? Moment, was? Was zum...?
Im ersten Schritt auf einen PC, im zweiten Schritt auf eine Cloud, genau,
dann eben diese Anbindung über 5G herstellen, dann fangen wir an eben zu schauen,
wo die Sicherheitsschwachstellen sind.
Warum zum Teufel sollte ich einen Monitorarm in Steuerung über die Cloud machen?
Hoffentlich so April, Mai sind wir damit durch und danach können wir dann wirklich ans Eingemachte gehen, die Angriffe implementieren.
Gut, cool, vielen Dank.
Die Studierenden sollen bei uns natürlich auch was lernen und insbesondere natürlich auch aktiv in Projekte mit eingebunden werden.
Das heißt, neben diesem theoretischen Teil in der Uni ist es natürlich, hoffe ich zumindest, auch schön für die Studierenden da einfach auch bei dem praktischen Teil zu sehen und an wirklich realistischen Anwendungsfällen auch mitzuarbeiten.
Die müssen jetzt...
Aha.
Das haben wir heute Morgen ja schon gesehen.
Das ist quasi unser Security Gateway.
Der Philipp war quasi auch maßgeblich mit beteiligt bei der Entwicklung von dem Security Gateway.
Genau, jetzt kommt quasi Jonas...
Aha.
Ein...
Läuft das Ubuntu-Ding hier drauf, oder wie?
Dazu, ein Werkstudent bei mir, hat in seiner Bachelor-Bite Angriffe implementiert.
Und wir werden das jetzt quasi hier einmal auf diesen...
Angriffe implementiert.
Ja.
Let's do it.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Was wir hier sehen, das ist quasi ein Fräsprozess.
Das ist jetzt eine Simulation davon, dass das Tool, das Machine Tool,
das sich auf einem Bauteil bewegt, also quasi in einem Bauteil fräst.
Wir versuchen jetzt quasi diesen Datenstrom, der zwischen diesem Gerät und diesem Gerät hier stattfindet,
zu verändern, indem wir da nämlich dann quasi Angriffe fahren.
Hä?
dass die fräse was anderes frisst
dafür habe ich mitgebracht haben wir hier schön arbeiten kann ja also es kann sein
dass wir hier kein kein netz haben schon wieder schon wieder hacking nicht möglich
wird es keine die maus ist vollkommen also ich drücke die ganze zeit auf
Was war denn der Sudo?
Up, get, install, python3, pip.
Okay, ja gut.
Und dann macht er gar nichts. Immer diese Informatiker.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer, was die da eigentlich gerade machen.
Du darfst jetzt weitermachen, komm. Wir haben ja auch einen Lehrauftrag hier am Frauenhof.
Oh, Hackerman.
Was auch immer.
Ja, läuft mir das rot.
Also wir schaffen es zumindest schon mal, quasi das System zum Abbrechen zu bewegen.
Ja, wenn der Angriff durchgeführt wird.
Das ist quasi noch nicht das große Ziel.
Also wir müssen da wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr Arbeit...
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich sehe das anders.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die auf der Demomaschine selbst was installieren,
sondern auf ihrem...
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Was die da haben?
Irgendeinen netten Notebook oder so?
Weil wenn du
physischen Zugriff auf die
Steuerungseinheit von
der Fräse hast, dann
kann man
nicht vorstellen.
Die haben da irgendeine
Kiste stehen, von der
sie versuchen, auf die andere zuzugreifen.
Wenn die selbst
da läuft ja auch kein Ubuntu
drauf auf der Fräsensteuerung,
oder?
Also keiner, ich verstehe es auch nicht so genau, was sie da eigentlich machen.
Quasi reininvestieren, wir können dann jetzt wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Tagen nochmal schauen, dass wir das optimiert bekommen, damit wir den Angriff auch wirklich durchführen können.
Wenn wir das jetzt in den nächsten Wochen schaffen, können wir das eventuell sogar zum Messer mitnehmen.
So, wir bauen das System jetzt wieder zurück.
Ich habe absolut nicht gecheckt, was sie eigentlich probiert haben.
Beziehungsweise, was sie probiert, sie wollten, dass die Fräse nicht mehr richtig fräst.
okay aber was sie da gemacht keine ahnung ich promo wie auch hier am fraunhofer ipt ich
persönlich eben auch in dem bereich der cybersicherheit ich guck da aus der ingenieurs
perspektive drauf normalerweise investiere ich so eine stunde vielleicht am tag in die
destination das wird sich aber natürlich dann auch quasi mit den nächsten jahren je näher man
dem ende des quasi kommt natürlich dann auch noch mal etwas steigern ich glaube den beitrag
hätten wir echt besser machen können ich denke schon dass sie da interessantes zeug machen aber
Aber so wirklich was gesehen hat man jetzt nicht, was da eigentlich so abgeht.
Ich verdiene 4.986 Euro brutto.
Das sind dann 3.047 Euro netto.
Wir haben noch quasi eine Erfolgsbeteiligung und auch eine leistungsbezogene Prämie,
eine Prämie, die halt eben von verschiedenen Faktoren abhängt.
Zum einen natürlich von Fraunhofer, als auch natürlich von meiner Leistung.
Wenn ich promoviert habe, werde ich auf jeden Fall in die Wirtschaft gehen.
Für mich lohnt sich das mega. Man muss natürlich so eine gewisse Motivation mitbringen.
Man muss auch ein gewisses Interesse für die Thematik mitbringen,
insbesondere wenn man promovieren möchte. Mit dem Geld bin ich auch zufrieden.
Man kann da sehr gut von leben, insbesondere hier in Aachen.
Dementsprechend, ja, von meiner Seite aus, es lohnt sich.
Ist das mein Auto?
Hey!
Ja, meine letzte große Anschaffung war tatsächlich ein Auto.
Genau, hab mir dann Toyota Aygo quasi beschafft, um dann eben ein bisschen freier zu sein.
Was die Mobilität angeht, hab ich mir dann tatsächlich letztes Wochenende ein Auto gekauft.
chat auto von meinem fiat sind die connect services abgelaufen und ich habe mich erst
gefragt warum bei mir das nicht funktioniert mehr mit batterie anzeigen und sonst was
und ich sag euch die seite von fiat zum verlängern dieser services alter ist die scheiße
das ist glaube ich so ziemlich die beschissenste seite die man hätte machen können
nee das war einfach nur jetzt zweieinhalb jahre mit drin im preis vom neuen auto und
jetzt läuft das quasi
theoretisch
gibt es das sogar als Monatsabo.
Aber die Fiat-Seite ist so
dermaßen beschissen gewesen, ey.
Diese Uconnect-Seite.
Also, hätten die
zu mir gesagt, Max, mach mal die schlechteste
Webseite, die du machen kannst.
Ich hätte es nicht schlechter machen
können, ne?
Also das ist echt für den Arsch.
Na, alles gut?
Ja, klein aber fein. Man kann hier auf jeden Fall ganz gut kochen.
Später kommen noch ein paar Freunde vorbei und wir machen heute Pizza zusammen.
Das wird ein Schmaus.
Das ist natürlich wichtig.
Dass die Leute immer so sozial sind.
Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock abends bei mir noch irgendwie Action zu machen, wenn
ich von der Arbeit komme.
Da bin ich im Arsch.
Hallo, schön, dass du hier bist.
Das hat er selber realisiert für die Doku.
Moment, die haben einen...
Die haben einen Steinohr, nein, das ist kein Steinohr, die haben einen extra Ofen für die Pizzes, aber advanced jetzt.
Achso, das Lied ist bestimmt Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
So, Runde 1, wer will anschneiden hier?
Was das für ein scheiß Song ist, ja, irgendwelches deutsches Hip-Hop-Zeug, das ist halt einfach egal was, Crap.
Und wir wollen auch das Gleiche.
Ich kann es dir beweisen.
Es klingelt an der Tür.
Dann kommt der Lieferant mit dem dampfenden Symbol unserer Hoffnung in der Hand.
Was ein Schatz.
Die heilige Scheibe, die alle vereint.
Weil es das AI generiert, könnte ich mir schon vorstellen.
Seit der Mensch...
Oh, ich glaube fest daran, dass uns Pizza retten kann.
So, das war mein Tag.
Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Okay, jetzt...
Jetzt wissen wir nicht wirklich, was sie da Cyber Security mäßig machen, oder?
Also da haben wir schon bessere Beiträge.
Außer, dass sie Scappy installiert haben über Pip.
hast du den 0.1 und 0,1 engineer gesehen du meinst von ihm hier ich glaube ich habe
letztens von ihm was gesehen der der fox engineer ich muss ja sagen die videos haben so viel auf
wo ich finde die meisten videos nicht lustig das ist irgendwie nicht nicht trifft nicht so
normalen humor richtig youtube empfehlung aller
wollen wir noch den vertriebsleiter gucken dass ich ein bisschen lästern
kann über über außendienst und marketing stellst oder was haben wir sonst zu
bieten windows 10 ende so einfach geht es zu linux ok einfach einfach geht es
zu linux tatsächlich ist halt die frage ob man wirklich noch alles machen kann
was man machen will damit spiele mit anti cheat ist vorbei aber ansonsten
geht ja mittlerweile das meiste
Okay, komm, komm.
Battlefield 6 geht auch auf Windows.
Ohne Secure Boot geht es nicht.
Okay, dann gucken wir den Vertrieb.
Hippla.
Okay.
Ja, aber denk an,
Secure Boot hier.
Sonst kannst du manche Sachen nicht spielen.
Also was ich ja ganz cool fand, das Video können wir gucken.
Das wollte ich mir nämlich schon die ganze Zeit angucken.
Ich habe jetzt nämlich einiges über CachyOS schon gelesen.
Und das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut, deswegen wollte ich mir das Video mal angucken.
Aber schauen wir uns doch mal an, was der Vertriebler im Außendienst...
Das ist auch so ein Job, da müsstest du mich einliefern danach.
Also Außendienst ist ja wirklich, also okay, das ist, also wir hatten ja hier, nein, nein, ich bin nicht mal, ich bin wupplos, wir hatten ja jetzt hier schon Sachen, also wie gesagt, am wenigsten Bock hätte ich hier auf den Job im Kindergarten, das würde mich den ganzen Tag einfach nur abfacken und ich müsste mich aufregen.
so
danach kommt
arbeiten mit Influencern hätte ich noch weniger
Bock, also ne, ne, noch weniger, nur
minimalst mehr Bock drauf
und Außendienstmitarbeiter ist das
nächste worauf ich da auch nur minimalst mehr
Bock hätte, aber alles nie im Leben machen würde
Außendienst ist
grausam
und ich arbeite aktuell bei einer Versicherung
ich weiß, also ich kenne
Außendienstleute
Im Leben nicht.
Ist dieses Jahr eigentlich das Jahr,
ist es jedes Jahr das Jahr des Linux-Desktops?
...der nach Leistung bezahlt wird.
Ich kann es mir nicht erlauben,
meine normalen 100% zu geben,
sondern es wird natürlich von mir erwartet,
dass ich mehr mache.
Im Vertrieb ist es einfach so,
dass man Zahlen bringen muss.
Hi, ich bin Markus, ich bin 34 Jahre alt.
Das ist halt das richtige
Crimeset-Mindset hier.
Ich bin im Praktikstraußendienst tätig
und ich verkaufe Cloud-Telefonsysteme.
Cloud-Telefonsysteme?
Also, also heißt
im Endeffekt
was ist ein Cloud-Telefonsystem?
Ein
ich würde mir halt vorstellen, ein VoIP-Anbieter
der halt irgendwelche
Telefonie-Services
anbietet.
Oder? So was in der Richtung.
Jabber.
Nee, Jabber werden die nicht verkaufen. Kein Mensch
benutzt im Jahr 2025 noch Jabber.
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand? Kennt ihr noch Jabber?
Telefonanlage im Netz. Ja, also im Prinzip
sowas, wie ich gesagt habe. Das ist quasi so
ein VoIP-Anbieter der Telefonie-Services.
das äh, as a service
quasi verkauft.
Okay.
Wir müssen noch ein bisschen zu früh, wir müssen noch ganz kurz warten.
Ach, so geht es nicht wieder auf.
Du bist aber fertig, gell?
Ich habe ein paar Macken, äh, das ist so,
ne, ich, die...
Echt, es gibt auch Leute, die Jabber benutzen? Krass.
Diese Pünktlichkeit
ist so, ich, pünktlich, ich muss immer pünktlich sein.
Warum ist die Auflösung
so schlecht?
Jetzt ist sie besser.
Das YouTube hat gefaked, das war überhaupt nicht 1080p. Das stand nur da.
Java, hallo. So, bis gleich.
So, let's go, die Arbeit.
Let's go, Kreiselkrieg startet.
Ich verkaufe etwas, dann denkt jemand, oh, da kommt jetzt der Verkäufer und der will mir irgendwie was andrehen.
Und ich habe mir immer gesagt, nein, ich will nicht dieser schmierige Verkäufer werden.
Ich fühle mich als Typ einfach locker, lässig.
Okay, eins kann ich euch sagen.
Ich arbeite jetzt eine Weile schon bei einer Versicherung.
Die Gehirnwäsche, die dort passiert, bei den Außendienstleuten, ist enorm.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es bei dem auch so ist,
aber viele der Außendienstleute denken wirklich, sie retten die Menschheit.
In Wirklichkeit verkaufen sie irgendwann mal was, was sie nicht braucht.
Guten Morgen!
Was ist das wieder für Musik?
So sieht eigentlich der klassische Tag bei mir aus.
Angebote mit dem Kunden noch konkretisieren,
Verkaufsgespräche führen
oder auch natürlich die Akquise,
ob jetzt Social Media, Telefon.
Das ist Linkin Park, oder?
Ja, ja.
Das ist heute ein Kunde, ein Autohaus aus der Region, der heute kommt. Er weiß gar nicht,
was ihn erwartet und deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, wie das dann heute wird. Wenn ich
mein Umsatzziel von 500.000, was ich dieses Jahr habe, erst mal Powerpoint-Stells machen,
dann habe ich eine Provision ausgezahlt, die aufs Grundgehalt noch mit drauf kommt.
Das, was ich heute mache, ist das, was ich wirklich liebe. Ich liebe es,
mich hier hinzustellen, vor den Kunden zu präsentieren, zu zeigen, zu begeistern.
Ja gut, es gibt Leute, die machen sowas gerne, da ist ja nichts dagegen zu sagen.
Und ich merke ja schon, wenn der Kunde lächelt, wenn er einfach seine Emotionen zeigt.
Und es gibt ein paar Sachen in meiner Präsentation oder auch in meiner Lösung,
wo ich weiß zu 100 Prozent, das gefällt jedem.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen Außendienst-Dings gegen Wäsche schon.
Ich sag doch, viele von denen denken wirklich, sie machen die Welt besser.
Ich kenne das von uns drin.
Ich muss nochmal schnell in mein Büro ran huschen, noch meine Maus holen.
Ich bin ein Mitarbeiter, der nach Leistung bezahlt wird.
Ich laufe jetzt noch ein bisschen schneller her.
Ich nehme noch Headset kurz mit.
Ich meine immer noch besser als irgendwelche DVG-Vertreter und sowas.
Maus, Headset, Tastatur, Hammer, Check to Check.
Ich nehme noch mein anderes Handy mit.
Und mein Tee ist abgekühlt.
Hast du mit denen viel zu tun?
Nee, eigentlich kaum.
... und im Vertrieb ist es einfach so, dass man Zahlen bringen muss.
Guten Morgen.
Hi, Servus.
So, ihr seid super früh, ne?
Wir sind sehr gespannt, was uns heute erwartet.
Aufgrund der letzten E-Mail bin ich ein bisschen besorgt, dass das funktioniert.
Ich bin auch immer besorgt, dass es funktioniert.
Surferstand eben noch nicht auf dem aktuellsten Bereich ist.
Wir gucken uns das an, das ist kein Hexenwerk.
Das ist mir auch wichtig, dass ich immer ganz ehrlich bin eigentlich.
Also ich würde den Leuten sagen, ne, wir haben wenig J-Boss.
Wir wollten nichts irgendwie aufschwatzen, was nicht funktioniert.
Ihr wollt ja wirklich eure Erreichbarkeit erhöhen.
Euch sagen die Leute, ihr seid nicht erreichbar, da geht kein Telefon, es ist besetzt.
Für euch ist natürlich auch ganz, ganz wichtig, jeder verpasste Anruf ist ja ein potenzieller Kunde.
das ist euer anruf beantworte und diesen anruf beantworte könnt ihr
wenn wir nicht verkauft den anruf beantworte wir sind im jahr 2025 aller ich wusste gar nicht dass
das so die krasse geschichte ist aber stimmt ei anruf beantworte selber programmieren ich zeige
ich das ganze mal hier ja das ist ein bisschen alles gut nicht so kompliziert wie es aussieht
es gab natürlich ein paar skeptik was was was ist das hier was sieht man da
was bin ich sehend keine ahnung
es gab natürlich ein paar skeptische blicke jetzt kommen wir zur live präsentation hoffentlich
funktioniert alles nach genau so jetzt ich bin nicht dran gegangen jetzt ging es bei der
zentrale zentrales aber auch gerade machen brauchen was immer nicht der platz jetzt
macht bitte eine nachricht noch dazu ich würde gerne ein fahrzeug kaufen
die 1234 bitte diesen start gemacht hast
Es ist ein Anrufbeantworter, Alter! So was hat er mal vor 30 Jahren, 40 Jahren schon!
Ich dachte, das Ding kann wenigstens AI-mäßig erkennen, was der Typ gesagt hat und kann
er zusammen... whatever.
Ja, hoffentlich Sprache zu Text.
Der Kunde hat Emotionen gezeigt.
Wegen einem Anrufbeantworter. Emotionen.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, wenn es einfach nur ein Anrufbeantworter in der Cloud ist, ohne irgendwelche spezialen neuen Zusatzfunktionen.
Eine ernst gemeinte Frage, warum ist das besser, als vor 30 Jahren eine Kiste mit einem Band drinne?
Ich würde heute auch keine Kiste mehr mit einem Band drinne verwenden.
Aber was ist von der Funktion her denn jetzt da der große Vorteil, dass ich das in der Cloud brauche?
Er hat gelacht, er hat mitgemacht.
Ja, genau.
Ausfallsicherheit.
Okay, das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Wobei ich denke, dass selbst die Oldschool-Dinger mit einem Band drin so gut wie nie ausgefallen sind.
Ich habe sehr viel Zeit und Energie in diesen Kunden investiert.
Ich wäre schon traurig, wenn es nicht zum Abschluss kommt.
Ja, grundsätzlich gefällt mir das, was ich gesehen habe.
Fragen habe ich heute keine mehr.
Es ist alles sehr gut erklärt.
Wir setzen uns jetzt damit auseinander.
Und dann...
Das Band kann nur einen Anruf gleichzeitig.
Das ist richtig.
Da hast du recht.
Ja.
Wenn die mehrere Telefone irgendwie Leitung haben,
ja, okay.
Wenn man das verbindet mit irgendeiner Cloud-Telefonanlage, das soll quasi auch an mehrere Mitarbeiter weiterleiten, okay, lass ich mir gefallen, habt ihr recht.
Aber das kannst du im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich sogar mit einer Fritzbox machen.
Da hat die auch einen Anrufbeantworter.
Aber ist egal.
Ich verstehe schon.
Aber ich meine jetzt diese krasse neue Sache mit Anrufbeantworter in der Cloud sehe ich
jetzt die Emotion und Experience Innovation sehe ich da jetzt nicht so.
Ich sage es mal so, es könnte schneller gehen mit den Abschlüssen.
Wir hatten schon Verträge, das hat erst nach einem Jahr zum Abschluss gekommen.
Schön, dass ihr da wart, die Dame zuerst. Vielen lieben Dank fürs Dasein.
Ladies first, so wie ich das gehöre.
Wir quatschen, wir halten Kontakt.
Genau.
Bei meinem Umsatzziel von den 500.000 habe ich aktuell, stehe ich bei ungefähr 195.000.
Und das ist für den jetzigen Stand sehr gut. Ich bin über meinem Soll.
Wenn die Zahlen nicht stimmen würden, würde mich das definitiv unter Druck setzen, weil man weiß dann, dass man mehr performen muss oder besser performen muss.
Da muss man überlegen, was lief in der letzten Zeit schief.
Super, so machen wir es. Dankeschön. Ciao.
Super, sehr gut.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe jetzt nochmal so ungefähr eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Okay, aber eins muss man dem zugutehalten
Im Vergleich zu vielen anderen dieser Videos
Der schafft wirklich den ganzen Tag
Also, das muss man ja
So mal Vertrieb Leuten lassen und so
Die haben teilweise echt heftiges Arbeitspensum
Kenn ich auch von unseren
Also
Die sind da teilweise schon
Das ist schon ein harter Kreiselgrind
Warum die zu ihm kommen?
Naja, weil wenn du eine Demo zeigen willst,
wo für irgendeinen Laden mit zig Telefonen und sonst was,
kannst du ja bei denen nicht einfach anschließen.
Die müssen da hinkommen für die Demo.
Das macht ja schon Sinn.
Die können ja schlecht ihre Demo irgendwie dort vor Ort aufbauen,
in irgendeiner Abstellkammer oder so.
Ich benutze übrigens, mal so, kleines Ding am Rande,
wir haben auf der Arbeit auch solche Jabra-Headsets.
Benutze ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich benutze seit ein paar Monaten für die Arbeit dieses Ding hier.
Und das kann ich echt empfehlen.
Also das habe ich mir selbst gekauft.
Das Ding.
Benutze ich seit ein paar Monaten für die Arbeit.
Das ist ein Knochenschallkopfhörer.
Du hast die Ohren frei.
Guckt.
Das geht über Knochenschall.
Du hörst quasi alles von dem Kopfhörer, hörst aber auch noch drumherum was.
Und das Gute ist, dass du dann halt auch nicht so rumschreist und so.
Hält das 8 Stunden?
Also ich hab's letztens den ganzen Tag verwendet, das waren aber keine 8 Stunden, ohne aufzuladen
zwischendurch.
Aber ich hab auch nicht den ganzen Tag telefoniert.
Trinkt man das dann 24-7?
Kannste, wenn du willst, aber ich seh keinen Sinn
daraus, das irgendwie nachts anzuhaben.
Ich hab das nur, also ich hab das im Büro
halt auf, weil ich hab gemerkt, dass
ich mit Kopfhörern,
ich schreie immer so rum und sowas.
Und damit nicht. Damit redet man
ganz normal. Qualität ist auch okay.
Die Audioqualität
ist jetzt sicherlich nicht hier krasses
Hi-Fi-Stells.
Aber ich hab ja noch so eins,
nur ohne Mikrofon zum Joggen.
Der Sound ist fürs Laufen vollkommen ausreichend
und man hört halt noch was.
Ich sehe hier so viele Leute rumlaufen mit Kopfhörern und sowas,
die joggen und dann über die Straße laufen.
Teilweise kriegen die gar nicht mit, dass ein Auto kommt und sowas.
Das Problem hast du damit halt nicht.
Du hast halt einfach deine Ohren offen.
Es ist am Anfang ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig,
dass man quasi komplett die Umgebung hört,
plus Sound, weil man das so gar nicht gewöhnt ist,
aber man gewöhnt sich eigentlich recht schnell.
Also das kann ich wirklich empfehlen,
hab ich seit ein paar Monaten schon,
für Zugfahren und
sonst was, wo ich nicht
mein Noise-Canceling-Ding aufziehe, also wenn Kinder
im Zug rumschreien, ziehe ich mein Noise-Canceling-Ding auf.
Aber für Zugfahren, für unterwegs
rumlaufen, telefonieren,
im Büro sitzen, auf der Arbeit, ist das super.
Ist mir lieber als unsere Jabra-Headsets, die wir auf der Arbeit
haben.
Ja, wenn ich Homeoffice-mäßig arbeite, dann habe ich auch hier genau das gleiche Headset auf, was ich jetzt auch auf habe.
Mein MMX 300.
Wie ist die Qualität?
Ich finde, das ist ganz okay.
Also das ist jetzt nicht mit dem MMX 300 beispielsweise zu vergleichen, audioqualitätstechnisch.
Und die Mikrofonqualität ist hier sicherlich auch besser.
Aber für Teamsgespräche vollkommen ausreichend.
Ups, warum ist hier unten jetzt so ein...
Aber das ist natürlich Teil meines Jobs.
Wenn ich keine Akquise betreibe, bekomme ich keine neuen Kunden, keine neuen Abschlüsse, keinen Umsatz.
Laut Communications.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Ich gucke mal, was die für Jobs anbieten.
Einfach nur just for fun.
Was es da so gibt.
Gar nicht.
Ja gut, doch nicht.
Keine Jobs.
Ja.
Jeden Abend.
guck mal
was haben die denn so
sales ist wichtig ja klar du willst ja dann kram an die leute bringen natürlich ist das
wichtig ist es bloß überhaupt werbe absolut nichts für mich verfügbare positionen vertriebsbeauftragte
ja okay, Sales Manager
IT
Kommunikationssystemtechniker
Public Cloud Lösungen
für Mietel
ist das ein Hersteller, ist Mietel?
kenne ich nicht, kenne mich damit eh nicht aus
das ist was, was ich auch gar nicht
machen könnte
ich habe da absolut keine Ahnung
von Telekommunikationskram
IT-Systemelektronik, was gibt es noch?
Oh, warte mal, es klopft bei mir an der Tür.
Leute, ich habe was zu essen gebracht bekommen.
Ist es schon so spät, ja?
Okay, dann gucken wir mal kurz.
Meine Tätigkeiten.
Selbstständige Entstörung von Private und Public Cloud Lösungen.
Herzliche Atmosphäre unbefristet.
Möglichkeit zur persönlichen Weileinspruchs.
Übertariflich.
Gut, das schreiben sie ja alle.
Freiheit zur Entwicklung.
Das soll es wirklich sein.
Ah, okay.
Kurz und knackig.
Gucken wir, was es sonst noch gibt.
Was ist nicht mehr nötig?
IT-Systeme?
Nö, nö.
Seht man nur selten.
Kann man auch nachträglich gucken noch, ja.
Für zwei, drei Monate oder so.
einfach immer dieses 9-to-5 am Schreibtisch gehockt und gearbeitet und
habe gewartet bis halt abends ist, bis ich wieder nach Hause gehen kann. Aber ich liebe es
einfach raus zu gehen, Leute kennenzulernen, andere Unternehmen zu sehen, die Welt zu
sehen. Der Quereinstieg war super hart. Ich musste nicht nur das Technische mit
Telefonanlagen und Kommunikation lernen, sondern auch die vertriebliche Seite.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Gerade wenn man sowas nicht gemacht hat.
MonkaS, nervige Musik.
Regelarbeitszeiten, die sind natürlich von 8 bis 17 Uhr eigentlich.
Es ist aber immer mehr.
Ich mache sehr viel zu Hause.
Das ist so eine typische Vertriebssache.
Die sind immer, das kenne ich auch, wie gesagt, bei unseren...
Da bist du nie fertig im Kopf.
Noch.
Damit.
Es sind öfters viel mehr als 40 Stunden.
Das sind Dinge, die keiner eigentlich sieht, die weiß eigentlich keiner.
Da ist das Möbelhaus, wo wir jetzt hin möchten. Das ist unser Ziel und wir sind zeitlich super.
Kriegt das Möbelhaus jetzt auch Klaus Sachen verkauft?
Genau, also der Kunde ist super wichtig für uns, weil das ist von der Userzahl her,
die jetzt hier angemeldet sind, sind es über 400 User. Das ist für uns wirklich schon eine ordentliche Hausnummer.
Es gibt Vertriebler, die machen einfach nur Abschlüsse, Abschlüsse, Abschlüsse. Mir ist es
aber wichtig, zu einem Termin noch mal hinzufahren, danach zu fragen, wie geht's, war alles gut,
was können wir noch machen? Macht ja auch Sinn. Vielleicht wollen die noch mehr haben,
vielleicht wollen die upgraden oder sonst was. Ich hoffe natürlich auch dadurch,
dass wir vielleicht dem Kunden noch irgendwelche neuen Sachen zeigen können,
die wir dann noch zusätzlich verkaufen können. Also ein klassisches Upselling.
Grüß dich. Hi hi. Anna. Anna, genau. Ja richtig, die Anna. Genau, dir. Einmal will ich euch so ein
bisschen updaten. Da ist jetzt tatsächlich die V15 R1 rausgekommen und da gibt es ein paar nette
Sachen, ein paar ganz neue Sachen.
Hier kannst du dir quasi Aufgaben
erstellen, also quasi, ich nenne es einfach mal
To-Do-List. Über die Finanzen muss man
natürlich immer noch ein bisschen näher sprechen.
To-Do-Listen im Cloud-Telefonsystem,
okay, das...
Head of Business Applications.
Aber da wir an und
für sich den Need haben, oder...
Oh Gott, dieses Enterprise
Business Gelaber, Alter!
Oh, da kriege ich
Anfälle bei.
Weil wir den Need haben, Mann.
Den Bedarf, so eine Aufgabenplanung
in irgendeiner Weise bei uns abzubilden,
mit einem anderen Programm, wäre das...
Aber das würde ich doch nicht in der Cloud-Telefonanlage
machen. Wäre interessant für uns, ja.
Also das bedeutet eigentlich
auch, wenn wir da zusätzlich
Geschäft generieren können, wäre das natürlich auch zusätzlich
zu Umsatz.
Ich habe einen Grundgehalt von 3.800 Euro.
Dazu kommt dann nochmal eine betriebliche Krankenversicherung und meinen Firmenwagen, den ich auch privat nutzen darf,
sodass ich dann bei einem Brutto von 4.000 Euro lande.
Dann werden dann nochmal Steuern und Sozialabgaben abgezogen.
Der Firmenwagen wird auch nochmal versteuert, sodass ich dann am Ende das mache, bei 2.408 Euro netto.
Und da kommen jetzt auch Provisionen massig drauf, gehe ich mal von außen.
Mein Gehalt würde dann natürlich steigen, wenn ich mein Umsatzziel von 500.000 Euro in diesem Jahr erreiche.
Und dann würde ich eine Provision ausgezahlt bekommen, die ist aktuell bei 5.500 Euro brutto.
Moment, nur?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, da gibt es mehr.
Die würde ich dann bekommen und wenn ich natürlich mehr als meine 100%, mehr als die 500.000 erwirtschafte, bekomme ich natürlich auch mehr Provision.
Also wenn das pro Monat wäre, würde ich sagen, ja okay, aber insgesamt ist es jetzt nicht so krass, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hätte.
Ich höre mich natürlich auch in meinem Umfeld um, was die anderen natürlich auch verdienen.
Andere Sales Manager, andere Vertriebler und dadurch, dass ich erst auch so kurz in diesem
Job eigentlich bin, weiß ich auf jeden Fall, dass es Luft nach oben gibt.
Ich komme mit meinem Gehalt klar, aber der Kreislauf muss weitergehen.
Ich muss eigentlich mehr verdienen als jetzt.
Jetzt wird Feierabend gemacht und dann geht's zum Sport.
business klein fertig jetzt kommt der fitness klein crossfit auch noch okay
dass er tut wenn erstmal reifen geschoben und die man ja alles mögliche fahrraddingsen bis
zum Umfallen.
Crossfit hat ja so ein bisschen
den schlechten Ruf,
weil
das vor ein paar Jahren
in den USA so ein krasser Trend war,
wo Leute, die
null trainiert sind,
quasi
voll eingestiegen
sind und dann teilweise im Krankenhaus gelandet
sind.
Natürlich Blödsinn jetzt
bei ihm, das hat mit dem Video gar nichts
zu tun, aber das hat so ein bisschen
schlechten Ruf gehabt.
So, gehen wir rein.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss,
toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Oder hat immer noch einen schlechten Ruf.
Das ist quasi mein Privatfahrzeug, also Firmenwagen, Privatfahrzeug. Wird über mich bezahlt, weil meine Frau noch in Teilzeit ist.
Und jetzt gibt's lecker Essen.
Waren das die Kinder oder eine Katze im Hintergrund gerade, Leute?
Hört mal.
Und jetzt gibt's lecker Essen.
Jetzt, habt ihr das gehört?
Katze oder Kinder?
Da ist sie!
Die will auch was von der Lasagne haben!
Also mein Part ist alles was das Kind betrifft, Kita, Data Managerin, dann die ganzen Kosten
was man für sie einkäufe also für unsere tochter und ansonsten auch lebensmittel einkäufe für uns
beide so dass das bei mir bin also quasi haus auto versicherung alles komplett bin ich gebe
noch sehr gerne geld für die börse aus tatsächlich also zum investieren also ich versuche richtig
sehr viel von meinem geld was ich habe zu investieren kreisel kleiner ist aktuell bei
50.000 Euro.
Ich finde, das ist schon ein stolzer...
Ob der auch Reddit bei...
Wie heißt das Subreddit, wo die alle
immer erzählen, unter tausendfachem Hebel
ist nix. Ne, ne, nicht Finanzen.
Finanzen ist ja noch halbwegs seriös.
Mauerstraßenwetten.
Genau. Das meine ich.
Das meine ich.
Er ist aber bestimmt auch am Start.
Für mich lohnt sich der Job auf jeden Fall, weil ich einfach leistungsorientiert bezahlt
werde.
Ich weiß, umso mehr ich mache, umso mehr kann ich dann Ende des Tages verdienen.
Also ja, für mich lohnt es sich.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Ich mach mal kurz aus.
Also die Provision hätte ich gedacht, gibt es da echt noch eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Hm.
Dann gucken wir uns jetzt das zu CachyOS an.
Das wollte ich mir die ganze Zeit schon angucken.
Und ich muss nebenbei ein paar Nudeln futtern, Leute.
Peppo Fat Time.
Guck mal hier.
Wie schnell läuft bitte dieses Betriebssystem?
Ja, da wurde gerade Thunderbird installiert
in etwas mehr als...
Das geht aber schnell.
Ist das Arch-based, Leute?
Ist Cache Arch-based, oder?
Weil anders kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
wie der Package-Manager so schnell ist.
Vielleicht nix Arch-based.
By the way, natürlich, was sonst?
Chat, sind das die normalen Arch-Repos?
Darf man sagen, dass man Arch, by the way,
used, wenn man Cache used oder nicht?
Oder ist es wie bei Manjaro? Bei Manjaro
dürfte man ja auch nicht sagen, dass man Arch used.
Oder ist CacheOS
auch so mit Zwischenrepos?
Haben eigene Repos?
Ja, dann ist
kein Arch, by the way.
Ist laut genug?
Ich denke schon.
Ich versuche, meinen Salat zu
essen, ohne zu sauen.
zumindest laut der Website Distrowatch.
CashUS hat dort tatsächlich gerade ganz frisch Linux Mint von Platinum.
Distrowatch ist ja auch PPGA-Seite.
Da kannst du nichts drauf geben.
Und CashUS sieht auch noch richtig gut aus, oder?
Also ich habe das auf jeden Fall installiert und ziemlich intensiv genutzt.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich bin begeistert.
Genau so muss sich 2025 ein Betriebssystem anfühlen.
Warum nicht das Ding...
Ich habe schon gesaut mit dem Salat.
Ich bin das...
Ich bin es einfach nicht mehr gewohnt vom Rechner zu essen.
Früher habe ich das easy hingekriegt, da konnte ich ganze Pizzas vom Rechner ohne zu sauen, aber jetzt kann ich das nicht mehr.
Wenn ihr euch so begeistert habt, erzähle ich euch in diesem Video ein paar Benchmarks im Vergleich zu Windows 11 gibt es auch und ja, ich überlege, ob das jetzt das Betriebssystem ist, auf das ich fest umsteigen werde.
Also bleibt dran.
Achso, achso, achso.
Ihr müsst hier für dieses Video keine Ahnung von Linux haben.
Wenn ihr Ahnung von Linux habt, erfahrt ihr hier hoffentlich auch noch was, was ihr noch nicht wisst.
Hoffentlich.
Hallo liebe Hacker und Internet-Hübscher.
Ja, liebe Hackerin, ihr Internet-Server, herzlich willkommen hierbei.
Ja, CacheOS hat keine integrierten KI-Funktionen.
Dafür bietet der Sponsor dieses Videos gleich mehrere KI-Modelle in einer Oberfläche.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Mammuth, die kommen aus Frankreich und die haben den Untertitel nicht ausgesucht.
Ich schippe mal kurz die Werbung.
Nö.
Ja, der Cache-OS-Hype, der ist gerade definitiv ziemlich doll.
Aktuell gerade wegen dieser Distrowatch Platz 1-Geschichte.
Aha.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, hä?
Ja, Distrowatch.
Oder wisst ihr denn überhaupt, wie viele Leute welches Linux installiert haben?
Ich dachte, der Punkt bei Linux ist, dass das gerade nicht nach Hause telefoniert.
Ja, das ist korrekt. Distrowatch zählt nämlich einfach nur, wie viele Leute sich auf der Seite die Infos zu den jeweiligen Linuxen angeguckt haben.
Ja, und wenn man auf die Google Trends guckt, da sieht man dann, dass immer noch deutlich, deutlich, deutlich häufiger nach Linux Mint gesucht wird.
Deswegen, ich wusste nicht mehr genau, was es war. Ich wusste nur, dass Distrowatch echt PPGa-Metrics sind.
Sagt CacheUS. Ja, also auch wenn man diese Distrowatch-Geschichte mit so einem Grain of Salt nehmen sollte.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist CacheUS auf jeden Fall super interessant.
Und zwar, weil das Ding einfach konsequent auf Schwoptizität getrimmt ist.
Also das soll sich so schnell wie möglich anfühlen.
Und da wurde an so vielen Ecken wie möglich versucht, jegliche Verzögerung zu verhindern.
Und was soll ich sagen? Das funktioniert beeindruckend gut.
Meint ihr? Chat, meint ihr, ich sollte es mal ausprobieren?
Ich habe ja hier so einen Mini-PC, den ich für nichts verwende.
Der ist gar nicht schlecht. Der hat so eine AMD-Kombi-CPU, GPU drin.
Und es ist der, wo wir mal, was haben wir da drauf ausprobiert?
Irgendwas haben wir im Stream da drauf ausprobiert auf dem Mini-PC.
Ich glaube Moonlight oder wie das hieß, dieses Streaming-Zeug.
Lass mal ausprobieren.
Ich schreibe mir das mal kurz auf Stream-Themen.
Hashi-OS auf Mini-PC.
Hyperland! Ah, dann...
Nach dem Neo-Film-Stream.
Ja, wir haben noch viele Sachen, die wir machen können.
Ich würde mich mal selbst als Betriebs...
Ne, das war nicht der Batocera-PC.
Der Batocera-PC, den habe ich meinem Vater geschenkt.
vor
eineinhalb Jahren oder so.
Den benutzt der.
Nachdem er seinen anderen Windows-PC
so voll gemüllt hat mit
irgendeinem Scheiß.
Ich habe den Linux Mint installiert auf dem Mini-PC
und
hat keine
Admin-Rechte.
Und seit eineinhalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren, keine Ahnung,
gibt es da überhaupt keine Probleme mit.
Der benutzt
ja nur seinen Browser.
kann er genauso gut mitmachen dem connoisseur sich wie sirene eine sirene
bezeichnen ich probiere gerne viel betriebssysteme aus und ich kann sagen
man merkt das sofort das käse ist einfach extrem schnell läuft also als
ich das gerade installiert hatte und angefangen habe das system einzurichten
dachte ich am anfang ernsthaft dass da irgendwas kaputt ist weil software so
schnell installiert wurde ja schaut mal das ist hier die installation von
thunderbird ungefähr eine sekunde dauert das und hier audacity auch super schnell und hier einfach
gut ist halt arsch das dauert arsch geht also generell muss man ja sagen arsch pacman ist
sauschnell weniger als 20 sekunden für dieses riesen software paket ja unter windows dauert
das ein bisschen länger und das alles open source und kostenlos ja aber klar das ist nicht nur der
verdienst von cash ios dass es alles schnell ist sondern grundsätzlich sind arch basierte linux
also cash ios basiert auf arch linux sehr schnell bei der paketverwaltung aber cash ios hat da direkt
out of the box ein bisschen optimiert zum beispiel dass cash ios immer direkt zehn download verbindungen
aufmacht und das fasst eigentlich direkt die cash ios philosophie zusammen das ist nämlich einfach
an ganz vielen stellschrauben optimiert wo die sachen vielleicht einzeln gar nicht so ins gewicht
fallen aber in der masse dann eben wenn das eigentlich eine richtig gute idee weil du
kannst an art ja auch so viel rum stellen du weißt halt bloß nicht unbedingt wurde überall
dran rum stellen könntest du müsstest und was sinn machen würde ich finde die idee dahinter
gar nicht schlecht und hat was ich glaube wir probieren das mal zusammen aus auf dem mini pc
Doch.
Da können wir nämlich auch gleich ausprobieren, ist das AMD?
AMD fundst ja unter Linux, was Gaming angeht, eh deutlich besser.
Das probieren wir mal aus.
Klar, das ist Linux.
Man kann natürlich auch auf anderen Distributionen die ganzen Sachen einstellen,
aber CacheOS macht das eben direkt alles out of the box.
Also ich habe in Cache auf jeden Fall bislang kein einziges Config-File manuell angepasst.
Der ganze Installationsprozess hat bei mir auch wirklich unproblematisch funktioniert,
was ich nicht für alle Linux überhaupt kann.
Und das trotzdem mit sehr großer Offenheit, würde ich mal sagen.
Also man kann da viel einstellen, muss das aber nicht.
Wie die meisten Linux-Rebooted-Cache erstmal in so einen Live-Linux vom USB-Datenträger.
Da kann man sich das ein bisschen angucken und wenn man dann halt will, kann man das dann installieren.
Alleine an Desktop-Umgebung hat man da 17 Stück zur Auswahl.
Voreingestellt ist aber KDE Plasma und das ist auch die, in die die meiste Arbeit fließt.
In der FAQ ist da von Flagship-Desktop-Umgebung die Rede.
Deshalb habe ich die auch ausgewählt.
Ja, was soll ich sagen, hat alles direkt funktioniert.
Und sah auch direkt richtig nice aus.
Mit so schönen Kleinigkeiten.
Was ist denn das für ein Desktop?
Ich habe gerade nicht aufgepasst.
Was ist der Flagship Desktop?
Klar, ah, Blasma.
Okay.
Ich muss sagen, das finde ich ganz hübsch gerade.
Also, ihr kennt mich ja, ich mag keine Linux-Desktops.
Also weder Gnome noch KDE oder sonst was.
Das Einzige, was ich halbwegs erträglich finde, ist i3.
Und das im Prinzip auch, weil es keinen Desktop hat.
Aber das sieht zumindest optisch ganz nice aus hier.
Hier, guck mal, der Login-Screen.
Das kann Apple doch jetzt auch nicht unbedingt besser, oder?
Und was mir auch gut gefallen hat, das Boot-Menü von vielen Linuxen
finde ich ziemlich überladen und wird auch auf meinem 4K-Monitor standardmäßig viel zu klein dargestellt.
Bei CacheOS sieht das so aus. Ja, schick, oder?
Ja, und dann wird man direkt von so einem Menü begrüßt, wo man dann zum Beispiel mit einem Klick das ganze Gaming-Geraffel installieren kann.
Also Steam und Lutris und so. Praktisch.
Vor allem gibt es auch ein CacheOS-Paket-Installationsprogramm, wenn man nicht die Kommandozeile benutzen will.
Ja, und da gibt es dann halt direkt unter beliebte Pakete so eine kuratierte Auswahl, zum Beispiel von Office-Programmen.
einfach anklicken installieren fertig wenn man da was nicht findet kann man hier oben
auch auf hyperland kann ich nicht benutzen weil das wayland und wayland
funktioniert richtig drin
deswegen noch i3
Wir könnten
Wir könnten es mal wieder ausprobieren
Ob Wayland mittlerweile gescheit funzt
Wir probieren das ja so einmal im Jahr aus
Um dann wieder enttäuscht zu werden
Wie viel Crap das teilweise noch
Ist
Vielleicht geht es ja mittlerweile
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht
Auf Repo klicken
Oder Repo
Repositories
kann man auf repo klicken und da gibt es dann mehr zur auswahl also während meines tests
waren das 15.808 pakete ja was ich aber irritierend fand es gibt zusätzlich hier
noch eine software liste in diesem begrüßungs menü hier unter apps installieren da kann ich
dann super tux card beste eine andere liste sehen aber nicht suchen aus irgendwelchen gründen das
Das erwähnte bessere Paketinstallationsprogramm findet sich übrigens unter Apps, Tweaks und dann CacheUS Package Install.
Und gibt es da eigentlich fünf Möglichkeiten Pakete zu installieren?
Und dann gibt es aber auch noch Octopi, wo sich dann nochmal mehr...
Okay, acht Möglichkeiten Pakete zu installieren.
...Installationspakete finden.
Ja, mir ist klar, dass so Linux-Veteranen genau erklären können, warum das so ist.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das auch ziemlich viele Leute verwirrt.
Da muss ich echt sagen, dass das bei Mint besser gelöst ist.
Also der Mint Software Manager, der ist schon ziemlich gelungen mit diesen Screenshots und Beschreibungen und so.
Aber es ist alles Jammern auf hohem Niveau.
Ich habe bei diesem minimalistischeren Cache-OS-Package-Installer auch immer alles gefunden, was ich installieren wollte.
Und das ist ja auf jeden Fall auch schon was wert.
Also unter anderem auch so lustige Sachen wie diesen textbasierten Spotify-Client.
Ich verwende den...
...echt inzwischen häufiger als den normalen grafischen Client, den es natürlich auch gibt.
Aber apropos textbasiert, die vorinstallierte Phish-Shell kannte ich noch nicht und ich fand...
Jetzt Phish standardmäßig drauf, okay.
Damit werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht warm.
Das muss ich auf Zsch, auf Zsch umstellen, Leute.
Damit ich meine Config verwenden kann.
Wobei, können Sie sich ja mal angucken.
Also was mir an Phish immer nicht gefallen hat, dass es nicht Bash-kompatibel von Skripten ist.
weiß nicht, ob sich da mittlerweile was getan hat,
dass sie so eine eigene Skripting-Syntax haben,
das finde ich
unpraktisch.
Sehr, sehr schön. Also erstmal
schön bunt, aber auch die
Autovervollständigung ist echt praktisch.
Aber na gut, das kann man natürlich bei jedem Linux
haben. Bei CacheOS geht es ja um die
Geschwindigkeit. Und die kommt
unter anderem durch einen optimierten
Cache-Körnel, also der
Linux-Körnel. Das ist ja der zentrale
Teil des Betriebssystems. Und bei
Cashe kommt da zum Beispiel ein anderer
Scheduler zum Einsatz, als beim
Standardkernel. Der Scheduler
Ach, das ist in der
Tat mal was spannendes, ja.
...ist dafür zuständig, die CPU-Ressourcen zu
verteilen und beim Standard-Scheduler
steht im Fokus, dass alles besonders
gerecht zugeht. Dass also
Programme fair behandelt werden
und bei Cashe's Scheduler, der
heißt übrigens BORE, B-O-R-E,
da geht es bewusst ein bisschen
ungerecht dazu, nämlich dass alle
interaktiven Sachen, also was weiß ich,
sowas wie Fenster verschieben oder Mausklick
in einem Spiel priorisiert werden.
Während so länger andauernde Dinge,
also was weiß ich, so ein Renderjob
in Blender, bei dem wird was abgezwackt.
Das heißt, er braucht dann womöglich etwas
länger als ohne Bohr,
aber der Vorteil bei Bohr ist halt,
dass sich... Eigentlich eine gute Idee, oder?
Das ist mal wenigstens ein bisschen was
anderes, wie bei den ganzen tausend
anderen Distros, die es so gibt, die ein Desktop-
Hintergrundbild ändern und sagen neue Distro.
Da hat sich einer wirklich was bei gedacht.
sich alles immer schnell anfühlt. Und das klappt zumindest auf meinem System mit CacheOS sehr gut.
Der Scheduler ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum das CacheOS heißt.
Also es hat nichts mit Caches Blog aus Bremerhaven zu tun, Grüße gehen raus.
Der Scheduler hieß früher einfach Cache.
Und einer der beiden Gründer von CacheOS, Peter Jung aus Bayern übrigens,
hat an diesem Scheduler mitgearbeitet, bevor er sich 2024 gedacht hat,
ey, lass mal so ein optimiertes Linux anfangen.
Cache.js ist trotz der großen Beliebtheit und ist nach wie vor ein Hobbyprojekt von Peter.
Und was ich auch krass finde, er schreibt im Cache.js Forum, dass er erst 2018 von Windows auf Linux umgestiegen ist und da sein erstes Linux-Info-
Nicht schlecht.
2018 auf Linux umgestiegen und jetzt Kernel-Distributions-Hackerman?
Pfeiffer-Time, oder?
Wo ist das Gehirn?
Also recht schnell vom Windows-User zum Linux-Kernel-Magier geworden.
Ist beeindruckend.
Eine andere wichtige Sache bei CacheOS sind die architekturoptimierten Repositories.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal kompliziert, aber das bedeutet einfach nur,
dass je nach eurer CPU speziell drauf angepasste Software heruntergeladen wird.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ihr einen AMD-Prozessor mit Zen 4 Architektur habt,
die Teile gibt es seit 2022, oder bestimmte Intel-CPUs,
dann holt sich CacheOS automatisch daran angepasste Software,
die den sogenannten AVX-512-Befehlssatz beherrscht.
Das wird wahrscheinlich bei den meisten Sachen kaum nennenswert ausbringen,
aber ist cool.
hat irgendjemand
alles quasi mit aktuellen
Compiler und Compiler-Flex gebaut.
Ist auch ein größerer Aufwand.
Machst du auch nicht mal heute auf morgen.
Und andere Linux'e nutzen halt
einfach den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner.
Also immer nur einen Softwarestand,
der dann aber auch halt auf steinalten
Prozessoren läuft. Cache-OS-Macher,
die gehen halt die extra Meile,
dass sie für viele Prozessoren optimierte
Programmvarianten anbieten. Was das am Ende bringt, ist natürlich je nach Software unterschiedlich,
aber zum Beispiel eine Analyse der Linux-Website Foronix hat ziemlich deutliche Verbesserungen
ergeben, so im Bereich von 5 bis 20 Prozent. So, aber was ist denn jetzt mit Spielen? Dafür
ist CacheOS ja laut eigenen Angaben auch sehr gut geeignet. Und ja, alle Spiele, die ich ausprobiert
habe, liefen out of the box. Wie gesagt, Steam, Lutris, Heroic und so ist mit einem Klick
installiert und ja die performance ich hatte ja vor ein paar wochen in video zum handheld pc
lenovo legion go s gemacht und da die drei spiele cyberpunk 2077 scherter und black mith wukong
jeweils unter windows 11 und unter linux also ich es team us benchmark von linux war immer schneller
die gleichen spiele habe ich nun auch hier auf meinem system mit amd reise 9 79 50 x
Linux ist mittlerweile zu sehr damit beschäftigt, irgendwelche Metriken zu Microsoft zu schicken.
Und schätzt, dass der Kram schnell funktioniert.
Ich finde das eigentlich cool, ja.
Irgendwie haben wir das alles ein bisschen...
Irgendwie haben wir das alles ein bisschen Gaben zu verdanken, oder?
Dass das so gut funzt mit Linux Gaming.
Ohne Gaben hätte es das alles so nicht gegeben.
3D und Nvidia RTX 4090 unter Cache-OS und Windows gebencht und hier liefen die Spiele unter Linux
mit zwischen 15 und 23 Prozent weniger Frames. Ist Cache-OS nun langsamer als SteamOS? Nein,
sicherlich nicht. Der Punkt ist einfach, das Legion Go S hat eine AMD-Grafikeinheit,
mein Rechner hat eine von Nvidia, das bedeutet zwei unterschiedliche Treiber. Leider ist der
Nvidia Linux-Treiber bei weitem nicht so gut optimiert wie der AMD-Treiber und das ist einfach
das problem ziemlich viele benchmarks die ich so im netz gefunden habt die bin ich froh dass
man mini pc amd kramt ritter hat zeigen dass das mit amd hardware dann gleich schon wieder
ganz anders aussieht also häufig mit cash ios im vorteil gegenüber windows ja ich hatte mir
auch überlegt ob ich jetzt mir kurzfristig sagt mal warum sind die nvidia treiber eigentlich so
kacke unter linux wundert mich weil nvidia macht doch auch so auf ei und sonst was und und solche
Sachen werden doch hauptsächlich unter Linux laufen und nicht unter Windows.
Warum sind denn die Linux-Treiber von Nvidia so kacke?
Was ist das da für ein Hintergrund?
Die haben keinen Bock. Ja gut. Aber warum nicht?
Das ganze AI-Zeug läuft doch eher unter Linux als Windows.
Ja, gut.
Stimmt, du hast recht.
Das braucht nicht die Grafik-APIs.
Okay, ja.
Ist das grundsätzlich in Linux?
Du meinst, dass das AMD viel besser funktioniert als Nvidia?
Ja.
... AMD-Karte besorge und das teste.
Am besten wird wahrscheinlich immer noch Intel out of the box funktionieren unter Linux, oder?
War zumindest früher immer so.
Ich wollte das nicht übers Knie brechen und ich kann euch aber jetzt schon sagen, dass wir da was Größeres machen wollen.
Und da schon ziemlich konkret an der Planung dran sind, da wirklich systematisch unterschiedliche Linux-Distributionen mit unterschiedlicher Hardware ganz ausführlich zu testen.
Aber sowas ist natürlich sehr zeitintensiv, also geduldet euch noch ein bisschen.
Interessant ist aber, dass andere Sachen, die auf meiner Nvidia-Grafikkarte laufen, also mit den nicht so guten Nvidia-Linux-Treibern, tatsächlich schneller unter CacheOS laufen als unter Windows.
Ich habe ein bisschen KI-Zeug auf der GPU, also mit CUDA ausprobiert, zum Beispiel zwei Sprachmodelle mit Ulama und die liefen beide zwischen 7 und 10% schneller unter CacheOS als unter Windows.
Und die Open Source Sprachtranskriptionssoftware Whisper von OpenAI mit Pinocchio installiert, dazu hatten wir ja schon ein eigenes Video, die lief nahezu doppelt so schnell unter CacheOS mit der gleichen Tondatei, mit den gleichen Einstellungen.
Also da scheinen wirklich die ganzen Optimierungen von CacheOS wirklich reinzuhauen.
Mein Fazit.
Also ich habe bislang CacheOS immer in diese Ecke Linux speziell für Spiele eingeordnet.
Also sowas wie SteamOS oder Besside und Nobara.
Einfach weil CacheOS immer in irgendwelchen Spiele Linux Benchmarks aufgetaucht ist.
Ich suche aber für mich und das geht vielen von euch vielleicht auch so, einfach eine Windows Alternative.
Unter anderem war ja im Oktober der Support für Windows 10 endet, aber das nur am Rande.
Und ja, ich spiele zwar auf meinem PC, aber ich mache da natürlich auch ganz viele andere Sachen mit.
Und deshalb kommt da so ein ganz auf Spiele fixiertes Linux nicht in Frage.
Also klar kann man mit SteamOS auch einen Desktop-Modus nutzen, aber das ist alles nicht optimal.
Alleine weil SteamOS und Besside auch übrigens weite Teile des Systems auf nur Lesen stehen hat.
Und ja, Nubara und PopOS, die habe ich auch schon mal ausprobiert und mit beiden bin ich nicht warm geworden.
Aber das ist ganz individuell mein persönliches Problem.
Ich wundere mich allerdings selbst, dass ich hier CacheOS so super finde,
was mich nämlich zuerst ein bisschen abgestreckt hat, weil als Basis Arch Linux verwendet wird.
Ein zumindest früher berüchtigtes Linux.
Wir hatten ja schon mal ein ziemlich positives Video über...
Mittlerweile ist es mit Arch Linux gar nicht mehr so schlimm, seit es den normalen Arch Installer gibt.
Früher musste es ja viel selbst machen, aber mit dem Arch Installer ist das eigentlich auch kein allzu großer Akt mehr.
Das Problem ist eher nach der Installation, wenn du nur eine minimale Installation gemacht hast, du musst dir den Kram halt selbst einrichten.
Du musst dir irgendeinen XOR, Qualient, sonst was installieren, gucken, dass das läuft, dann irgendeinen Window Manager und alles.
Du musst halt viel selbst machen.
Aber die reine Installation von Arch ist mittlerweile eigentlich gar kein Problem mehr.
Finde ich.
Endeavor Linux gemacht, was ja auch auf Arch basiert, wie übrigens SteamOS auch. Und Endeavor
habe ich dann die ganze Zeit genutzt, bis mir dann ein Update das komplette System geschrottet hat.
Also bootete nicht mehr. Ja, doof. Und ich hoffe, dass mir das bei CacheOS nicht passiert,
aber das ist halt auch ein Rolling Release Linux. Also da wird nicht erst gesammelt und im Ganzen
getestet, bevor es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, halbjährlich oder jährlich sogar nur Updates
gibt, sondern die aktualisierten Bestandteile werden immer sofort ausgeliefert. Das ist cool,
weil man dadurch halt immer den neuesten Kram hat, aber ist natürlich auch riskanter,
dass da mal was zusammenbricht. Ich bleibe auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal bei CacheOS,
habe da richtig Lust zu, aber ich kann natürlich nicht sagen, wie das mit uns so weitergeht. Ich
kann euch auf jeden Fall allen empfehlen, das mal auszuprobieren, einfach weil das so faszinierend
schnell läuft. Oder habt ihr andere Erfahrungen gemacht? Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben,
ich lese zumindest die ersten Tage nach Veröffentlichung alles. Ja, und natürlich
abonnieren wenn ihr unsere große linux analyse demnächst nicht verpassen wollt ja tschüss
große linux analyse und ich war gespannt was da kommt so ich muss jetzt ungefähr 12 gabeln
Nudelfutter.
Und
dann bin ich ready.
Link bitte, für was denn?
Zum Video.
Meinst du dem hier?
Guck mal hier.
Guck mal, ja.
Bitte.
Ich hab schon ewig kein
BTRFS, man spricht das ja eigentlich
ButterFS aus.
Ich sage aber trotzdem
BTRFS.
Schon ewig nicht mal ausprobiert.
Ist das
mittlerweile so, dass man sagen kann,
man kann das
verwenden?
ja ich kann mich noch dran erinnert vor ein paar jahren gab es probleme mit
raid 5 dass ich das irgendwie korrupt korrupt korrupt hat kaputt gegangen ist
war alfred an und ab
Pock Subscriptions
Link zu den Nudeln
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
Ja Lidl
Also
nichts irgendwie ausgefallen ist.
Oh, gleich leer hier.
es muss keine 20 jahre alt sein aber das ist genauso wie diese geschichte
mit bcfs oder hieß der kram doch dass ich damit linus gebieft hat immer das
würde ja auch nicht verwenden
erst fertig
nudellehr ist nicht immer noch der standard für rate mit replizierung
also standard kann man nicht sagen der fest hatte auch letztens irgendwelche korruption probleme
der fest ist halt aber ganz eigenes biest für sich so wurde auf sehr viele dinge achten muss
ja zum beispiel war es früher unter zfs so ich weiß nicht ob es immer noch so ist dass du eine
ZFS-Platte nicht vollschreiben durftest,
sonst geht sie kaputt, beziehungsweise
kann man nicht mehr löschen.
Aber ZFS ist gut.
Also ZFS würde ich
von diesen ganzen Advanced-File-Systemen
am meisten trauen.
jetzt zfs unter bsd nicht mittlerweile das gleiche wie unter linux haben die
nicht auch umgestellt auf open zfs oder wie das heißt es ist nicht alles das
gleiche mittlerweile will ich mir einen körper gelesen zu haben
jetzt alles auf die zeit fs doch auf den linux und freepass so was haben wir sonst
vielleicht gibt es noch irgendwas was sich lohnt anzugucken
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Chat, ich brauch mal einen Videovorschlag.
Irgendwie, was können wir uns denn angucken?
Oh ja.
Kurz.
Lego Baustells guck ich immer mega gern.
Geht auch immer schnell.
Was können wir uns denn angucken?
Klemmbausteine.
Allah.
guck mal chat youtube faked das ist nicht 1080p seht ihr wie pixelig das ist aber es
zeigt an es wäre 1080p und jetzt gehe ich mal auf 1080p passt mal auf guck
beim viel schärfer was macht denn youtube da wieder
8 stunden als fachinformatik über tüsten gruppe kürz kann
mal gucken.
Die wollen Bandbreite sparen.
Das ist jetzt der neueste Trick,
nicht einfach Auto auf 480p zu
schalten, sondern anzuzeigen, man wäre
auf 1080p. Jetzt ist es aber gar nicht.
Das ist Next Level 5-Head-Time
von Google. Habt ihr das
mitbekommen, dass Google
ungefragt Videos per AI
verändert,
um sie angeblich klarer und besser
zu machen. Das ist mir auch schon
aufgefallen. Ich habe mir Videos, gerade bei Shorts,
habe ich mir Videos angeguckt
und habe mir gedacht, das sieht
so AI aus, teilweise.
Und jetzt
erklärt es das auch.
Was ganz creepy war,
AI hat bei mir mal ein Gesicht rein
halluziniert in YouTube AI.
Das Video war relativ
schlecht aufgelöst
und du hast
eigentlich nichts erkannt, aber irgendwie
hat der Typ an der Stelle, wo
er eigentlich gar nicht den Kopf hatte, so ein ganz merkwürdiges
Gesicht. Da hab ich gedacht, was zum Teufel
ist das los? Das muss doch AI
generiert sein. Aber jetzt
ergibt es Sinn.
Guck mal, David.
Nee, wir gucken uns das andere an.
Genug Lego-Stells.
Wir gucken uns lieber hier Dings an.
Acht Stunden Fachinformatiker.
Das klingt ganz schlecht.
Warum eigentlich nur acht Stunden?
Das ist ein Industrieunternehmen in Deutschland.
und ich durfte hier für einen Tag als Azubi-Mitarbeiter.
ThyssenKrupp steht seit...
Er hat quasi so ein Eintagespraktikum gemacht.
...über 200 Jahre für...
Obetag.
Oder ist das Werbung für ThyssenKrupp?
Mit fast 100.000 Mitarbeitenden weltweit
entwickeln sie Lösungen für einige der wichtigsten...
Das ist Werbung, oder?
Das ist doch Werbung.
Erzählt mir nix.
...Branchen.
Aber was genau passiert hier eigentlich?
Welche Berufe gibt es?
Und wie sieht der Arbeitsmarkt aus?
Guck mal, das ist wieder nur 480p gefaked als 1080p.
Was ist das? Was macht YouTube da?
Das finden wir heute gemeinsam heraus.
Aha.
Fischicht auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin heute Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration bei ThyssenKrupp.
Digga, es ist arschkalt, deswegen...
Digga!
Bisschen leiser?
Problem ist, wenn ich das jetzt lauter mache, dann ist es in anderen Bereichen wieder zu laut.
Was man in der Ausbildung macht?
Man lernt von der IHK, dass man eigentlich halber Kaufmann ist.
und sich fragt, was geht mit der IHK ab?
Und man lernt auch, die IHK zu hassen in der Ausbildung.
Wie läuft das Ganze ab?
Also erstmal, die Ausbildung geht natürlich im Regelfall über drei Jahre.
Man kann die natürlich auch verkürzen, wenn man dementsprechend guten Notendurchschnitt hat.
Es gibt natürlich auch einen Ausbildungsplan,
den es auch natürlich auch schon sehr detailliert im Bistro Group gibt.
Da stehen natürlich auch Aufgaben, Lernziele, was man natürlich lernen muss.
Wichtig ist natürlich auch, viel Grundlagen erstmal aufzunehmen.
Auch die Begrifflichkeiten.
Wie ist eine Benutzerverwaltung?
User anlegen?
Wie ist es die Technologien?
Warum habe ich immer das Gefühl,
dass bei den meisten Leuten irgendein Windows-AD-Admin da bei der Ausbildung sitzt?
Wenn ich das schon höre mit User anlegen und sonst was.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht einmal in...
äh, Moment,
Kopfrechnungs-Fail,
einmal in
18 Jahren
einen AD-User
angelegt.
Oh, scheiß, noch nie.
Und ich bin auch froh drüber.
Ich mach da auch ein ganz großes, okay, noch nie,
weiß ich, weiß ich auch nicht, ob wir in der Berufsschule vielleicht mal sowas
gemacht haben, keine Ahnung. Ich will auch nicht.
Windows-Crap, Alter.
zu lernen
Vernetzung, Netzwerk,
Netze trennen.
Das OSI-Modell.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Jetzt. Pass auf.
Nicht nachgucken.
Wer kriegt die OSI-Modell-Layer
noch zusammen?
Also, es gibt ja
Würdet ihr die noch zusammenkriegen?
Also, ich kenne auch diesen Merksatz, den wir in der Berufsschule hatten.
Please do not throw salami pizza away.
Physical, data, bla, blub, weiß ich nicht, Network, Transport, Presentation, Application,
Session habe ich noch vergessen. Salami-Pizza-Session habe ich noch vergessen hier dazwischen.
Ja.
Ich kriege diesen Mist heute immer noch zusammen.
EDV, Adressenvergabe, das sind so Grundlagen, die erstmal einem beigebracht werden.
natürlich auch schon praktisch, auch schon hier vor Ort, natürlich auch schon den erfahrenen Mitarbeitern.
Und bringt das was? Nö. Es bringt jetzt genauso wenig wie in der Ausbildung was.
Auch erfahrene Mitarbeiter hier im Team stehen einem immer zur Rat und Tat zur Seite
und helfen einem auch weiter und lösen auch Probleme zusammen im Team.
Das ist natürlich auch ganz wichtig.
Die ganzen Fachbegriffe, die du jetzt vorhin genannt hast, also ich habe jetzt Bahnhof verstanden.
Ja, verstehe ich.
War noch gar nicht so wirklich viele Fachbegriffe drin, oder?
Ausbildung bin, kann ich bei null starten?
Ja, das ist definitiv
möglich, klar.
Das sage ich auch,
man macht in der Ausbildung was zu lernen.
Sicherlich ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn man ein bisschen
Vorkenntnisse hat, aber ich bin der Meinung,
es ist gar nicht so essentiell, dass man da krasse
Vorkenntnisse hat.
Das ist nur in Unternehmen so, die Azubis
eigentlich als billige Arbeitskräfte einsetzen
und die gar nicht ausbilden wollen, sondern einfach
irgendwas machen, direkt was machen lassen
wollen. Also ich bin der Meinung,
Es ist viel wichtiger, dass einer was lernen will und irgendwie eine Motivation für die Ausbildung mitbringt, als dass der schon alles weiß.
So, die Ausbildung ist dazu da, dass man was lernt.
Ich sehe da gar kein Problem drin, wenn man startet ohne großartige Vorkenntnisse, solange man eben motiviert ist und Bock darauf hat, es zu lernen.
viele haben natürlich schon
Vorkenntnisse, weil es ja meistens
nicht so ist, dass einer irgendwie mit der Schule fertig
ist und sagt, oh, ich hab mich nie mit Computer
beschäftigt, ich will jetzt Fachinformatiker werden
das ist ja
nicht so, also die meisten haben ja schon Vorkenntnisse
aber
was mir aufgefallen ist jetzt über die Jahre da
mit Azubis
ich hatte zumindest den Eindruck
dass die, die sich besonders geil
fanden, so nach dem Motto, ich weiß doch schon alles
ich mach die Ausbildung eh nur noch, dass ich den Zettel
braucht, dass es bei denen tatsächlich
ein bisschen gehapert hat daran
und vielleicht auch gerade wegen dieser Vorstellung, ich weiß
doch eh schon alles.
Also,
was ja meistens nicht der Fall ist.
Weil daheim,
bis hin am Rechner schrauben,
ist schon was anderes wie
Business Enterprise IT-Stells.
Da ist ja auch vieles dabei,
womit man sich daheim gar nicht
beschäftigen muss.
Weil es irgendwelche Compliance und
sonstige Security-Vorgaben sind, was
an der Heim alles überhaupt nicht interessieren muss.
Daheim machst du
eine SSH-Verbindung von hier auf deine Cloud-Kiste
und auf der Arbeit
musst du erstmal durch drei
Ringe springen, dass du überhaupt eine SSH-Verbindung
kriegst.
Zum Beispiel.
Also vieles ist im Business Enterprise Umfeld
viel komplizierter als daheim.
Fängt mich teilweise auch richtig ab.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, man wird auf der Arbeit
echt sabotiert.
weil du so viel, um was kleines zu machen
so viel Umwege gehen musst
dass ich mir auch immer denke
wie kriegt man überhaupt noch was auf die Reihe
Dokumentation braucht man nicht
wenn man alles fehlerfrei macht
ist doch klar, ich sag doch
Errorless Programming
dann braucht man
keine Dokumentation und keine Kommentare
ganz easy
einfach keine Fehler machen, dann keine Dokumentation
nötig
das ist so easy eigentlich
so easy nie was verkehrt machen dann muss man nie seine fehler fixen
skill driven development genau und natürlich habe ich auch noch nie was
gemacht auch noch nie im stream oder so geht alles immer first try
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Der Code dokumentiert sich selbst.
Und mal ehrlich, Chat.
Die beste Dokumentation,
die es gibt, ist immer noch die Bash-History.
Genau, die Shell-History.
History-Dokumentation.
Und
das ist viel
realistischer, als ich das jetzt gebracht
habe. Das ist wirklich so. Also ich meine das ernst.
Shell-Dokumentation bringt
mir oftmals, also
Shell-History bringt
mir oftmals mehr als irgendwelche Dokuseiten.
Also ich hatte es schon öfters, dass gerade ich, ich bin ja jemand, der gerne früh da ist und wenn man früh da ist, da kriegt man auch öfters die Probleme ab, wenn morgens was kaputt ist.
Und wir sind zuständig für, frag mich nicht, über 40 Services bei uns im Team und da sind die meisten davon, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Aber nachdem ich so früh da bin, werde ich öfters angeschrieben, so Max, kannst du mal kurz gucken und wie oft ich da schon die Probleme fixen konnte, indem ich in die Shell-Historie geguckt habe, das kannst du ja nicht mal an den Fingern abzählen.
History Size ist bei mir unlimited.
ja zwischenablagenverlauf ist auch praktisch
ich hab beides unter linux
ich hab zwischenablagenverlauf hier
und ich hab hier mein guck
ich hab hier
zack
Meine History.
Das Zeug hier liegt daran,
dass ich gerne
gerne Sachen kopiere.
Das liegt daran.
Das ist kein Passwort oder so.
Das ist, weil ich immer irgendwelche
Buchstaben kopiere.
Weil ich immer
den hier mache.
Ja.
So.
Guck mal jetzt mal fertig hier.
Wenn ich bei ThyssenKrupp starte,
du hast ja vorhin erwähnt,
dass da ein Plan erstellt wird.
Welche Abteilungen beispielsweise
sind denn in der Ausbildung quasi für mich wichtig?
Weil ThyssenKrupp hat ja...
Okay, das ist eine Werbung für ThyssenKrupp.
Gefühlt Logistik, Produktion, Vertrieb, alles.
Was lerne ich kennen in der Ausbildung?
Also, ich bin auch immer ein Freund, weil wir geben ja Support für alle Bereiche hier.
Ganz klar.
Und dass man in der Ausbildung auch irgendwo im Einarbeitungsplan hat,
dass man mal jede Abteilung mal durchlaufen hat.
Thorsten, was verdient man dann in der Ausbildung?
Das finde ich persönlich, muss ich sagen, nur am Rande sinnvoll.
Wir hatten das bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber, war das auch so.
Da sind die Azubis so durch alle Abteilungen durch.
Die haben nichts richtig gelernt in der ganzen Ausbildung.
die haben alles mal ein bisschen gesehen für keine paar wochen bis bis im monat aber am
ende das kannst du mit denen dann auch nichts anfangen wenn die da frisch sind
also das fand ich nicht so sinnvoll
haben sich auch ein paar azubis darüber beschwert
haben auch gesagt sie werden gern bei uns ein bisschen berlinungs zeug machen
Ja, und das ist nur selten möglich gewesen, weil die halt da auch ihren starren Plan hatten mit, du musst überall hin, auch da, wo du gar keinen Bock drauf hast.
Also, fand das nicht so sinnig.
ich meine das macht sicherlich
ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt
mal so im ersten halben Jahr oder vielleicht auch
das erste Jahr über mal
so ganz schnell durchlaufen, dass man mal
alles irgendwie gesehen hat, das ist okay
ja, aber
danach, die nächsten zwei Jahre sollten
wirklich schon
sich auf
mehr oder weniger das gleiche
Gebiet
beziehen, damit man eben auch ordentlich
was lernt, weil am Ende bringt es dir nichts
wenn du alles einmal gesehen hast.
Wie lange schaut man sich denn in der Regel
die anderen Abteilungen an?
Was, was meinst du?
Achso, das kann man, ich finde es
durchaus legitim, solche Sachen zu fragen
im Vorstellungsgespräch,
wie da die Abläufe sind.
Das zeigt ja auch, dass du dich dafür interessierst.
Das finde ich nicht schlimm. Kann man auch fragen.
Kannst ja fragen,
wie das wieder so der Plan ist.
Du hast schon öfters mal gehört, dass die Leute hier verschiedene Abteilungen durchlaufen, wie das so ist, wie lange ist man denn dann pro Abteilung eingeplant und wie geht es danach weiter, wenn man überall mal gewesen ist.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Also für mich wäre das sogar eher ein Pluspunkt, wenn das jemand im Vorstellungsgespräch fragt, weil man sieht, dass der daran interessiert ist, wie es läuft.
Ja, ich finde es auch sinnvoll, dass man sich während der Ausbildung schon spezialisieren ist vielleicht jetzt.
Wir sind das falsche Wort. Ich würde sagen, wenn man hauptsächlich in einem Linux-Team ist, ich würde jetzt, ja man könnte schon sagen, so Linux und drumherum ist eine Spezialisierung, aber es ist ja schon immer noch sehr breit. Es ist vielleicht eins von zwei Möglichkeiten, Windows oder Linux. Da hast du dich halt schon mal auf einen Pfad vielleicht spezialisiert, aber jetzt wirklich nicht so sehr im Detail.
Das finde ich aber auch sinnvoll, zumal ich auch gemerkt habe, dass natürlich wie bei uns, wenn man fertig gelernt ist, ist es bei Azubis aber auch genauso, die haben auch ihre Vorlieben und Sachen, die sie gerne machen und nicht gerne machen.
Wir hatten einen, der fand die ganze IBM Mainframe Geschichte, der Herr Endpunkt bei dabei, der fand die ganze IBM Mainframe Geschichte total spannend und toll. Eine Sache, der ich überhaupt nichts abgewinnen kann. Dafür hat das bei uns so mit Linux Sachen nicht gehabt.
und umgedreht hatten wir aber auch Leute,
die gesagt haben, ey, ich würde gerne viel mehr
Linux machen als Windows. Das konnte ich natürlich
unterschreiben. Da habe ich auch gesagt, ja komm doch,
probieren wir mal, ob wir das nicht irgendwie bei uns
für ein Jahr unterkriegen.
Hat auch bei manchen geklappt, manche waren dann länger bei uns.
Also ich finde, das hat denen auch was gebracht, weil
die konnten danach halt auch was
Linux-technisch.
Weil wenn du deine gesamte Ausbildung nur von
Abteilung zu Abteilung tingelst,
die können mit dir nichts anfangen
und du kannst mit den Sachen nichts anfangen. Am Ende
hast du deine Ausbildung fertig und hast eigentlich von nichts eine richtige Ahnung.
Bei Tussend Group ist es stark abhängig natürlich, welche Branche.
In jeder Branche hat einen eigenen Tarifvertrag.
Wir hier am Standort Mühlheim sind IG Metall Tarifvertrags gebunden.
Aber man kann aber sagen, auf jeden Fall im ersten Ausbildungsjahr
öffnet es über 1000 Euro und natürlich von Jahr zu Jahr steigert sich das.
Wie viel man mittlerweile in der Ausbildung verdient?
Na gut, das kostet ja auch alles doppelt so viel.
Im zweiten, dritten Jahr wird es dann angepasst, das Gehalt.
Das geht dann auch nach oben. Es gibt auch Tarifverhandlungen immer regelmäßig, wo auch mal Einmalzahlungen dazu gewährt werden.
Aber das ist dann immer von Verhandlung zu Verhandlung unterschiedlich.
Im Einarbeitungsplan werde ich ja verschiedene Abteilungen durchlaufen.
Richtig.
Habe ich die Möglichkeit, die Abteilungen heute zu sehen?
Na klar, können wir gerne machen.
Na klar, das habt ihr da sicherlich zum ersten Mal besprochen.
Wir gehen jetzt in die Produktion. Vorher bekommst du natürlich erstmal einen Sicherheitskittel.
Okay.
total spontan war nicht geplant in der produktion sind natürlich die ganzen
anlagen pc gesteuert deine aufgabe wird es sein ganz klar die betreuung der pc
ist vor ort an den anlagen das klingt ja fast schon ein bisschen nach end user
support ruft dann irgendeine an so nach dem motto hier meine mein computer für
die fräsen steuerung von es nicht richtig
das ist quasi end user support bloß noch unter zeitdruck
Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Dann, wir gehen jetzt zum Karsten.
So, jetzt zieh ich mich natürlich auch an.
Da muss ich auch behind the scenes.
Der Karsten. Absichern.
Ah, nee, der Kameramann.
Ich brauch 42, Mann.
Das wird wirklich ein Fruchtzwerg, Alter.
Alter.
Generation Z
speak.
Ah, die guten einen Römer sind da.
So, Outfit completed.
Outfit completed.
Ich bin jetzt in der Produktion und suche den Carsten. Der zeigt mir die ganzen Schnittschnellen mit der IT.
Ist der nur mit Carsten los?
Carsten, moin.
Grüß dich, Erkin.
Zufälligerweise ist er da.
Carsten, ich sehe, wir sind super viele Maschinen, Roboter, Linien nennt ihr auch das Ganze.
Linie, ja.
Kannst du mir erzählen, was das mit der IT zu tun hat?
Ja, klar. Jede einzelne Linie ist mit mehreren IPCs, also Industrie-PCs, gekoppelt.
Das heißt, jedes Modul hat ein IPC und die steuern die ganzen Roboter und die ganzen Abläufe auf diesen IPCs.
Die Software ist installiert und die übernimmt die ganze Kommunikation.
Und ich bin dafür zuständig, dass diese IPCs regelmäßig gewartet werden und funktionieren.
Sollte es zu Problemen kommen, muss ich schauen, dass ich sie schnellstmöglich zum Laufen bekomme.
notfalls ein Backup zurücksichere,
weil wenn ein
IPC ausfällt, steht die ganze
Produktion. Und wenn die Produktion dann
ausfällt, ist das halt immer halt
suboptimal. Das heißt,
miese Zahlen. IPCs hast du genannt.
Ist ja durchaus sinnvoll, auch was zu lernen,
was nicht in der IHK-Prüfung vorkommt.
Du lernst ja nicht für die Prüfung, sondern hast am Ende
was kannst. Wenn das der Bereich ist, der dich
interessiert, der gebraucht wird, warum nicht? Die Prüfung
kriegst du auch so hin. Die IHK-Prüfung
schaffst du ja nicht, weil du auf deiner Arbeit
was gelernt hast. Die AK-Prüfung schaffst du, weil du vor der Prüfung drei, vier Wochen
lang einfach mit alten Prüfungen übst.
Was ist ein IPC?
Ein IPC ist einfach nur Industrie-PC.
Ach so, ja.
Was wird hier hergestellt?
Also wir stellen hier Lenkgetriebe her für renommierte Premium-Marken.
Egal ob Elektrobereich oder halt Verbrenner.
Ein Auto muss halt immer bewegt werden und Lenkgetriebe braucht man halt.
Wir haben halt dafür den Zuschlag bekommen, hier hochwertige Lenketriebe zu fertigen.
Das ist schon eine halbe Jahre Veranstaltung.
Du bist ja auch vom Beruf ITler.
Ja, bin ich.
Wenn die Anlage jetzt eine Störung hat, bist du der Mann dafür?
Ja, wenn halt eine Störung kommt, kommt drauf an, was für eine Störung.
Aber wenn ein Industrie-PC, der die Anlagen hier betreibt, ein Problem hat, werde ich gerufen.
Und dann muss ich schauen, wo liegt der Fehler und natürlich schnellstmöglich Abhilfe schaffen.
notfalls halt ein Backup
zurücksichern, weil
Produktionsstillstand...
Die machen bestimmt keine Backups, sagt er einfach nur.
Na doch,
ich glaube, die haben da schon ganz genaue,
also gerade so Industrie,
Produktion, sowas, die haben da schon
ziemlich genaue, wie nennt man das,
Vorgaben und auch
Sachen, die sie einhalten müssen, also ich gehe mal davon aus.
Ein bisschen wie bei uns,
wo es ja auch sau viel Regulierungen
gibt von Behörden und sonst was,
dass wir...
Finanzmäßig muss das ja alles richtig sein.
Und da ist auch was Backup und Archivierung angeht, gibt es auch ganz genaue Vorgaben.
Da können wir auch nicht sagen, ach ne machen wir nicht, weil wir keinen Bock haben.
Wird sogar unabhängig überprüft teilweise, ob das alles funktioniert und da ist.
Dann weiß man halt, kostet Geld und Zeit ist halt Geld.
Zeit ist Geld, ich hab beides nicht. Der Thorsten wartet auf mich,
der wollte mir noch ein paar Sachen zeigen, deswegen geh ich jetzt zum Thorsten.
Hier siehst du ja, die Kabel, hier kommen die ganzen Netzwerkanschlüsse um in den Büros und teilweise auch in der Fertigung zusammen.
wo das alles kaut und rüben war.
Du siehst, wir sind in einer kleinen Standort,
hier kommt schon einiges zusammen, aber das ist natürlich auch spannend,
da wir auch schön beschriftet haben,
die Kabel, wie man Netzwerke verkabelt,
Routing von Paketen, das kommt hier alles so zusammen.
Und um mal so einen kleinen Einblick zu kriegen, wie das aufgebaut ist,
stehen wir jetzt hier vor einer Netzwerkverkabelung.
Das heißt, diese Netzwerkverkabelungen, die sind alle dann in einem Serverraum?
Richtig, wir sind hier in einem Serverraum,
wo es alles zusammenkommt aus den ganzen Büros.
Das ist jeder Fall und wird dann
auch die einzelnen Komponente dann
verteilt, die Anschlüsse.
Thema Datensicherheit ist auch sehr wichtig,
was das angeht. Datensicherheit, Datenschutz
ist höchste Priorität natürlich bei ThyssenKrupp.
Wer im Chat
hier ist eigentlich Linux-Admin?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Linux-Admin ist mir
zu oldschool. Ich bin Senior
Linux-Engineer, bitteschön.
ja
wenn schon
muss das korrekt sein
ja ich bin aber hier plus 1
das sind einfach nur neue
Bezeichnungen im Prinzip sind die ganzen
DevOps Leute oftmals auch
stink normal Linux oder ehemalige Windows
Admins oder Netzwerk Leute
es klingt einfach geiler wenn man
Linux Engineer ist oder DevOps Engineer
Wunderbar abgesichert, auch schon vom Hauptkonzern her, also da sollte es angreifen.
Also so wirklich viel lernt man da jetzt ja nicht.
Ansonsten habe ich gehört, der Carsten hat noch ein offenes Ticket, sollen wir da mal rüber gehen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Jaira!
Super, mach ich.
Ticket.
Moin Carsten!
Hi Erkin, grüß dich!
Moment, sah der Carsten nicht eben noch anders aus?
Gött, du hast ein Ticket für mich, irgendwas?
dann komm her. Ich geb dir mal den Stuhl, dann setz dich hier hin. Gewicht habe ich so um die 80 Kilo.
Ich habe ein bisschen wenig Sport gemacht in letzter Zeit. Ich war innerhalb von den letzten 14 Tagen nicht mehr Fahrrad fahren, nur einmal joggen.
Dann zeige ich dir mal mit welchem Ticket Tool wir hier arbeiten. Das Ticket Tool ist Key2Help und
Key2Help habe ich noch nie gehört.
Moment, Moment. Das klingt nach irgendwie einem
Softwareanbieter, der gute Marketingleute hat und denen was verkauft hat.
Key to help?
So?
Key.
Ja.
Irgendein Anbieter, der eine gute Marketingabteilung hat.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum es so viele eigene Ticketsysteme gibt, warum man nicht einfach irgendwas benutzen kann, was ein bisschen verbreiteter ist.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir was zum Lästern haben.
Ist das Browser oder Windows-Only-Software, Leute?
Ist das ein Browser?
Oh, Helpline, hör mir auf, Alter.
Helpline ist das schrecklichste Ticketsystem, was ich je gesehen habe.
Ist das Browser? Okay.
Bin nicht so sicher, ob das ein Browser ist, Leute.
Das ist kein Browser, oder?
die haben es ja aufgebläht, ein Ticketsystem.
ServiceNow, ServiceNow kenne ich, das ist, naja, das ist halt bei meisten Unternehmen krass customised und davon hängt es ab, ob es gut oder schlecht ist.
Erstmal auf Wartet auf Ticketsteller umstellen.
Customer erstmal einstellen direkt.
Das ist
eh die beste, beste Taktik,
um nice Ticket-SLA's
zu haben, beziehungsweise einzuhalten.
Ticket bekommen,
Ticket in Bearbeitung stellen,
eine dumme Frage
reinschreiben und direkt wieder
zurück an den Absender Pending Customer.
Und dann hast du Zeit, dir das in Ruhe anzugucken
und hast
0,00001%
krasse SLA-Bearbeitungszeit.
Was? Magst du mir das Ganze zeigen?
Aber klar, RKM, komm, lass mal schauen.
Ich hab dir ja unten gerade schon erzählt,
dass wir Industrie-PCs
verbaut haben.
Es klingt jetzt so, als denke ich mir das aus.
Das macht Microsoft, Oracle und alle anderen
machen das auch. Was meint ihr denn, warum
die ersten Antworten
auf teure Support-Tickets
immer so dämlich sind?
die machen genau das gleiche.
Wenn du bei Google ein Ticket aufmachst,
ist die erste Antwort quasi eine
etwas umgeschriebene
Frage von dir. Also du fragst hier,
warum ist da und da,
keine Ahnung, gibt es Probleme mit Version 1.8
in Kombination
da und damit. So, schreibst du rein,
dann ist die Antwort vom Google Support,
aha, wir sehen,
dass sie bla bla bla
in Version 1.8 einsetzen.
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe, gibt es bei ihnen Probleme in Kombination damit.
Ist das richtig?
So, sowas in der Richtung steht dann da.
Oder haben sie schon in die Knowledge Base geguckt?
Das kriegst du dann als erste Antwort.
Die erste Antwort ist nicht dafür da, dass sie dir wirklich hilft.
Die erste Antwort ist einzig und allein dafür da, dass die SLAs gut aussehen.
Oder eingehalten werden.
Oder sie gute Zahlen verkaufen können.
Als SLAs, ja.
Gute Zahlen verkaufen können.
machen die immer so
und die richtig sinnvolle Antwort
kriegst du meistens nach einem Tag oder sowas
deswegen, warum sollte man das nicht einfach auch so machen
einfach direkt
ich mach das nicht, muss ich gleich dazu sagen
ich versuche tatsächlich die meisten Tickets
wenn ich verstehe, was die wollen
so zu bearbeiten, dass es möglichst schnell durch ist
aber, warum sollte man es
eigentlich nicht auch so machen
erstmal blöde Rückfrage stellen und auf
Pending setzen
Leute, ich hab am Freitag innerhalb von einer Viertelstunde neue Sachen deployed.
Test, Integration und Pre-Production.
In einer Viertelstunde.
Die haben noch nicht mal das Ticket refreshed, bevor das schon fertig war.
Da hab ich hier wieder meine eigenen Sachen nicht befolgt.
Ich hätte es ja erstmal auch auf Pending Customer setzen können.
Es war so schnell bearbeitet, so schnell konnten die gar nicht gucken.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen, ich habe ein bisschen gecheatet.
Ich wusste, dass da jetzt ein Ticket kommt und ich habe mich schon im Vorfeld eingeloggt,
dass das möglichst schnell geht.
äh
God One, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen
dass die Antworten
für Tickets bei Google, Microsoft und so
dass die AI generiert sind
aber dass der eigentliche Ticketbearbeiter
das nochmal durchliest
bevor das abgeschickt wird
leider nicht Production Push
das haben wir nicht gemacht, Pre-Production
Testumgebung, Integrationsumgebung
und manch einer würde es auch Abnahmeumgebung nennen.
Gepusht.
Nicht Produktion, das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Das machen wir nächste Woche.
Die haben auch extra gesagt,
danach, weil ich so schnell war,
ich soll noch warten mit Produktion.
Sie hätten gedacht, das klappt erst nächste Woche.
Sie haben noch gar keine Freigabe für Produktion gehabt.
Tja.
Ist ja auch klar.
Wie sollen sie auch eine Freigabe für Produktion kriegen,
wenn das in den Umgebungen noch nicht drauf war?
Haben sie nicht damit gedacht, dass ich so schnell bin.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Linux-Härtungs-Guidelines?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mir die noch nie angeguckt.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Die beste Härtung ist allerdings immer noch Systeme, nicht ins Internet stellen, die ins
Internet gehören.
Und was nicht lauscht an einem Port kann nicht angegriffen werden.
So mal ganz generell.
Starbucks, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Box Subscription.
Massive Sub.
Ansonsten kenne ich die Härtungsguidelines nicht, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht
Wie findest du das neue Design von Golem?
Ehrlich gesagt gefällt es mir nicht
Das ist so rund teilweise
Und es ist verbuggt
Das Golem Design
Denn
Ich hoffe man kann das auf dem Desktop nachstellen
Das hier oben ist kaputt
Wenn man das umstellt
auf Mobile-Ansicht.
Okay, hier ist es
okay.
Ich habe auf meinem
iPhone das Problem, dass man hier oben die
Warum ist das so groß?
Ich habe aber vom iPhone das Problem, dass ich das hier oben nicht richtig scrollen kann,
dass es kaputt geht, wenn ich das scrolle.
Ich war das auch nur ein temporärer Bug, keine Ahnung.
Ich gucke das Video schnell fertig, geht ja nur noch eine Minute.
Was haben sie da am Start?
Erzählt, dass wir Industrie-PCs verbaut haben in der Linie.
Und hier kannst du dir mal anschauen.
Das ist so ein Industrie-PC.
Also hat nicht viel damit zu tun.
Ist das noch ein DVI-Stecker?
stecker alter nicht mal gesehen
mit dem desktop pc ist die man eigentlich kennen ja die üblichen und
diese pcs werden eigentlich standardmäßig in produktion eingesetzt
weil sie ziemlich robust sind und langlebig und wenn wir die dann so
bestimmt auch schweine teuer darf ich das ja klar schaut das netzteil an
wie ein würfel ja und mit sich ein bisschen aus wie eine gamecube sagt er das was ja
wirklich nicht wirklich viele gamecube aller ich muss blau das betriebssystem installiert
worden ist und ich alles geprüft habe ob die software sowie sie bestellt worden ist vorhanden
ist dann schreibe ich hier rein was ich getan habe das in den request in ganz ehrlich klingt
überhaupt nicht sonderlich spannend was sie da gerade zeigen ja ticket bearbeitung standard
Software irgendwie drauf, so Residenz
Lieber. Bearbeitung,
schreibe rein, dass die Installation durchgelaufen
ist, wie gewünscht, alles fertig.
Dann beende ich den Service-Request.
Ich könnte mir so Windows-Administration
und Software-Verteilung und so Kram, ich könnte mir das
null vorstellen. Das klingt so
so, oh,
da kriege ich, da würde ich
Bauchweh beikriegen, wenn ich das jeden Tag machen
müsste. Vor allem, weil ich mich da jeden
Tag mit Windows auseinandersetzen muss,
würde ich echt Anfälle kriegen.
Und der User, der den Service-Request aufgegeben hat, wird automatisch per Mail informiert,
dass das Ticket abgeschlossen ist und der wird dann mit mir einen Termin vereinbaren,
wenn er den Rechner dann abholt und dann können wir dieses Ticket schließen und sind fertig.
Super, ich bedanke mich.
Ja, Erkin, hat mir viel Spaß gemacht.
Mir auch, vielen, vielen Dank.
Genau, gerne, jederzeit.
Ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen Feierabend.
Dir auch, okay, ciao.
endlich feierabend acht stunden bei tis group als fachinformatiker für system
integration mein persönliches fazit ich fand eigentlich viel war da jetzt aber
nett oder echt cool ich habe das ein bisschen eintöniger erwartet dass ich
den ganzen tag nur im büro sitzt winter pool das frage ich mich auch ich frage
mich bei sowas immer also machen die das wirklich so manuell alles oder machen
die das jetzt nur zum zeigen alles manuell
weil eigentlich würde man davon ausgehen, du schließt sowas an,
wählst irgendwo vielleicht noch aus, was das für ein PC-Typ sein soll
und dann wird alles automatisch gemacht.
Zum zeigen, ja.
So, mal gucken, was mein Arch-Dinux sagt, ob ich neue Packages kriege.
Ich habe heute Morgen schon geupdatet, aber...
Ha!
Dachte ich mir.
Arch Deluxe ist halt so aktuell,
da kannst du mehrfach am Tag aktualisieren.
By the way.
So.
Nochmal Reboot.
Macht keinen Sinn.
Wutnix Kernelmäßig ist aktuell,
aber ich reboote trotzdem nochmal.
Beta Distro.
Ja.
Pleading Edge Distro.
Aber beste, by the way.
Arsch.
Mal gucken, ob meine YouTube-Empfehlungen
mittlerweile besser geworden sind.
Dass auch irgendwas empfohlen wird, was...
Ja, das haben wir schon vor Ewigkeiten
geguckt.
Haben wir schon anders geguckt.
Was ist das?
What the fuck?
Microsoft vs. Salesforce
und dann sieht man da irgendwelche
Cricket-Dinger. What?
YouTube, was geht ab, Alter?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Die YouTube-Empfehlungen sind schon recht wild teilweise.
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt.
Ich war jetzt 4 Stunden 11 on.
gehe ich off.
Muss mal aufs Klo.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid
und das besonders ausführliche Aufwachen
streamt.
Ihr hört uns.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.